[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my God
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
there it is a smile she clinches the
match What a Feeling to win a match for
your team welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives five he checks first is
light checks a little triangulation
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
yes Chelsea's gonna win it Chelsea's
gonna win it
and Pablo has won it Pablo has won it
wow
happy Wednesday everybody and welcome to
the pro chess League two incredibly
exciting matches for you today as usual
I'm your host Grandmaster Daniel
narditsky alongside me today once again
it is a pleasure to be commentating with
International Master Tanya sajdev Tanya
it's morning for me it's late in the
afternoon for you but I think we're both
excited to watch some chess
Ryan we have an incredible day of just
coming up ahead and saying that I'm
excited would just not cut it we started
the protest league with 16 teams the aim
was clear three wins takes you to the
playoffs three losses and you're out
we're down to 15 teams
sorry about the elimination of your team
the Charlotte cobras and I know it was a
tough loss
it was a tough loss but hey it's the
protest League Happy Days for some teams
sad days for others here are the top of
the standings you can see the Indian
yogis and the levitov Chester's who are
facing off today at 2-0 if they win one
more match they are in to the playoffs
some teams are one and one such as
Magnus Carlson's team the Canada chest
cross and Tanya thanks for reminding me
they're Sean range in particular there
is one team the Charlotte cobras and
unfortunately lost yesterday's match I
was not able to play I was traveling to
be completely honest I'm kind of glad I
didn't get internet on the plane
laughs
absolutely as you're mentioning it's
really a big day uh Daniel with Indian
yogis and the laptop chess Wizards
facing each other these are the two of
the four teams that are on 100 score
right now there's so much at stake one
of them will punch their ticket into the
playoff uh they have been the best
performers at the protest league so far
and it's tough It's a tough one to pick
a favorite in this one uh because we've
got to take a look at just their rosters
that the two teams have got with them
and we also have the week three
standings of the other teams Daniel
yeah you can see the Charlotte Cobra is
the only team that has thus far been
eliminated some teams are on the brink I
think the most surprising uh element of
these standings is the St Louis
archbishops which has won the protest
league in the past they have an
incredibly strong team but they have
lost both of their first two matches and
I think what we're seeing is that it's
really not about which team has the most
Super GMS it's all about which team has
the most well-assembled roster that
seems to be a lot more important than
the average uh rating but all of that is
in the past Charlotte cobras will
regroup today we have two other very
exciting matches for you we will start
with the levitov chest Wizards uh
against the Indian yogis this is one of
the most hyped matches that we've had
thus far in the PCL and then later today
we will have the Garden State passers
taking on the Canada chest press
super big day here at the protest League
we've been talking about getting to that
eight and a half Point Victory and today
it's not just the match win but making
it to the playoffs that stay and The
Wizard they've had a brilliant
performance so far as well as the yogis
but let's not forget uh Daniel last week
the yogis barely survived their match
against the Kanda chess bras uh
meanwhile of course the Garden State
passes with James Canty III and the
chess bra team are going to be looking
at their at their journey to make it to
the playoffs I am super excited to kick
off today uh and what do you think one
of them makes it to the topic to the
playoffs which one is it gonna be will
it be the levitov or the yogis
both of them have demonstrated just
incredible play in the first two weeks
and speaking of incredible play let's
look at the players who've made that
incredible play happen for the levitop
chess Wizards you can see a certain guy
named Daniel dubov on the photo there he
is making an appearance today it is his
first protest League appearance of the
Season as if they needed any other
reinforcements uh Alexis Ralph momentov
all of these names are incredibly
Familiar shimana of lazovic I mean look
at these names Tanya it's just amazing
Daniel dubov is the most creative
is absolutely inimitable he plays for
the fans Daniel he plays to the
galleries he's making his debut in the
season this in today's matchup so I'm
super excited to see what Innovative
opening ideas he comes to and of course
we've got Valentina who's also been a
strong player for the lavator of Chess
wizard I mean look at their roster there
are so many Grand Masters so many big
names and we've seen it in their
performance so far in the protest League
and speaking of big names the yogis have
some big names as well they've got a
roster assembled of the very top Indian
players Vida Gujarati is not able to
play today but uh frog Nanda is as well
as his sister vaishali who has been an
integral piece of the Yogi's success
thus far of course nihal Saran is a
crowd favorite and he is part of the
team as well so these two teams um when
I say that they're evenly matched they
really are evenly matched and uh it's I
mean it's a toss-up it's total toss-up
it's super hard to to pick a favorite
and this matchup that we've got coming
up and as you're mentioning today's
theme is so young we've got Prague who's
leading from the front now even though
he's just all of 17 years old it's hard
to go by his age because he has so much
experience in his online chess format
where we've seen him really hold his own
in the Champions chess store as well and
it would be easy for the captains so you
know Daniel just go with the top four we
know that the protestly one of the most
exciting features of it is the lineup
rules they've got to follow the rules
when they put out the roster when they
put out their players for each match
you're exactly right and here you see
some of the key features of the lineup
rules every team must include at least
one female player there is a total
rating average cap of 25.50 but players
over 2700 count as 2700 So Magnus
Carlson counts as 2700 that encourages
more Super GMS and players under 2200
count as 2200 and women over 23.50 count
as 23.50 in the levitov chest wizards of
course have two of the strongest female
players in the world's gunina and
castenoke and on that note let's kick
off our first match of the day the
levitov chest Wizards and the Andean
yogis are going to face off it's a
complete and total toss-up as we look at
the board assignments dubov is making
his PCL appearance for the first time
timeout
and so we see yeah
yeah it's really interesting as we see
that our board assignments of today now
Danny let's do a little Deep dive into
this we see on board one three and four
at least rating wise it looks like the
levittoff Jazz Wizards have an upper
hand compared to the Indian yogis we've
got Prague vaishali and pranesh on board
one three and four but on board two
actually nehal strings the one who's
with a higher rating that's that also
let's point out that these ratings are
in fact the ones that were there in
November there have been a lot of huge
jumps and changes with the players the
one that stands out is that fourth board
that you see for the Indian yogis it
says
not an image
and in fact has just become a grand
master about a month ago winning the
Wilton Cup in style India's 79th Grand
Master so even though in front of our
screens he is currently the fourth board
do not be fooled by that rating he's
currently 2500.
that's great Insight Tanya his GM
application is open but will obviously
be approved and the laptop chesswords is
they've got four grand Masters but as
you're saying International masters
Grand Masters everybody is capable of
impacting a PCL match and we will see
who the X factors are going to be I
think pernicious performance is going to
be crucial I'm on the same page Dania
the players are on the same page the
gong has sounded to the matches kicked
off and pranesh is facing off against
the chess Wizards board one Daniel dubov
as they enter a rue Lopez what's been
really interesting about these two teams
has been the mix-up of their player
lineup every week Daniel every week they
come out with a new team to play and
that is such a smart strategy because
you're really able to see the
performance and the form of each of the
players on your roster now this is
pronation's first game in the protest
League he's up against Daniel dubov and
I'll tell you one more thing about
pronage openings have definitely been
something that he's struggled with he's
very strong in the middle game and the
end game so this is going to be
interesting to see who wins the opening
battle here because we know dubov he's
definitely someone who likes
unconventional territory and I see the
position on our board it's something we
see very often in the Royal Pass
no we do not and in particular I think
Knight B to D2 which we just saw is a
relatively rare line normally you see
white capturing on E5 and often that is
followed by a queen trade on the
turn tonight back to D7 supporting the
995 so the Queens I think are likely to
stay on the board in fact they are going
to stay on the board guaranteed that's
music to my ears Tanya
well and I see this move but pranesh
you're talking about the queen staying
on the board absolutely agree with that
it means it's going to be a fun middle
game very often we do see the d-line
being opened up for that Queen trade and
the move A5 this Pawn advance in the
queen side a very thematic idea here and
the point is that you disconnect Black's
a pawn and the B Pawn and what happens
with that often is that the B4 Pawn can
become a weakness in do Bob's cap but
you know what Dubose made his intentions
pretty clear he's saying pranesh I don't
care about these weaknesses I'm keeping
the Queens on the board because I want a
middle game fight Daniel duboff a huge
favorite in this one he knows this is a
tough match he needs to get those points
in
I think we've seen two common patterns
in a lot of the PCL matches both of
these sound like cliches but obviously
your board one needs to have a big
performance I haven't seen a single PCL
match one where the board one scores two
out of four or less and if you're board
four can score one upset or more that
gives you an incredibly Big Boost so I
think that's what should be going
through pranesha's mind right now this
is a growth mindset kind of game
nobody's expecting him to go four out of
four but if you can get a draw here
maybe even a win there that's going to
make a huge positive impact Knight takes
E5 is on the board I think Daniel is
going to recapture it with his Knight
Tanya and if white plays F4 prematurely
that could run into Bishop G4 so white
needs to tread very very carefully here
because his pieces are kind of clogged
up in the center
and coming in the way of its own pieces
and that's why Bishop G4 was such a
massive threat easy to miss that the
queen had no squares which is why we see
furnish taking the decision to fall back
with the Knight to make sure that if you
go with the bishop he has the option to
push that pawn to F3 and start attacking
the bishop he's opening up his own
bishop and C1 for development knight
from F1 is headed to E3 because it wants
to get to the center to the D5 Square
indeed in the middle game I think is
about equal the position is stabilized
and that affords us a good opportunity
to go back to our bird's eye view and
check out some of the other games
because two other games are now in
progress vaishali uh is facing dropstone
DP that is davidparabians chess.com
handle and of course Dennis llazovic is
squaring off against nihal sarens the
top right there Tanya we're seeing
paravian against vaishali that looks
like a Karo Khan where white has the
bishop pair and the lower left board has
just begun as well
is a huge scorer for the Levitt officer
it's so far he's raked up six points out
of a possible eight for his team so
that's definitely a board that is very
important for the Wizards and as we've
been pointing out in here in the bottom
left we can see a lot of moves have
happened but it looks like the position
is pretty evil evil it will become evil
at some point but it's pretty level for
now while on the top left board it
continues with the Queens on the board I
think so far it looks like each of the
boards Daniel everything is pretty sane
and normal for both white and black but
it's the vaishali board that catches my
eye and I would I think we should just
jump straight into it we're seeing a lot
of Trades there that have happened and
uh quite a wild Pawn structure
yeah and I was misled this Pawn
structure sometimes happens in the
tartica OR Cairo uh in reality this came
from a Petrov so David paravian playing
a Petrov really not minding a draw I
think with the black pieces and that is
where the game is heading vaishali has
traded another pair of minor pieces
she's up a D4 Pawn but I think black
does have enough compensation there on
the king side Tanya F7 F5 is a dangerous
move because it threatens to open the f
file this game could fizzle out I think
into a draw pretty quickly
it very well I think vaishali might
still want to try a little bit as you're
pointing at F5 was very important to try
to create that counter play against the
pawn that David paravian has lost where
white can also think about bringing her
own Rooks into the game where Charlie
can potentially double up on the a file
or bring it to the open e-file but I
love the idea of going Brook A1 Rook A7
really trying to Target your king as
well vaishali has a different approach
she wants to trade off more pieces the
more pieces that eliminated I think we
get closer to the draw
yeah I mean queen takes out five right
now essentially gives white a risk-free
position but
thank you
are terribly realistic Tanya that's
because of two main reasons first of all
the king Side Pawn structure is going to
be quite weak uh and second of all David
parabian has very active pieces you're
going to find it very very difficult to
get this d-pawn past to D5
that's a really great Point Daniel and
King on G1 open it's hard to imagine
that happen as well perhaps she wants to
trade on her own terms and wants to
improve the pawn structure while doing
that so move like Queen to G4 saying
that if you trade Queens I not only
improve my Pawn structure but then
create better winning Chances with the F
Pawn and the g Pawn connected slowing
down Daniel I think that's the trade
that she's looking at on the G4 Square
well she senses that this is an
important moment that Queen takes that
five can guarantee her at least a draw
but an upset win in round one would be
such a huge boost for the yogis I agree
I think she should go Queen G4 she could
also consider King G2 trying to say okay
I'm Gonna Keep My Pawn structure but
you're gonna have to help my king get
active and get toward the center not
obviously a trade of Rooks in uh that
ensuing end game would be squarely in
White's favor and a great move bye-bye
Charlie she plays King G2 David pravian
still has over 10 minutes on the clock
but I do think that he's got to tread
carefully if he wants to ensure half a
point here
I like that move King to G2 but I'm just
worried that can black actually now just
decline a queen trade and say that your
king is in the open it's you know you
don't have that pawn shield in front of
it I'm gonna decide to keep the queens
and actually fall back with the queen to
either to E6 or D7 or just any Square
where you can keep the queen still on
the board and that might put the
pressure on vaishali to again try to
keep her King safe well Charlie this
match this round is actually the third
seeded player for the Indian yogis
usually we see her play on board four
and this is a big one for her against
David paravian so far she's scored three
and a half points out of a possible
seven for the Indian yogis she's been a
solid board and it's a great start with
the white pieces Bishop to E7 and still
go ahead with the trade on F5 or the
other idea Queen to G4 but now don't
forget notice that King on G2 Queen G4
might allow a check on D5
Queen G4 might allow that check and the
last thing you want to do is lose the
pawn on Z4 the last thing you want to do
is take any unnecessary risk because the
draw is a very reasonable result for my
shot and as she Ponders uh ways to keep
the initiative going and keep that extra
Pawn alive we go back to the bird's eye
view because some of the other games are
reaching a very very interesting point
top left we still have that same Pawn
structure two minor pieces a piece that
looks relatively balanced maybe even a
slightly uh more pleasant position for
pranesh I'm looking at the bottom right
though Tanya where we have a very
unbalanced Pawn structure in Valentina
goon in his game against prognananda
white has the bishop here white has
damaged kingside Pawn structure but it's
hard to say it's hard to evaluate that
position so let's take a closer look who
would you rather be playing here
say that I'm liking what rights
compensation for the destroyed Bond
structure and that is because I am very
biased towards the bishop pair and also
the fact that the G line is open you
constantly have to watch out for
sacrifices on that tender G6 spot yes
currently it's guarded by those two
pawns but it's something that you have
to make sure that you've got enough
pieces around your king and look at what
Prague has done he immediately strikes
in the center with the move F4 and I
like this because it comes with a
devious trick Daniel now you might be
thinking of a possibility to push that
pawn to E4 to block that Bishop on D3 no
more sacrifices on G6 but I think after
E4 what Prague wants to do is actually
capture that pawn with his knife notice
how the bishop on B4 hangs so if black
takes the Knight on e4 you pick up
Black's Bishop on B4 meanwhile after
Knight E4 if proc captures on D2
Valentina can actually pick up on D2 and
I just realized that Valentina is the
one who's playing with white in my head
I thought it was Prague who was white I
love valentina's position here with no
E4 coming up I think she's done all the
right things with the bishop capturing
the G file oh but she just took back on
see-through with the pawn and I'm really
not sure about that decision that
introduces I think unnecessary
weaknesses to her Queen Side Pawn stroke
I really didn't see a reason why white
couldn't take back on C3 with the bishop
if we bring up an analysis board what's
the key difference in these two captures
well after Bishop takes C3 if black
closes the center with E4 white drops
the bishop back to E2 and white is now
ready to reopen the dark Squad Bishop
with D5 even if black plays C6 why could
very well consider sacrificing the
d-pawn and getting that diagonal open
instead if we go back to the live board
look at that Bishop on D2 it now has no
prospects it's hemmed in by its own
pawns and I'm pretty shocked at
valentina's decision there I think that
does give black a pretty comfortable
position it's very strange Daniel you
double your own pawns you know you've
already got one double pawns on the king
side you don't need another pair on the
queen side and you also block that
Bishop on D too so making sure truck
gets that E4 blocks that Bishop on D3
but now those double Bishop pair that
I've been screaming about just doesn't
feel as strong as it was Valentina wants
to continue the pressure she does a rook
lift also eyeing to get the other Rook
to the G file Prague calmly and coldly
just sidesteps I'm not seeing an attack
but black has to watch out for an F5
break at all times even if it means a
pawn sacrifice it could be super
dangerous for Black's King side
yeah it could black has to be incredibly
Vigilant but again I think the story
revolves around the dark squared Bishop
if that Bishop was on C3 it would be a
different story The contribution of that
Bishop to the attack would make the
attack largely Unstoppable now in
response to F5 I think Prague could
either move the queen back because G6 is
so well protected or he could even
potentially capture on F5 and bring a
rook to G8 and a trade a mass trade of
Brooks here I think would squarely favor
Black so the more this game continues
the more I think Valentina is going to
regret that decision to recapture on C3
with her Bishop but still plenty of
Chess left to be played Tanya as she
brings her Queen back to D1 potentially
preparing maybe bishop G4 but then
you're gonna have to reckon with the
weakness of the C4 Pawn
it's a very strange decision that
Valentina made with capturing on C3
doubling up the pawns when it was so
much more natural to take it with the
bishop keeping the pawn structure
activating the dark Squad Bishop just
visualize this exact position with the
bishop on C3 on that diagonal of A1 to
h8 that would be a huge Advantage but it
looks like Valentina has got a tunnel
vision right now she wants to get all
her pieces to the king side she wants to
get that F5 break in Queen G2 F5 she's
eyeing that G7 Square once the G file
opens up as well and it's still far far
from over and she's still exerting a lot
of pressure on the Queens on the king
side
agreed completely I think practically
speaking as you see prognon on this
clock start to dip down below five
minutes a lot of attacking chances here
for white so let's go back to uh the
bird's eye view because some of the
other games uh have been progressing we
still have that pawn up end game in
vaishali's game against David parabian
she's managed to push her Pawn to D5 so
there's no doubt in my mind that by
shali is the one attempting to win that
game she's not quietly going to agree to
a draw she's going to torture black
while she has the chance
completely agree now this is a position
on the top right where white is playing
for two results and that's quite a big
start for where Charlie who is both
three today for the Indian yogis but the
board that catches my attention is on
our top left take a look at that eval
bar it is creaming for pranesh saying
that white is doing super well in the
position I see that dubov has gone for
another very creative outcome after the
opening the H Pawn is already down the
board with H5 but it can be a big
weakness and Daniel should we do a deep
dive into that one because it's
exploding
it's exploding and it might not be
exploding in Black's favor and as we go
to that game as most people already know
um I am traveling these next two days so
I was aware that there were some uh
lagging issues hopefully uh it resolves
itself but
um again doing doing the very best that
I can you know I have a a job that's
hard to do when you're traveling but
um I'll be doing my best hopefully the
issues uh won't be too distracting but
Daniel Dua might be distracted by
something because he's got 90 seconds on
his clock Tanya he's just taken on A5
and that's a pretty devilish move he
threatens potentially a smothered maid
with Queen B6 and Knight F2 but it feels
like if white makes an accurate move or
two black might fall apart here maybe H3
is what the doctor ordered to create a
little hole for the King on H2
wow that is such an incredible idea that
you're pointing out because let's say
you try to trade on A5 after Rook A5
black will have the additional option of
doing the Intermezzo check on B6 and now
you're forced to step with your king to
F1 because King H1 we've got to point it
out we never get chances to play out as
modded mate on the board Daniel we've
got to do it
but there's no smell they're made here
actually even if the King goes to H1 and
that's the sad thing for black even if
you go through the motions you give a
check on G1 and then you give a
Checkmate on it oh there's no mate on F2
because the queen is guarding that
square so black doesn't even have that
but Tanya I don't think white should
even allow the check on F2 and get his
hands dirty I think the simple H3 would
eradicate all of Black's attacking
chances because after Queen B6 King H1
Knight F2 check the king slides up to H2
it's a beautiful hiding square there's
no check on G4 and the king is safe but
instead pranesh has opted for another
defensive move and it's not even really
a defensive move it's an aggressive move
and it takes the B6 square away from
Black's Queen I like this as well I like
this a lot H3 was very subtle but Queen
D4 you centralize your queen and you
take away your opponent's active Chances
with any check you pointed out that
there was no small that made in that
position but it could be a problem later
on
decides to steal that opportunity to
decline that Rook trade but A6 that
weakness can now be snapped up The Rook
can jump again not only picking up the
pawn but also defending his own Pawn on
C6
you're exactly right dubo now falls
under a minute H3 is on the board the
Knight is forced back to age six no goes
back to F6 I thought dubuff might try to
reroute it to F5 white is unquestionably
winning here white is winning but
pranesh has to stay accurate and dubov
is so so tricky what captures your eye
China
yeah just the whole position I'm
and I mean that could potentially be a
huge upset pronation it is the fourth
board for the Indian yogis playing
against the first Port against Daniel
dubov and this 17 year old we can see
the eval bars screaming but still there
is work to be done to actually convert
this position you're pointing out the
rerouting of the bishop to D3 falling
back with the bishop to D3 but there are
so many ideas that you have to look at
what happens if black actually captures
on C6 you want to Target the beef what
happens
I think the simplest there would have
been to trade Rooks and take on B4 but
maybe that wasn't satisfactory for
pronounce she won something a little bit
more convincing he goes Rook to D1 which
I really like as well now if black takes
on C6 which I think is likely white can
choose between the simple option to
trade and then to take on D6 and
stabilize the material advantage or
alternatively you could move your Rook
up to the seventh Rank and go for
tactical ideas related to the F7 Pawn I
don't think furnace should do that I
think you should keep it simple and he
does takes on C6 he's got a big time
Advantage he now has a stable extra Pawn
he should be able to capitalize but
Tanya how many games have we seen in
which the board 4 starts getting nervous
and even chokes and loses some of these
quote unquote unusable positions way too
many and Daniel dubov is one player
make sure
most of all his chances and you're
pointing it out as you're saying it's
happening a check on E3 you move your
king you pick up that pawn on F4 there
are all these ideas of Knight jumping
into the game if you go King H1 white E4
looks super scary and Daniel dubov has
done it one more time just creative
resourceful play and it looks like
pranesh is the one who needs to be a
little careful right now
he got too greedy pranesh could have
dropped his Queen back to F2 and kept
all his pawns defended instead he's
allowed the check on E3 Tanya I'm sure
he expected dubov to take on C2 instead
as you're pointing out the Knight is
jumping into E4 and this is suddenly a
three result game just because of this
check black is going to develop Furious
attacking chances on White's King but
can dubov make all of this happen with
only 18 seconds a rookie one a
well-placed move by pranesh now Queen
takes F4 there are tactics with a
discover check by the bishop where
should dubov go with his Knight Knight
F2 Knight G3 I don't know what to do
he's got five seconds he might not be
able to figure this out he needs to make
a move and he makes them with barely any
time on the clock he gives a check
because if you go back to G1 Black's
Knight will pick up that pawn on H3 with
a check a double check at that so it's
just a complete mess this position
because the line can continue with white
skin stepping up to H2 and it is just
really tough to understand what's going
on if you go King H2 black can pick up
the F4 Pawn with the check Daniel dubov
down to four seconds on the clock and a
complete mess on the board
oh my goodness and this is the most
interesting game I'm keeping an eye on
by Charlie's end game but let's stick to
this pivotal game for now like you said
a win by pranesh would be a massive
upside we've seen this happen a couple
of times in the PCL so far the queen
steps into G3 the threat is Knight takes
H3 check and Tanya Duba won't just
deliver a Perpetual he might actually go
for it with the Knight takes up four
panash is now dropping on the clock
maybe Knight H1 no he takes on F4 oh
there's no Bishop F7 because the queen
captures oh that's a nice tactic you do
have your queen picking it up so you
don't lose it King goes to King goes to
F1 Queen F4
wow two seconds he goes for it he's
going for it he's down upon but it is
Daniel Dubois who wants to play for the
win but he does have the people I don't
think it's much going for it Daniel
because you still don't have another
piece into the attack and that is it
this game ends in a draw it is a huge
result for pranesh but Daniel he's got
to be a little upset that he could not
convert it oh without question I think
he's going to be upset but I also think
he was calm he didn't do anything rash
and half a point squeezed from the top
board is still a big result for the
yogis all three of the other games are
still going they are all heating up
simultaneously bottom right you can see
a lot of moves being made and gunana is
struggling with that dark squared Bishop
vaishali is trying to squeeze out that
end game advantage against David
paravian it doesn't appear that she'll
be successful but let's have a look as
that game reaches its climax because
vaishali now has two past pawns and
let's see if David paravian can hold
half a point in that game
this is looking very dangerous for black
for David here because you can't pick up
the D6 Pawn the white Bishop jumps on to
C5 pinning that Rook on D6 and winning
it so currently black can't pick up that
pick up that pawn so he can step up to
G8 first with the King hit that rook and
then start threatening to pick up the
pawn on D6 is that something that David
can do move that King to G8 and then
pick up the pawn on D6
I actually think you can maybe get away
with Rook takes T6 I'm not totally sure
Bishop C5 you can meet that with King G8
I actually think that's what David is
calculating and you're absolutely right
he starts with King G8 okay now where is
vaishali going to go with her Rook Rook
to H6 looked like an interesting try I
think after F4 vaishali has to be
careful not to lose this game I know
that sounds crazy but Tanya if black is
able to play G4 and those pawns start
rolling white could get checkmated there
wow you're talking about a mating attack
and vaishali has to defend against that
in just five seconds she falls back and
as you're mentioning G4 right now is not
possible she keeps it defended she stops
black from pushing G4 G4 by putting
pressure on the F4 pawn bishop to E5 by
Charlie's playing oh no seconds right
now G4 looks very scary he's playing for
a win G4 and white has to sacrifice her
Bishop on F4 and get rid of Black's last
remaining Pawn but that's such a hard
move to play with five seconds David
could draw the game immediately with
Rook takes D6 but he goes for and he's
threatening Jackman he's gonna win oh my
God he's going to win
this option where the Rook could have
slid down to G7 given a check picked up
that pawn on G4 and now David's Jeep on
lives and this will be the decider it
looks like David's had a massive turn
around but I think vaishali still got
some idea she wants to trade this Pawn
off she goes rookie four and she's is
she gonna go she just keeps The Rook on
the seventh rank Black's King is stuck
on h8
fantastic resourcefulness bye-bye
Charlie but Tanya if I'm honest I think
the problem isn't that vaishali won't
get rid of the pawn I think she might I
think in the ensuing position though
David can squeeze a rook and Bishop
versus Rook which is one of the most
notoriously difficult end games to draw
when you've got just a couple of seconds
left so I think vaishali might even be
able to get rid of the pawn but can she
draw the ensuing end game that's what
I'm doubtful of and she just allowed G3
no I mean now you're not getting rid of
that Bond ever once that bond gets to G3
that pawn is going to live till the end
of time here Daniel but you made a
really good point that Rook Bishop was
his Rook is one of those end games that
I can never defend and yet I can also
never win them it's so hard when you're
playing on seconds I always seem to be
the one who comes up with the worst kind
of defenses in that F5 this is getting
crazy now whoa whoa whoa whoa
he should have kept the bishop on the B8
G3 diagonal I'm not sure why he got it
at age six now vaishali might be able to
get Rook to G6 but she's gonna flag she
flagged
or did she oh my God yeah we saw David
and he's she flagged she flagged my gosh
and even David does it looks like he
can't quite believe what just happened
yeah it looked like the server Yeah by
Charlie lags and I think her internet
might have lagged out there but I don't
think she would have saved that anyway
Tanya I mean two seconds left and she's
down a bishop what a heartbreaker there
by vaishali we've got two games still in
progress a likely draw between lazovic
and Negal and that means the gun in a
game is going to be really really
crucial
super important for both these themes
and vaishali they're a heartbreaking
result but there's so much positive to
take from there as well it was a big
fight uh Daniel we've got to rush to our
games the players are playing on second
and we see Valentina there in this
position she picks up the G6 Pawn but
Prague the Knight he's got an extra Pawn
on the queen side the Knight is going to
jump around notice how white spawns are
fixed on the light squares which makes
it impossible for the king to defend
them the Knight is coming into E5 your
king can't go to D3 anymore to save that
pawn and I think 95 just picks up the
second Pawn for Prague ah man these are
two heartbreaking games for the chess
Wizards Valentina had a great position
out of the opening in this one too and
vaishali she had a rook Bishop in three
against Rook Bishop in two but she led
those pawns through and we just see how
hard it can be to handle the position in
time pressure these GMS are so tricky
they'll find winning chances in
literally any position this one's over
though time you mean all black has to do
is just push these pawns forward and
fantastic time management for Prague
who's got 40 seconds to figure out the
winning process here that's a very
confident win by him and as you're
mentioning not just a position on the
board but the clock as well and he plays
with a lot of speed he keeps the
pressure up on the clock the white there
is no counter Play No passes at all
Prague has a clear idea to advance the
pawns right now he needs to fall back
with the Knight as it was attacked you
can never trade off the bishop for the
night that is a lost King Pawn end game
this is going to be an Indian Yogi's
game while vaishali lost so Prague the
power siblings of the Chess World
they've got each other's back
they do and they're probably playing
from the same location looks like
prague's internet is okay for the time
being and he's left himself with enough
time uh to survive a potential lag he's
getting the king to C5 and he's going to
eliminate another punt I think it's only
a question of when Valencia resigns this
one she's gonna go down three pawns and
Brock could also just promote his Queen
side pawns he can play C3 whenever he
wants to now would be a pretty good time
to do that I think C3 and C4 this is
basic Betty
you called it it's on the board and
everything stuff can just even pick up
the H5 Pawn gives a check and we'll go
on to pick up that pawn you he's a
million coupons up right now it is a
good time to resign but it is you know
you're playing on seconds you want to
keep that team uh Team feeling alive so
I can't understand Valentina continuing
the position till the very end
even without any of the a pawns this
would be totally winning I would just oh
and there goes the bishop that I think
will be the strong that breaks the
camel's back and a big big win a big win
by Prague there who survives a dubious
middle game position and B take C3 in
the early middle game that is going to
do Valentina in we've got one game
remaining it's not going to be remaining
for very long it is a well-known
theoretical draw called the Philadelphia
position and Dennis has just admitted
the inevitable but okay I'm getting
worried they're about the clock and
about the potential lag issues
and this is Elementary staff ending at
the
backside the king just maintains up
and with that what an exciting round one
of this anticipated match up Daniel it
is it ends with a level score 2-2
I think that is the fairest score we
could possibly ask for because there
were some missed opportunities Tanya for
both sides pernesh let's applaud him for
drawing Daniel dubov that is a result to
be proud of he did have a potentially
winning position but man these top guys
they they weasel out of everything the
most frustrating player for the yogis a
frustrated player is going to be
vaishali who doesn't manage to draw that
end game but her brother ragnananda had
her back and nothing has been decided
after round one time
wow what around this was
we expect out of the two best performing
teams of the protest league so far and
we've got three more games coming up
it's gonna be a fun one
three more rounds and fascinating new
matchups do not go anywhere you're
watching the pro chess League this is
our first match of the day and we will
have the second round of that match
coming up for you in just a couple of
short minutes
[Music]
foreign
to our new video lecture series here
with the one and only the 14th World
chess champion vishwanathon and on if
you have to explain that you're world
champion and it's taking longer than two
words there's something wrong with the
adventure
but I believe in when we're talking in
the 60s and 70s even the 80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where I
was trying to tone it down
uh not get very excited and also I had
not had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um
we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
with it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the pro chess League the
first match of the day features the
Indian yogis and the levitov chess
Wizards and their first round has ended
in a 2-2 time nothing has been decided
yet so make sure your seat belts are
still fastened we are going to review
the round two lineups alongside
International Master Tanya sajdev Tanya
we could not have asked for a more
entertaining start and for a more
entertaining set of round two matchups
I couldn't agree more with that I mean
we had a level score in round one but
the games were just full of fireworks we
had two draws and punches being traded
on the vaishali and the Prague board and
of course the day is just getting
started we're just getting things going
as we enter into round two where Charlie
took a tough loss in round one where she
got flagged could have been a lag on her
side playing on seconds a difficult
position to defend she's against Daniel
dubov life doesn't get easier for
vaishali right now
the pro Chesley can be so brutal you
lose a painful game here you have the
black pieces against the opposing teams
board one and an angry boy one because
Daniel dubuff will want to assert
himself this is his first PCL appearance
and he will want to score his first PC
of Victory sooner rather than later
Prague he's got the white pieces against
the ultra solid Dennis lazovic I think
that's a big X Factor game Tanya Ken
Prague step up and deliver his second
consecutive win
wow these are two teenagers playing
against each other so
dubov he definitely wants to
stay on one I think he'd be relieved
with surviving that one against pranesh
it looked like at some point it was
going to not go his way he was worse but
some creative ideas resourcefulness so
that came end in a draw and we've got
liftoff Daniel against vaishali starts
with the Queen spawn opening
okay let's see whether vishali takes on
C4 nope she opts for the Queen's Gambit
decline but this could morph into a
bunch of other related openings like the
rokozen but dubov he opts for a
relatively rare move of course Knight C3
there is the main line instead he
develops his Queen's Bishop first then
secures it with E3 and he's actually
delaying Tanya he is delaying the
development of his Knight this is
typical dubovian stuff here he always
seems to find a way to make things
original
take them original
or do Bob's worked with Magnus where
you're basically playing offbeat lines
not going into opening theoretical ideas
that of course these Young Guns have
studied tildity and he says you know
what I just want to play a game I don't
want to battle it out in any big opening
preparation so he just mixes up the move
order a little bit the knight from B1
can land to C3 can go to D2 and do buff
now slowing down looks a little bit on
the side deciding what kind of an
opening approach does he want does he
want to pick up the pawn on C5 does he
want to develop the Knight or does he
trade the other Central Pawn on D5
so many choices here to make for life he
could also take on F6 at any moment I
wouldn't really do that I wouldn't hand
over the bishop here even if it means uh
that you temporarily win a pawn I think
he is probably going to take the pawn on
C5 which he just did and if vaishali
kind of blindly recaptures then white
could take on D5 of course the queen on
C2 is extremely well positioned it aims
at H7 but it could also hit the bishop
on C5 so vaishali has to tread very
carefully here anti-young player Chast
Sanya I love it and one of its most
important aspects is that the engine
often frowns upon the opening choices
made but that's exactly the point that
makes him a bit less likely that a
diligent young player has checked those
lines with the engine I think this
opening choice is already turning out
successfully for Daniel dubov as
vaishali delivers a check on A5
wow I was also thinking about just
developing the Knight to pick up that
pawn on C5 but vaishali wants to pick it
up with four so first goes with the
check but this just means that she's
inviting white to further develop the
night and I'm super tempted to get it to
the C3 Square where it also targets the
D5 pawn and as you're mentioning you
know regardless of what the eval bar
might say of these off-beat ideas that
the top players employ but practically
with this time control it's so difficult
to counter them Daniel and do both there
just delaying his development a little
bit uh going into a little bit of a
think here but I'm expecting Knight C3
it's just such a logical and a natural
move here but then it's do-bop dubar
will probably just play something
completely unexpected
listen he's probably thinking about
Before He'll sack the pawn to open the
people but I'm with you Tonya I think
he's gonna go Knight C3 and we're gonna
get sort of a relatively standard uh
Queen's gamma decline type of setup now
we've got something very non-standard
going on in one of the other boards so
let's go to the bird's eye view first
because all four games are now underway
two of them are still in their incipient
stages we've got a four nights Italian
on the lower left but look at the top
right this is happening
craziness Sicilian Madness in David
paraben's game against prenatra let's go
take a closer look it appears that
pranesh has unrolled some incredible
preparation he's got over 10 minutes
he's still pre-moving
oh my gosh what is going on here
he's taking all the white spawns he's
taking all that white spawns and he's
blitzing his moves out he's got more
time than what he started the game with
he's up a bunch of bonds but his King is
still in the center this is an absolute
mess
so I think we need to rewind a couple of
moves while David is thinking and show
how this happened now this started as a
sharp Sicilian a four-night sicilian
which is known as a particularly chaotic
line white takes and plays E5 this is
all very standard stuff white kind of
clamps down at the center Queen C7 and
queen B6 has been known for a long time
but after C4 Tanya I'm pretty sure that
Bishop B for Chuck is the more common
move pranesh immediately jumps into E3
and then he follows that up with the
check on B4 in turn he gets his Bishop
out to A6 note how the queen is guarding
both the Knight and the bishop white
can't take on E3 because the black's
Bishop pins its counterpart instead
paravian trades he gives up the pawn on
B2 now you can't take the Knight because
the A1 Rook was hanging so you have to
develop pronish is taking more pawns
he's played Knight takes C5 oh my God
what is this F T C5 and queen takes C5
what's happening just insane stuff I
just want to point out that you could
not have picked up the bishop on A6
because pranesh has a devious idea that
if instead of the night David would have
gone for Queen A6 there's Queen D4 check
winning that night on e4 tactics every
everywhere but this is definitely not
over the board inspiration this is solid
prep from pernicious side and he goes
into a position after the Knight was
captured on E5 he picks up the pawn
gives up the bishop and picks up a white
knight on e4 it is a mad position where
black as we can see on the live board
Daniel has got four pawns per piece
of four pawns for the piece indeed and
of course black couldn't have taken
White's Queen there because there was an
intermediate check on D6 with whitesnite
so that's a devious detail now from
David Robinson I guess I can show that
since we have the annel support still
open 95 If instead Whitehead played
um if instead black had taken whites
Queen and then the Knight on e4 you're
not going to be able to take the Knight
on e4 because it's no longer on e4 and
this is a miserable position with that
Knight firmly ensconced on D6 so instead
both sides have dodged their fair share
of landmines and finally dare I say
Tanya these are dangerous words but I
think the position has more or less
stabilized it's stabilized into complete
Anarchy and Chaos I still don't know
what's going on but at least both kings
are finally relatively safe I don't even
know how to evaluate this position I
know we've got the eval bar and it seems
to say that it's edging a little bit
towards uh White having the edge here
but it doesn't matter what the
evaluation Bar says these four pawns and
the fact that pranesh has managed to
keep control over the clock it is still
a position for all three results but now
this is going to be a slow grind will
David's piece be stronger than a Black's
Central pawns uh Daniel it's tough to
comment one way or the other in that
yeah it's hard to make heads or tails of
this I think the reason the engine is
skeptical about parnesh's compensation
although that's probably the wrong word
because technically black is up material
he's got four pawns for the minor piece
and a minor piece is worth three I
actually thought parabian would have
dropped the king back to G1 instead he
is trying to insist on the queen trade
and that was an implicit draw for from
pranesh I don't think David proven is
even thinking about opting for a draw
here I think he's either going to play
King to G3 trying to hide away on the
flank knowing David he's definitely
tempted by this move or Tanya you could
try to play Queen D4 and hide the king
at its sort of normal spot on G1 and if
that happens then who would have ever
thought that what we saw in the opening
uh led to White's King being in the
center you would you would have thought
that this was a normal game where both
sides castled King side could not be
further from the truth
oh he's going into a little bit of a
tank tank now if he goes Queen E3 that's
definitely a draw for but Queen D4 is a
little more ambitious because black will
fall down with the check and then it's
up to White to decide where to move the
king because we can see that black will
not be able to pick up the A2 Pawn as
the D7 Pawn is hanging uh which would
not have been the case was White's Queen
on E3 because you can't take Rook D7 The
Rook on D1 needs to defend that B1 Rook
so in this case black would have simply
gobbled up the A2 Pawn but we do we do
have Moves In fact and I see that Queen
D4 Queen C2 a check was given King falls
back and now I'm expecting black to
start pushing that D7 Pawn you want to
go D5 you blanch that Bishop on F3 and
now you're checking to pick up the A2
Pawn
great calls Anya D5 on the board what a
risky decision what a gutsy decision by
David paravin who let's point out is
four minutes down on the clock extremely
unusual David usually is the is the side
that has nine and a half minutes after
40 moves but the roles have been
reversed here and pranesh is the one
with almost all of the time that he
started with and after 35 and E4 Daniel
how far has
even prepared this line the guy isn't
stopping
he's just conceivably conceivably this
still might be preparation I think more
likely is the fact that he's just used
process of elimination to play quickly
maybe he was taking that minute to
review his files this could conceivably
be preparation though still Tanya which
is incredibly terrifying it's just a
terrifying prospect that you're in move
26 and you're in a position this sharp
and your opponent is still fully
acquainted with the typical ideas E5 E4
is coming and David might regret that
choice pretty soon to not repeat moves
and keep the draw
regardless of what the objective
evaluation is of the position it's
psychologically so difficult to deal
with this situation where your opponent
is just blitzing move after move you
were pointing out the idea that pranesh
has to push the E Pawn down the board
and David says not gonna allow that
moves the Rook to E2 so at least
controls the center pawns for now but
black cans thought I am getting his own
Rook to the open file and he does it
Rook comes to be it a takes control
their ideas of Rook lift you want to try
to push C5 at some point I'm
I would be terrified as white if black
can either get the C Pawn up to the
fifth rank or the E Pawn these are two
very critical ideas in Black's position
pranesh is such a valuable player to
have on your roster this is exactly the
kind of board four that you want you
pointed out that he is a grand master
elect so take his feet a rating with a
grain of salt it's now closer to 2500
than it is to 2400 and the confidence
with which he's playing I think he's
signaling with his play in these first
two games that he believes that he could
not only eke out half a point maybe
another half point I think he's fully
confident that he can come up with a
plus score and he can essentially be the
MVP of this match rugby one is on the
board initiating a trade of Rooks and
actually if you can get the Rooks and
the Queens off the board then obviously
those past pawns are ultimately going to
overwhelm the bishop so I think it's
important for David to be the one uh at
this point to keep at least one set of
heavy pieces on the board and to keep
some time on his clock because he's down
to three minutes now
this is a very strong statement by
Prince who's making his debut this
season in the protest League he draws
the first game without too much trouble
without any trouble at all actually on
his own terms being better against
Daniel duber and then blitzes out this
prep and it looks like David paravian is
the one who needs to be careful he has
an extra piece but for four pawns and he
makes the move Rook B2 now pranesh needs
to decide which Rook do you want to
trade and my intuition here would be you
want to pick up the B2 Rook because why
give your opponent an open file
but if you're picking up the B2 Rooks
maybe it's worth starting with the
Intermezzo C5 the queen can't take on C5
because you dropped the rock once the
queen drops back I agree with you Tanya
take B2 push the pawn down to C4 and
make sure that your extra pawns here are
all protecting each other the last thing
you want is to give line access to the
B7 square and you might start dropping
some of these pawns that you've worked
so hard to capture Daniel there is a
crazy idea if you go C5 does white have
the option to actually capture capture
the B1 Rook with the D1 Rook
a little careful here watch out watch
out
and the room jumps back and that
Checkmate but as I was as I was filling
out this line I realized that you do
have the escape with Queen B1 picking up
that Rook with a check and now you'll
pick up the queen but you're right Tanya
after Rook V7 this does not seem
appetizing because it's much harder here
to push Black's pawns which are now
damaged so great call I'm gonna give
myself a little slack because it is
still pretty early in the morning the
sun is just coming up well and the sun
has come up on Black's position here I
like the way pranesh is handling this
very practical he's taken D1 I do agree
Tanya I thought maybe taking the other
Rook would have been a little bit more
clinical but he is still very much in
control of this game after he slides the
queen let's say to G5 threatening to
move into C1 good position here for
pranesh but in the meantime some of the
other games have been heating up as well
so maybe we can leave pranesh to handle
this incredibly complex position we'll
come back to it in a couple of moves but
if we look at the top left Tanya that's
the game I want to go to I think you're
exactly I know exactly where you want to
go I mean it's kind of obvious look at
that bottom left board that we've got
right the bar says it's creaming for
Prague but take a look at the position
it is so scary black looks like he's set
up all the attack against White's King
with our eval bar it loves Brock's
position I would be terrified as
Whitetail with the Knight jumping onto
F4 Daniel makes sense of this for us
as my coach would say white might be
better but I might need to change my
pants here if I'm playing white because
you're right the Knight is coming to F4
when the engine looks at this position
what it sees is very White's got an
extra Pawn on the queen side let's just
take on A6 because what could possibly
go wrong when black plays Knight F4 if
we could bring up an analysis board I
think the reason Knight gf4 is not scary
and remember we have the benefit of
knowing that it's not scary because we
see the Evolve our showing plus too
white moves The Rook up to F2 obviously
defending against Spain black does have
some exciting tactical prospects here
such as Knight takes G2 but Tanya if we
follow this line to its conclusion white
could maybe drop the bishop back to E2
the engine actually gives the incredibly
cold-blooded Rook to B3 lifting the
other Rook up and knocking the Queen off
of its active post forcing it back and
now white just continues his Queen side
campaign with Bishop B7 when the red
carpet has been unrolled for the a pawn
but how hard is it to convince yourself
that even in this final position black
doesn't have any scary prospects on the
king side Knight F4 looks terrifying if
if Prague has the cojones to go for this
I will be very very impressed so let's
go back to the live board wow so this is
the current position and as you were
pointing out once the A6 Pawn is picked
up and you can take care of the attack
the red carpet will be rolled out and
the a pawn will be the star of his own
movie but it's so difficult to navigate
through those complications seeing those
Knights jump into the attack is
terrifying Prague makes a simpler safer
move goes for The Rook lift to B3 his
idea is against that Knight G2 sacrifice
that you were pointing out he over
defends the F3 Knight currently but this
means black has the opportunity to
defend that A6 Pawn but of course Dennis
lazavic he doesn't care of course he
doesn't even think about it he just goes
Rook F4 rookie would have upset you and
I'm sure a lot of fans Rook F4 he wants
to go for fire he wants to pick up that
E4 Pawn I do not see Prague going for
Bishop A6 right now Rook E4 is super
scary
I think that ship has sailed I think
white needs to keep this E4 Pawn alive
because if that pawn Falls not only is
White's Queen going to be hit in the F4
square foot vacated for one of Black's
Knights but I would just try to keep the
center stable with either Bishop D3 or
92 instead he goes for active defense
with H3 oh my gosh if Knight G3 check
Prague simply wants to slide his King
over to G1 and there will be no way for
black to maintain contact between the
queen and the Knight so Knight G3 check
as tempting as it is would actually be a
blunder much more reasonable would be to
slide the queen into G3 instead he
brings the queen back to C8 seeing an
opportunity to defend that ailing Pawn
on A6 now don't go Queen E2 and Prague
avoids that with the 10 foot pole
he goes King H2 one of prague's biggest
strength is his ability to calculate
precisely and as well as quick and
that's really a strong point in these
formats so we can see he's very cool and
calm in a very scary looking position
King H2 now that Rook Cliff that we saw
from Dennis moving that Rook up to F4
also gives him the opportunity to in
fact double up on the F5 he can
currently move the Rook from EA to f8
really put the pressure down uh it just
seems like it continues I'm just you he
falls back with the Rook 2 F6 and I was
wondering was G4 a potential idea that
in fact Prague had set up it looks
absolutely ridiculous but G4 could have
been big trouble for that night would
have had to fall back to F6 he says I'm
going to fall
forward with Rook Knight to F4
also I think Dennis was worried about
the prospect of Queen E2 which Prague
Was preparing with the move King H2 and
black just has no way to defend the pawn
on A6 a second time so it may seem like
black is in the out of the woods on the
queen side but in fact he isn't once
that E6 Pawn Falls we already know how
quickly White's Apon rolls down the
board so by moving The Rook bag Dennis
gave his Knight the opportunity to jump
to F4 but that gives Prague a very
important defensive Tempo what's he
using this Tempo to do he's using it to
take as many pieces off the board as
possible and the more pieces disappear
from the King side Tanya the likelier it
is the black is ultimately going to pay
the price for that week A6 bond this is
a very very dangerous position for
Dennis lazovic he's got to find some way
to add some fuel to the fire on the king
side and we see the trades are on and
you made a very key point that imagine
this position when the major pieces the
queen and the Rooks are off the board
black will be dead lost unless black can
arrive with the Knight to C5 a very key
defensive square and I can go to D7 and
C5 and protect that A6 spawn but all end
games will be very dangerous for black
here so Knight falls back to F6 and a
couple of moves ago it looked like big
trouble for white skin at least frog
isn't getting checkmated anymore anytime
soon
I'm always so impressed by his ability
to stay cool Under Pressure it's an
ability that he has worked on for many
years with his longtime coach uh one of
the key figures in Indian chess
Grandmaster RB Ramesh who is just well
known for helping top Indian talents
develop their calculation skills I've
had the pleasure of training with Ramesh
and seeing it firsthand and it's
incredible what Prague is capable of
particularly in acute time pressure but
he has a lot of work to do Bishop D3 is
something I would consider to reinforce
this Pawn on e4 and then maybe you could
guide your queen back to home base on E2
White's plan is so so very clear but
Prague is investing some time here
trying to find the best arrangement for
his pieces instead I think he's got his
eyes perhaps even on the king side what
a Twist that would be Tanya if white
would ultimately be the one to go after
Black's King who would have thought
I love that you're pointing this a rook
transfer to the king side and then truck
can play on a weakness on the queen side
the A6 Square as well as the g786 pawn
that would need the funding Prague has a
different approach he blocks not only
the f file but frees his own queen I'm
not loving this diagonal for the bishop
but Daniel this is a good moment to get
our bird's eye view up this game is
going to be a grind and we will keep our
eye out but there is fire everywhere
especially the top oh my God right board
take a look at that pranesh against
baravian those pawns have marched down
the board
oh I'm looking I'm there's so many games
are for my attention top left board time
you're like Charlie has one dubuff's
Pawn on A3 she stands in a very very
good spot as well but I agree I think we
should go back to the David provin game
for now because it is on fire as it has
been from the very first moves I thought
that black was getting checkmated but as
I look at this position closer I think
the tables might actually turn once
again if black plays Queen to F7 in this
position a queen trade would be
Unthinkable with Black's pawns having
reached these Advanced spots instead
pernav moves his Queen to C7 and David
has 20 seconds to handle a wildly
complex position
wow and the first thing that comes to
mind is what happens you can't move your
queen what happens if white defends that
truck and he's done you ghost King H2
because he wants to get the queen to
eight seven but Queen C7 was a sneaky
move actually threatening The Rook on G3
which I miss for the first 10 seconds uh
realizing that that Rook needs to be
defended so easy to blunder into that
but now Queen 87 is another a big threat
that needs to be handled and it might be
time for pranesh to offer that Queen
trade
it might I think it's time to play Queen
F7 now you could pursue that black queen
to G8 and we could get a repetition of
moves with Queen F7 back to G8 back to
F7 but pranesh must be thinking right
now about how he can generate winning
chances of course C3 is very tempting
but white might be able to set up mating
threats with Bishop to E6 Tanya that has
to be calculated very carefully last
thing pranesh wants is to give up half a
point here we've got a bunch of other
crazy games we have a Time scramble in
dubov against vaishali I think we should
go back to our bird's eye view I think
we should pay our respects to vaishali
who is handling Daniel dubov with
tremendous Precision right now she's got
winning chances but she's also got five
seconds on her clock let's watch that
time scramble unfold yes why Charlie is
black yes she is up upon here
she's up upon and this is just giving me
nightmares from the previous round she
was also handling David per avian with a
better position but then she got flagged
missing her opportunity and lost that
game here
96 on the before he's gonna win a second
she wins the second pawn and look at
vaishali declining the repetition a
couple of moves ago wow that's what
great players do she is completely
winning here but Daniel do off how many
of these games as he pulled out of the
jaws of defeat he's not trying just the
last one Daniel and verb just yeah just
one just one now vaishali has to keep
time on her clock we know that her
internet lagged out in the last game
Knight to d8 or Knight A5 trade the
Bishops and push your queen side Pawns
well she does it she goes to B4 and of
course Daniel is gonna try to keep those
Bishops if vaishali trades on D5 Daniel
gets a past Pawn she's never gonna do
the Knight C5 advancing and attacking
the A6 Pawn right now she defends it
with Bishop B5 B3 is still not possible
because the bishop and the Knight stop
it I thought if I surely could have
taken on D5 instead she gives the check
Daniel duboff trying to get his pieces
as active as possible to her but the
Knight is heading to D3
or is it I wish I she goes Knight to G6
stopping the king from going to E7
Daniel wants to go with that e-pawn but
it's not advancing any further while
vaishali making a lot of progress on the
queen side she is and Bishop D3 was an
excellent move the Knight didn't have
the F5 Square all she has to do is avoid
getting for it and she can just push her
pawns to Oblivion here
this is she is she is so close there's a
check on D7 the king runs away to G5 far
away from all the checks right now you
can't push the beep on the A4 Pawn will
be hanging now where Charlie wants to
get her Knight towards the queen side
she is playing with machine-like
Precision but don't play B3 that
blunders the pawn A3 is correct she's
almost there Knight D3 Chuck wins
oh she goes Bishop B1 but is there H4
check and why Charlie has to make sure
she doesn't lose that Knight or lose any
of her pawns Bishop D3 wins Bishop D3
ends the game she goes A2 and now he
can't pick up the A2 I don't want to
pick up the B for pawn and this guy
here to convert now just one remains one
Pawn remains and dubuff has to find a
way to give his Knight up for the h-man
and make vachali demonstrate the night
bishop checkmate with let's say six
seconds on the clock the internet might
not save you if you you know with 10
seconds you got to figure out the
procedure dubov needs to get his Knight
back to the king side and give it up for
the H Pawn which is not a given he might
not be able to do that well right now
ashal is definitely picking up the H2
Pawn with Knight F3 check and winning
that pawn dubov inching closer towards
this is every player's nightmare to
actually win a bishop at night versus
the king in just seconds which is five
seconds on the clock
you've got we have to stay here we have
to watch this game I will point out that
David paravian I think it I think is
going to win his game his opponent
pranesh he went for the win he blundered
so David Peruvian is knocking on the
door but we're staying on this game
because this would be a sensational a
sensational Victory if if vaishali can
bring this to its natural conclusion
this is such a big moment for the Indian
yogis where vaishali is at the brink of
winning but she has to show good
technique she doesn't go H3 she's still
waiting on pushing that pawn gives a
check drives white skin further away and
now the pass watch out H2 Knight F1
you're not gonna win anymore that's it
do Bob's going to resign by Charlie
defeats dubov in an equal end game with
black that was some of the most amazing
time pressure technique that I have seen
in a long time cold-blooded as vaishali
heard from Under Pressure but we gotta
go back to our bird's eye view because
we've got one more time scramble and
it's another potentially amazing game
for the now the levitop chest was with
Valentina might score an upset of her
own no sorry valentina's black
she is playing against nehal Serene and
he is the bullet Genius of India it
doesn't matter how many what's how much
time he has it's more than enough for
him and there kunina she just flagged
wow she flagged she had a great position
Tanya just a couple of moves ago but in
the time pressure we know how merciless
knee-haul can be that is a big win for
the yogis vaishali wins nehal wins I
can't get over the fact that Daniel
dubov the board one has half a point out
of two and it's all because of the
amazing play of the Indian yogis in
these first two rounds
this moment belongs to West
parabian was in the driver's seat but
then messed it up in time trouble got
flagged and after that bounces straight
back against the top Board of the
levitar wizards one of the strongest
Grand Masters in the world what a game
by vaishali not just the point but she
also wanted in convincing style showing
Amazing technique this is truly a
historic moment and a Monumental one in
vaishali's career
anytime board for pizza board one and
not just any board one it's an
achievement to hang your hat on as we
look at the individual scores pranesh
with a frustrating game and a huge win a
huge win for David pravin who
essentially keeps the Levits off chest
Wizards in the match because that could
have conceivable being a 4-0 blow up
it's all about Prague who's got two out
of two and it's all about vaishali as
you said Kaiser didn't smile on her in
the first game but she keeps her
composure defeating dubov with black and
Valentina dance lassovic they are all
going to have to step it up as is of
course board one Daniel dubov
wizard with three points and the Indian
yogis have got five the golden number to
get to is eight and a half to seal the
match Victory but in this case it is not
just the match Victory but these teams
are fighting for a spot two the protest
League playoff uh Daniel so much at
stake here this is absolutely epic stuff
epic stuff indeed we hope you've been
enjoying the match and folks do not go
anywhere because the golden eight and a
half points is far from being reached
the chest Wizards are gonna put up Ace
an amazing what will hopefully be an
epic resistance of their own and we will
take an epic break so ladies and
gentlemen you're watching the pro chess
league and we will be back with round
three of this amazing match on the other
side of this short epic break
[Music]
in this video series I cover the entire
184 185 Spectrum so all the openings
that arises after our one E4
I have had a lot of experience in this
I've played several games with
prominence out of game against Levon
aronium from the world team championship
I also hit a game from Gibraltar against
Marcus ragger which is the game that I'm
gonna show here
the key here when this happens when your
opponent finds a resource of playing F4
or you've reached this position in your
calculations don't panic
[Music]
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
hello and welcome to this video
my name is Christoph zileki I'm an
international master in chess from
Germany and I'm here to share with you
why the opening plays such an important
role in modern chess the opening in
chess is like coming prepared with a
battle plan you play a move but it's
part of a larger strategy you want to
have an idea what to do against every
possible response that your opponent may
play against you want to have a plan a
strategy laid out before the game even
starts this can be really deep on the
top level of 10 20 30. you don't need
that much but you want to be prepared to
get a game that you enjoy playing it's
more fun to play and give you more
chances to win more games I've always
loved studying the opening figuring out
new ideas how to beat my opponents and
set traps this is now my profession
writing courses on openings for
chessable I've created more than a dozen
the most popular ones being of the keep
it simple series I have received an
award this year the author of the year
what I invite you to do is go to
chessable.com and check out how to play
the opening better get fun positions and
win more games
[Music]
foreign
chess
the weight of a win draw or loss is all
on one's shoulders
it's easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
there it is a smile she clinches the
match What a Feeling to win a match for
your team welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives five checks first is light
checks a little triangulation
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the PCL Legacy with a new format
and new schedule
only one team can be crowned the next
PCL champion
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
yes Chelsea's gonna win it Chelsea's
gonna win it
and Pablo has won it Pablo has won it
wow
he has played two games he has won two
games the Indian sensation Grandmaster
or progdananda getting focused before
round three of this epic PCL matchup
between the levitov chess Wizards and
the Indian yogis that Prague is such an
integral part of it's been an amazing
chess career for Prague really from his
very first year's time absolutely he's a
phenomenal Talent he became a grand
master at 12 Daniel he is the fifth
youngest Grandmaster in the history of
our game now with all these teenagers we
always talk about how Fearless they are
and that is a common attribute that they
have that I think what really separates
Prague and is his biggest strength is
his fast and precise calculation his
ability to really zoom into the critical
lines and weed out all of that that is
unnecessary makes him a dangerous
opponent in these formats
it does indeed and Prague is not the
only member of his family uh to bring
points to the table his sister vaishali
is fresh off of a defeat of the top
player for the Wizards Daniel dubov a
feat that she accomplished with the
black pieces in an end game in which she
fully outplayed our incredibly strong
opponent the individual scores there
really telling us the whole story Prague
with two out of two and let's not forget
niho nihal who wins a big game in that
last round against gunana as well he had
a bad position at some point yeah and
also pranesh we see that he's only
scored half a point but that doesn't
tell the full story he had a better
position against Daniel dubo he was
completely close to winning against
David paravian but both games did not
end the way he wanted so very strong
showing by the Indian yogis the Avatar
visits really need to step it up they
need to do it quickly the top board has
to perform in these formats we've seen
that time and time against Daniel duboff
currently struggling he needs to he keep
his loss in the last run to vaishali
behind him and start scoring up those
points for the team currently it is
David paravian who is carrying the
levitor Wizards indeed he is and the
score is five to three the first team to
eight and a half points wins the match
and because it's the third win for one
of these teams they will be
automatically seated into the PCL
playoffs as we review uh the lineups for
this round obviously a three and a half
or 4-0 Victory would end the match but I
think these are actually pretty decent
lineups here with Daniel dubov he's got
black against nihal sarin that's a game
he's going to try to win and I really
think the bottom two boards Tanya from
Dennis lazovic and Valencia Laguna
who've got the white pieces I think they
have to run the table and both of them
really have to win their games if the
levitov chess Wizards hope to set
themselves up for a comeback in the last
round that's a really important point
that you make down uh Daniel that do Bob
on the top what yes he has to try to
make the most but he's playing with
black and he's playing against nehal
let's not forget nehal Serene was the
global Championship finalist he beat
ding he beat a niche on his way that
eventually went on to lose to Wesley
only in the finals now in nehal's
accomplishments in speech as formats I
think we're all very aware of you cannot
underestimate him but it does come down
to those bottom two boards that we're
talking about with gunina and Dennis
lazavic they need to score those points
for that team against pranesh and
against vaishali we do have liftoff on
our top board as Daniel dubov and how it
looks a little different right now on
our screen
yeah well strap yourselves in ladies and
gentlemen Daniel duboff he cannot be
happy with the way that his PCL debut
has started but how many times have we
seen top players turn things around for
Magnus Carlson at the last how to steal
Daniel dubov is not going to let uh two
unfortunate games affect his mindset and
we can see how aggressive his mindset is
there B7 to B5 Tanya know that it's not
a mouse lip this is actually a common
way to handle the king's Indian attack
slash Catalan setup that nihal is
unrolling here with black controlling
some key squares on the queen side but
obviously that pawn is also sticking out
like a sore thumb and you often see
white trying to punish him with an early
A4
absolutely and when white does do that
which is a very very thematic idea
because you want to provoke black to
push that pawn to B4 what would then
happen is that the Knight would arrive
to C4 that would be a nice juicy Square
for the night but we see that nehal has
taken a different approach here he
instead of targeting that B5 Pawn with
the pawn actually attacks it with his
own Knight jumps with the Knight to A3
with this means that Daniel is not
forced to push it to B4 he can still
make the move A6 keep that pawn on B5
and control that C4 Square
and I think it's likely that he won't
cooperate and the secondary point of
Knight A3 might be to prepare c2c4 I
actually really really like that move by
nehal I think it's inventive I think
it's exactly the way that you want to
handle this setup for Black extra A6 C4
maybe Daniel can push his Pawn to B4 and
support it with A5 what's the point of
waiting for white to play C4 that might
seem counterproductive but of course the
point is that the Knight is not able to
reach us you called it that juicy square
if black plays B4 and A5 immediately
then Knight is of course putting even
additional pressure on Black's already
tender uh and potentially overextended
Queen side so I'm expecting A6 but
Danielle is obviously deciding between
these two viable continuations before
versus A6
and also let's find out that is not
drug Who currently
it's
so a definitely here is a big moment for
a do-bob he wants to defend that B5
Barney he's thinking about the different
ways in which he can do it gonna move
he's gotta move he decides to play A6
and that makes a lot of sense Daniel
we've been finding out you keep that C4
square defunded and as you mentioned C4
is the idea that nehal had and the
players are now blitzing out their moves
C4 was played Black pushed the pawn
attack the Knight the Knight now falls
back to C2 and dubov advances the a pawn
one more step down the board a quite a
quite ambitious play there on the queen
side
yeah I mean this is a very very
aggressive setup it obviously could
backfire if nihal continues to needle
those pawns but he's got to be careful
about how he does that because if he
plays A3 then black actually played B3
and A4 the pawns keep sort of
metastasizing and advancing forward and
the last thing you want is for the pawns
to land on B3 and A4 where they are
literally unattackable by White's other
pieces so both sides have to can't
handle this with a lot of caution I'm
eyeing the move D5 opening up to D4
Square for the Knight but uh reopening
the long diagonal for Black's Bishops so
incredibly strategically complex
position here uh with a lot at stake
here is niho now taking a bit of a thing
and perhaps giving us an opportunity
itanya
um I think you might have another
thought in this game
um so don't want to go out if you have a
line to show
not aligned to show but just to just to
end it end on what you were mentioning
this strategic fight I think that also
suits nehal's style of play he has a
very strong positional strategic
understanding but also one of his very
strong strength is that even though he
might not play an absolutely crazy
aggressive position he's tactically
really alert and these kind of positions
a lot of pieces and pawns are not traded
up everything's on the board so we can
expect a rich middle game but like
you're saying Daniel action is on on the
other both speaking of Rich middle games
we've already arrived there on some of
the other boards so let's jump on to our
bird's eye view
to the bird's eye view we go and my eyes
are drawn to the left bottom left side
lazovic against pranesh are in the midst
of a crazy opening sequence in the top
right we've got a somewhat more kind of
strategic a quieter position also
structurally unbalanced so definitely
Prague against David pravin is a game
that's worth looking at but I'd like to
go to the pranesh lasovic game lots of
it has the white pieces of course and he
now has secured the bishop pair so the
situation already starting to clarify
let's draw some opening conclusions
let's draw some endgame conclusions
Tanya because now the Queens are off the
board oh my goodness they're not even
letting me finish
the Queens are off the board and the B3
Pawn was attacked which has been pushed
as you were pointing out well this can
be almost called a queenless end game
there's still the two Rooks and white
hasn't castled yet uh I do like white
just a little bit here or Daniel and
it's because of what you pointed at just
the bishop Advantage right now the good
thing for pernicious that he has no on
weaknesses there are no easy Targets in
the position and then Bishop on D5 is
actually a beautiful piece it stops
white from really finishing development
very easily which is why we see the move
F3 because the bishop on F1 was tied
down to defend that G2 Pawn so F3 just
makes sure that White's Bishop can jump
into the game the king might decide
whether you want to put it on F2 or to
E2 because very often white in fact
doesn't even want a castle in these
positions
yeah black has hang out exactly the same
players have to decide where they're
putting their kings bronoff has made his
decision and now it's time for Dennis to
make his now if he castles prematurely
Tanya I'm with you I think that Bishop
is a monster piece and it could even
make its way it could worm its way to
beat three and black will actually have
obviously a May threat on D1 and the
last thing you want if you're Dennis
lazovic is just to exchange all of the
pieces here because I think a minor
piece end game despite light's Bishop
there is going to be basically a dead
draw so if you're Dennis lovesvik I
think you're going King F2 trying to put
your Rooks in the center Rook see one
Rook D1 and trying to punish black uh
for you know leaving himself with this
Knight on C6 that could become a serious
liability if white could find a way to
set his Queen side Pawns in motion
absolutely and once we see the pawns
Advance a little more we might even see
this bishop pair really showing the
Venom that they can have in these open
positions so pranesh needs to be a
little careful it doesn't look very
dangerous at the moment but this is
exactly those kind of positions which
are deceptive like that you make a
couple of inaccurate moves and in just
four to five moves your position can be
falling apart so pranesh needs to find a
way to try to neutralize this bishop
power Advantage but we do have a lot of
other action on already on the other
boards as well which see the Queens on
the board so let's bring up our other
boards and the one that really caught my
attention was take a look at the top
right David bravion against pragna this
is such a big board for these two teams
with the levitar visits at three points
but look at that pawn structure that
doesn't look ideal for Prague is Prague
in trouble here
hmm so I'm kind of adjusting my eyes to
this position I think the answer is no I
think the position is approximately
bounced so yes with his last move in
fact Prague was the one who voluntarily
went for this Pawn structure if we
rewind just a couple of moves he played
Knight to D2 this makes sense he opens
up his Bishop but then he makes a move
which I think a lot of players uh would
never play in a million years Knight T2
to C4 and what could possibly be the
point of permanently ruining your pun
structural no I don't think Prague has
gone crazy far from it I think the
reason he's done this is not only to
grab control of the D file which he can
do with Rook to D1 but that pawn on C4
as weak as it may look as weak as it is
it can also be an anchor point for the
light squared Bishop to hop into D5
which he could further secure with E4 so
Bishop D5 is possible and the last thing
I'll say Tanya now is that the B7 Pawn
is also a very very tender and if you
move it up to B6 you're walking right
into some massive Queen side pressure
the white good orchestrate with a well
timed A5 so I think Prague has very good
Dynamic chances here to compensate for
yes yes a very very disturbingly bad
Pawn structure
it's a very interesting position with
this give and take that both white and
black have as you pointed out Daniel in
a very instructive Manner and a prog's
last move seems to be hinting at trying
to get the Rook into the game you want
to play Rook D1 but I'm just wondering
Rook D1 white might have to be really
careful about tactics like Bishop C4
again I'm always targeting those weak
Pawns in the position so you still have
to watch out uh for keeping these pawns
defended I don't know if it works but
perhaps after eight six for example just
to show the point that I'm trying to
make yep if white or B6 which makes a
lot more sense let's say you go Rook D1
and then suddenly black can pick up the
C4 Pawn I think and the point is that
the queen on B3 is overloaded you pick
up the bishop you lose the Rook on the
on D1 you pick up Black's Queen on d8
you lose your queen on B3 so it just
looks like the tactics seem to work out
in the position which means that David
has one more move before white can
centralize that Rook on D1
great points on you and this shows why
you can't make automatic moves even if
the position is quote unquote quiet I
think it's a very misleading phrase
because tactics are omnipresent they're
everywhere and you have to look for them
so Rook D1 is not currently a problem
for black but even if white makes Rook D
won't happen black could also meet that
with Rook C7 to D7 so I don't think that
the D file is a matter of deep concern
for David but again A5 A5 is the move
that I think he just spent you know
however much time two minutes he spent
two minutes on the Move B6 so he was
trying to find a way to meet A5 and
maybe time and maybe he just wants to
play B takes A5 and say hey yeah my own
Queen Side Pawn structure is going to be
damaged there but at least I've got a
past a pawn no he wants Rook D7 and so
he opens up the defense on the B6 Pawn
by his Queen okay
I would have been surprised to see B
takes A5 just spoiling the pawn
structure would just seem like too
committal in that position now he's
threatening to win that pawn on A5 and
he could now pick it up with the queen
as well that is a legit alternative in
this position because after Queen B6
Daniel you were talking about having the
a passer that is there and if white
decides to trade the Queens after eight
xp6 now that C4 Pawn gets really tender
great point I was thinking about that as
well and David paramyan is thinking
about that himself obviously you can
sense the wheels turning in his brain
right the fact that he's thinking he's
deciding between a b and queen B6 it's a
very committal decision these are two
different completely different paths
that you can take it's on the board and
prox's queen trade I don't think so he
drops his Queen but not to A4 uh Tanya
he drops it to A2 and again I think the
reason why is that he wants to keep the
D5 Square under control he wants to open
up the possibility of Bishop D5 and
maybe for that reason black should
consider stacking the Rooks on the D
file then presumably Prague will
complete his development with Bishop E3
it's on the boat you call it our Rook D
it makes so much sense you control that
D5 Square so no trading on that D5 with
Bishop D5 you bring your piece you bring
your Rook onto the open file doubling up
watch out for threats of Rook D1 never
going to arise arrive now with prague's
last move of developing that Bishop to
E3 connects the Rook now a white can
start thinking about getting the F1 Rook
all the way across to B1 targeting black
screen and asking black uh questions
about where you'd like to go but that
Queen because not not too many Pleasant
choices there
not at all right you go to D6 you walk
into an open D file you go back to C7 uh
you're walking into Rook to B7 so David
probably been actually taking some very
creative measures in order to carve out
some more real estate for the queen on
the queen side I think after Rook ab1
you can now move the queen either to A7
or maybe more to the point is Queen to
A6 piling up on that C4 pawn and Tanya
you could get some kind of liquidation
here if Prague wants a draw I think he
can take on A5 and basically force a
trade of just about everything on the
board C4 is gonna fall why it's gonna
take C5 Black's gonna take E2 and you're
gonna get one of those sequences that
end up in
a symmetrical position I apologize that
move was not on the board that was
terrifying did probably G4
I mean I've seen all sorts of mouse
slips uh happen but after I've seen
everything you know but we could get
something like this I'm showing on the
analysis board you know it takes takes
now actually now that I look at this
Tanya why it has to be very careful it's
so easy to calculate to this point if
you draw no it's not a draw Rook to D1
and black actually wins the game on the
spot because after white takes he will
have to give away his Bishop to avoid
checkmates so I correct myself this is
still a very sharp position where both
sides have a chance to blunder
wow and it's so easy to fall for such
lines because you kind of just yet till
a certain point and feel your realizing
neutralizing liquidating but then you
missed that last move and suddenly
you're absolutely busted but Prague here
taking his time I think he is going to
calculate this till the end he's not
going to pick up that A5 Pawn Rook B1
still comes to mind as a move that asks
a lot of questions you pointed out the
A6 Square putting more pressure on C4
after Rook B1 Queen A6 it's also very
difficult to pick up the A5 Pawn let's
just show that as well because it's just
the kind of tactics that exist in this
position are insane diet rugby one Queen
S6 and if you pick up Queen A5 uh you
trade on A5 or maybe give a check first
but Rook A5 and now you give a check
forcing a rook trade and again the back
rank problem is screaming Bishop F1
Bishop H3 and you might be like wait a
second white has a background thing as
well rookie check but black falls back
and white is just one move shot after
Bishop to C5 you are the one who gets
mated on F1 first
almost there I'm one move away but
that's how chess Works ladies and
gentlemen and I think this line is so
instructive uh glad we show that Tanya
because you see that just because you
have a fiend Bishop doesn't mean that
your problems with the back rank are
solved you might be avoiding immediate
checkmate with Rook D1 but this Rook D1
Bishop H3 idea is so common it's won so
many games and black could even
potentially sacrifice his Queen for it
so a lot to think about here for Prague
who's now down to three minutes now last
thing I'll say and we should definitely
look at the other games but I think he
can play Queen takes eight five Tanya
and maybe I'm not going to show that
line again uh but meet Bishop C4 with
Bishop F3 instead he's gone for a
different kind of liquidation and I
still think the likeliest result here is
a draw and I think this was the safest
alternative you get rid of all these
ideas of background checks because you
vacated that G2 Square very important
and I have to say that David baravians
that move A5 was super tricky it forced
frog into a long thing really going low
on the clock we saw these different
tactics that existed but it seems as if
Prague has navigated his way across from
the troubles and as you said this is
most likely to end in an even result
although most likely those are dangerous
words in a PCL match because we've seen
all sorts of games go haywire and
speaking of other games let's have
another look at our bird's eye view
their bottom right you see another
interesting end game sort of a typical
grunfeld end game with Valentina gunana
I don't want to say in a must-win
situation against vaishali but winning
that game would give the lavatop chess
Wizards a huge boost and another end
game on the bottom left but these are
interesting end games Tanya these aren't
just your average boring symmetrical
types of end games
which one should we go to
you know what I know that
it is
that catches my attention it is a rich
middle game and I see we have a Central
Pawn break uh Daniel let's take a deep
dive into that one before we head to the
end games
absolutely listen now you I don't need
any convincing to go to the game with
the Queen's still on the board and I
actually think that Daniel dubov has
done a good job of unbalancing the
position and he's not gotten tilted
right you can tell that he's playing
objectively uh but he's created a very
intriguing middle game that's going to
result in an early time scramble look at
look at the clocks two minutes now for
Neil Hall two minutes and change for
dubov and this is the kind of position
in which one of these players could
easily spend Tanya 15-20 minutes per one
move in a classical game here they're
gonna have to make decisions Lightning
Fast wow and he does make a very
committed decision of trading on E5
allowing Daniel to jump in with the
Knight to E5 and this is what nehal had
seen after the trades he gets a C5 break
in the position is really opening up
right now C takes D6 is a big threat
winning that Bond if black was to
capture on C5 white retakes with the
bishop hitting that Rook on f8 a
Potential Threat on the B4 Pawn
big questions for Daniel how does he
respond to C5
there's no question that structurally
positionally white is better especially
if black acquiesces to the trade that's
why I think dubov might have his eyes on
the night Sally to G4 Knight E5 to G4
opens up the bishop it you might have to
sacrifice the pawn on D6 but if you can
root out White's dark skirt Bishops and
blacks Bishop on G7 will operate
uncontested instead instead he does
trade on C5 and simply plays rookie
eight and I just think black's pieces
here are so incredibly active if white
plays Knight D3 well then black Tigs and
Neil has to be so careful uh not to
catch a stray here because E2 and B2 are
weak if you play Bishop D4 Tanya then
the C Pawn is set in motion so Black's
position has a lot of potential energy
and I would actually take black any day
of the week uh in a Time scramble
including Wednesday
I love that Wednesday Thursday Friday it
doesn't matter but today especially a
black looks like he's got the position
you want you can never allow that c Pawn
down the board which is why nehal goes
Rook C1 just over protecting that C5
square but this also gives black the
opportunity to perhaps come forward with
his queen as well you can't start
looking at options like Queen to G4
Queen to F5 catches my attention Queen
B7 Checkers you're pointing out great
call Queen F5 on the board there are all
kinds of threats now you can potentially
move your knight to G4 at an opportune
moment the Knight can also go back to D7
because the queen on F5 attacks that
Bishop on C5 you'll be hitting that
Bishop you'll be hitting that pawn on E2
and once the bishop falls back to E3 the
C Pawn can start advancing down the
board
we're used to machine-like Precision
from nehal in time scrambles but man
will this be hard to handle with 45
minutes we already have a result lasovic
and pranesh have drawn their game Dennis
lazovic just never got off the ground in
that game a great hold for pernash who
didn't give his opponent any chances
that end game all the Rooks were traded
as we predicted and that fizzled out
into a colorless draw so definitely this
game is the place to be if you like
Intrigue one minute for Daniel duboff so
he can't exactly fall asleep Tanya
because if white consolidates if white
gets his night out then eventually the
weaknesses on the queen side could make
their presence felt
meanwhile on the clock has is down to
down to about 30 seconds right now but
we know nehal you can't play on his
clock he is just as strong with 10
seconds on the clock as he is with an
hour on the clock and that's I'm saying
that without even exaggerating Daniel he
is such a bullet beast and you know all
about being a bullet Beast well and I
know all about nihal being a bullet
beast and he is going to have to show us
that bullet Beast with 19 seconds he
drops the bishop down to D4 opening up
an attack on the C7 Square dubuff says I
don't care I'm gonna bring my Pawn down
to H3 and I am going to Checkmate you on
G1 oh my gosh Neal with 10 seconds maybe
it's worth taking that pawn and
preventing Bishop H3 or is he gonna take
some stuff he tries to trade his Queens
makes a lot of sense you know at least
if the Queens are off the board you
don't get checkmated but Daniel Duba
will not trade the queen it is a great
idea when you're on the attack to keep
the Queens on the board but can he find
a good Square for the queen
what a game this is where do you move
the queen queen G4 Tanya you're right
it's not easy to find an appetizing
Square you could trade Queens but no he
wants to win this game and nihal could
take C7 here instead he desperately
tries to simplify by trading the bishop
and moving his own Knight up to F3 I
think nihal is stable but probably worse
wow Knight F3 and you know I see that
see the eval bar and it gives a big
advantage to Black and I think it all
comes down to this queen side majority
that black has B3 a move thrown in
attacks the queen queen goes to D2
Bishop F4 is still not possible because
it can be captured by the queen even
though the G Pawn has been and now Duo
falls back with the bishop to F6 oh man
this is bad this is very bad for Newhall
he's playing with his last seconds Rook
B to Da this must be winning by force
yeah I think you should trade everything
in rookie too or no he that wasn't right
apparently that wasn't right why not
Rook takes C2 and does neo have some
weight to oh Knight D2 oh Rook takes C2
there's Knight F3 to D2 Tanya and he
wins the B3 Pawn you lose the ball that
one but you win the B3 pawn and that's
all that matters and nehal has it under
control
danielizes the big missed opportunity
it's been one frustration after another
but all credits anyhow he spotted that
idea when he played Queen takes D7 and
that's it the worst is behind him in
fact I know this sounds crazy but do
buff has to make sure that he doesn't
blunder a fork this is going to be a
draw and a big big save for Newhall that
is the second draw of this round that
means we're down in two games okay we
can I think trust the players so repeat
moves here there we go we have a draw on
the top board what a save for knee-haul
and that end game on the bottom right
Tanya that might actually decide the
round and that is heading into a Time
scramble as well wow A Time scrambled
with about a minute to the players I
think we have to go into that one it is
Valentina gunina against veshali and
where Charlie has had such a tremendous
day so far and I see our eval bar seems
to say that this game she is better as
well the reason for that is the peace
activity you see that nice D5 square
that vaishali has for the night the
control down the C file the queen side a
potential Queen side passer and also H6
which would be a strength in the middle
game can often be a weakness in the end
game
great breakdown and by Charlotte just
breaks down White's remaining Queen side
punch he says hey my knight on A2 has
many ways out back through before I
think this is winning for vaishali she's
now up a pawn and she has demonstrated
some incredible cold-bloodedness in time
pressure in the last game she needs a
little bit more where that came from
what do you think about Rook to C3 here
that forces the trade but white is able
to keep uh the material count largely
intact with King D3 there I'm positive
that that's what vaishali is calculating
right now Rook to C3 forces a mass trade
and might lead to a winning Bishop end
game
this is reminding me so much of the
advantage he had against Daniel dubov in
the last game where she had those extra
pawns on the queen side and now it is
a technique that she needs to show we're
surely taking too much time right now
she needs to decide either go with the
Rook to C3 the problem with moving back
your knight to B4 is you have to look
out for Knight B5 that is the counter
play the counter idea that Valentina has
currently in the position so vaishali
needs to make a choice does she go Rook
C3 does she go nights she decides to go
for the trade with Rook to C3
I think it's an excellent decision given
the match situation you want to
eliminate all risk if you're vaishali
because a 2-2 round would be okay with
the Indian yogis but I think she's going
to drive this point home okay so the
Rooks have to be traded Valentina has no
choice then I think by shali is going to
take that night and try to rush her King
up into the center gunana is pinning all
of her hopes on the counter play
provided by this past d-pawn but man am
I pessimistic about Hawaiians this year
but this allows King C4 and I was
wondering if black had the time instead
of playing the automatic King F7 to
maybe start pushing that B5 Pawn to take
that square under control but perhaps it
doesn't change too much you always have
A6 B5 in the air and once again I want
to point out that eight six Pawn can be
a weakness for white in these positions
absolutely and also important is that
Black's King side pawns are all on light
Square so you never have to worry about
those typical Bishop end game tactics or
white sacks a bishop for the pawn four
seconds she has to worry about her clock
though as she brings her King back to D7
and Tanya I think all by Charlie has to
do is maybe get the bishop back and
ultimately figure out a way to set your
Pawns in motion because any time white
makes a Mad Dash for the queen side
which maybe is what gunana has to try
black will happily give away both of
these pawns because these King side
pawns are going to be all sitting ducks
with blacks King and Bishop taking their
forks and knives out
a really nicely pointed out that white
it just doesn't have enough time but
also Valentina doesn't have an option
she needs to create her chances and now
the 861 under attack Bishop G7 doesn't
really help because black will go King
to D6 she loses that 860 weakness but
takes control of the D6 square and now
if you take on A7 we're getting the B
Pawn will start advancing
this is just over for white
I'm beyond impressed with vaishali's
handling of these end games and time
pressure she is making it look
incredibly easy but this all happens to
be calculated and now Bishop takes G3
Bishop G3 is a massive threat
without that move her entire strategy
would have failed going in a pushes her
Pawn I'm trying to preserve as many
pawns as possible that's a great move by
Valentina the game is not over
Blackstone you just go H5 and H4 is
coming in with the bishop G3 do not
forget about that H spawn I told you
immediately the H Pawn is what will
Bishop G3 played what a beautiful tactic
there this is amazing what a great call
Tanya you call this in the middle game
even before the Queens uh were off the
board that H Pawn it became a weakness
it does white in and this is an easy win
because vaishali is not giving away her
last remaining Pawn just F4 or Bishop F6
and white is in Zug zvon what a huge win
for the yogis because Prague he drew his
game as well Tanya that means three of
those games ended in draws and the yogis
are gonna take this round as well an
inch oh so close to the playoffs with a
two and a half one and a half victory in
this round
as a result and Indian yogis take this
one away with this they have a bigger
margin going into round for what a huge
match this was and it gets tougher now
for the levitor Wizards Daniel what are
the chances of a comeback in this one
oh my gosh and they need they need a
three and a half half Victory they need
three one just to force the playoffs so
listen we've seen a lot of 3-1 rounds
it's possible but some of those players
who've Stuffle today are going to have
to again step up in a huge weight in the
last round I'm looking at Daniel dubop
they have a little bit of margin for air
no they actually have to go three and a
half half I apologize uh to force the
playoffs Tonya because if the yogis
score even one point then they hit the
golden number eight and a half so oh my
gosh I mean let's be real this is this
would be definitely uh perhaps after the
Yogi's own comeback against the Canada
chess bras one of the biggest comeback
wins in the PCL they need a miracle
performance in the last round
wow there's so much big ger in the
lavator
of to go super big and all out all guns
blazing in the last one as you pointed
out yogis need one point to wrap up the
match wins to punch their ticket into
the 2023 protest League playoffs
two draws one win that's all they need
we need a little bit more coffee so
don't go anywhere the final round of our
first PCL match is coming right up in
just a couple of minutes
did you teach uh certain positions or
openings or middle games
openings or middle games or what what
did that your TR what did your training
uh people look like I'll give you one of
the secrets here so a good a good coach
will correct your moves but a great
coach will correct your thinking
and um all right hold on hold on I want
to repeat that again for the people in
the back can you just repeat that again
so a good coach will correct your moves
and a great coach will correct your
thinking so really part of the magic of
coaching is holding a mirror up to a
child's so they can see their own
thinking
and sometimes you made the move because
you were overconfidence uh you were
dismissive of your opponent and so these
whether they were this kind of
self-knowledge the self-awareness is
part of the cognitive process and it
helps to accelerate their learning curve
as as players
um and so meaning games in that loss
because you didn't know the Roy Lopez
even though the 14th move of the Roy
Lopez or because you couldn't execute a
rook upon that and again yes of course
these are these are technical things
that you need to win chess games but
games are also lost because of lack of
self-knowledge so
um
the issue of spasticity losing super
Trojan uh you know and I tell the story
many times but he lost the world
championships have chosen in
1966. goes back to baffinic and
he says you know why did why did I lose
now uh people many people may not know
but spasky was an incredibly talented
chess player right in many ways he's
considered one of the first Universal
chess player he can attack like Tao and
he can defend like petrosion but he
loses this match and baffinic told him
uh the great talented Boris basket uh
did you study Patrol
right so meaning it wasn't he didn't
think it was important to study the
opponent the famous line from Sun Tzu
know your enemy know yourself in a
thousand battles you you will never lose
uh heathus thought it was about about
sebasket and so he had to take the time
and recognize that he needed to
understand petrogen beating you means I
must understand you chess is a
conversation is a it's a dialogue
between the two chess players so by 1969
he knew what to expect at the chessboard
he has he has studied uh the Trojan and
he eventually becomes uh the 10th uh
world champion
[Music]
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of uh
you know anyone trying to develop their
chess game
um if you do find you know style of play
that you enjoy that's good but you could
also try to sharpen it by implementing
you know another form of
into your bag as we would call it
[Music]
in this video series I cover the entire
184 185 Spectrum so all the openings
that arises after our one E4
I've had a lot of experience in this
I've played several games of prominence
at a game against LeBron aronium from
the world team championship I also had a
game from Gibraltar against Marcus
ragger which is the game that I'm going
to show here
the key here when this happens when your
opponent buys the resource you're
playing F4
or you've reached this position in your
calculations don't panic
[Music]
Daniel dubov's pclw for the levitov
chest Wizards has not gone according to
plan we see him there on camera he has
not come up with a single victory in the
first three rounds and now time is
basically up and the chess Wizards need
a monster score in the fourth and final
round of their match against the yogis
to stay in the Imagine force a
tiebreaker as we see the match format
Everybody Plays everybody of course it's
up to four rounds we will have a fourth
round coming up right now and the Indian
Yogi is all they need Tanya is one point
to reach the golden number eight and a
half and punch their ticket into the PCL
playoffs
the love doll Wizards need to make a
massive comeback just the way the Indian
yogis did against the Canada chess bras
they need a big win the laptop visit
need to score a minimum of three and a
half points and that will take them to a
playoff if the levitar Wizards win 4-0
then they win the match you were talking
about things haven't gone do Bob's way
well everything seems to have been going
absolutely the Indian Yogi way so far
and Daniel I have to say that it's been
vaishali who's been the big MVP the
father siblings of Indian chess we see
Prague on the top board where Charlie
the third board today what a fantastic
performance by these two four and a half
out of six is what the siblings have
they actually have the levitov Wizards
total score just between themselves you
can see the match score there seven and
a half four and a half so as you said a
4-0 uh blowout by the Wizards would win
them the match but we've only seen we
have seen that in the PCL the Indian
yogis themselves came up with a 4-0
victory on the strength of uh the first
defeat suffered by Magnus Carlson at the
hands of vidit who is not playing today
but man oh man have hit his teammates
carried the torch with Grace
absolutely I mean look at the Indian
Yogi's lineup with Prague nehal vaishali
pranesh this is a team with an average
age of 18 years and what a performance
they've had today at the start of the
day few would have predicted this kind
of uh this kind of play going into the
final round especially up against the
likes of duboff for ravian lasovic
Valentina things have gone terribly
wrong for the Wizards Daniel what kind
of magic do they need to wield to take
this away some of the magic that helped
them win the first two weeks Tanya I
mean they were the aggressors especially
last week they blowed A team out of the
blue it blew a team out of the water but
now they are the victims they are
getting blown out of the water
themselves and that is ultimately what
monster teams do first of all Daniel
duboff he has to score his first victory
of the match he has to find it in
himself uh to defeat the Yogi's top
Board of course in the final round
ladies and gentlemen board one plays
board one or who plays board two Etc
that is the way the PCL match is set up
and I love that that means it's a true
test of that all of the boards dubuff
has to win their the margin for error
Tanya is basically zero especially with
Daniel Duba I'm needing to exploit the
white pieces against Prague
every match matters and every board
matters at the protest league and
absolutely agree with you no margin for
error this time hard to imagine that
Daniel dubov has not won a game so far
it's crazy it's unbelievable and we know
that when the top board struggles like
this it's actually it's just incredibly
hard to pull off a match no matter how
well assembled your roster is you're
you're Tom board
absolutely needs to deliver well Prague
delivers a nimso Indian here we already
have a sort of imbalanced Pawn structure
Tanya with uh black having the majority
on the queen side and white kind of
having the super solid Pawn chain in the
center
by this
meanwhile what black wants to do is
transfer that Knight on A6 all the way
to E6 Knight C7 and 96 are ideas that
are always in the air and getting it one
step closer to the king side as your
point and you can even get it to the G1
Square now that you mark the H3 Square
as well pick up that King meanwhile what
does white want one of the Thematic
plans is a central break you want to try
to get F3 E4 in as quickly as possible
if you're dubov in this position but
anytime white advances that F on one
step notice how the E3 pawns becomes a
weakness and very often that is the key
moment when Black's the one who strikes
in the center first with C5
I like this Choice by Daniel dubov I
mean he's guaranteeing himself at least
some winning chances here this isn't
just gonna gonna fizzle out into some
colorless draw and F3 E4 right up his
alley dubov is such an aggressive player
he likes creative ideas Dynamic play
Dynamic plans and right now the ball is
in prognan on his court he knows exactly
what white wants so Prague might want to
orchestrate a C5 Pawn break in response
to F3 if you do it immediately you're
going to be saddled with uh a weakness
on D5 so you often want to wait for
white to play F3 as you pointed out
Tanya because then the E3 Pawn becomes a
counter weakness the blacket attack so a
lot of decisions to be made here in the
early going for Prague and he's going to
invest a good amount of time to make
them right now the player who's
investing a good amount of time has
Daniel dubov he's uh meet them of Rook
D1 oh I'm sorry actually he has made the
move Rook D1 and it is prague's decision
now whether he decides to move the
Knight to E6 or is he he does it he
brings the Knight into play and still
after F3 he does have the C5 break so
everything is under control so far and I
see in RR bird's eye view let's pull
that up because the other games have
started as well and of course this is
the round where the levitov Wizards need
to score big to make their comeback
they do indeed and that is why Dennis
lazovic in the bottom left has played
very uncharacteristically a Sicilian
Defense lazovic is an E5 player through
and through but a good team player
adjusts to the constraints of the match
he doesn't make the team adapt uh to him
or her a great team player he they do
whatever it takes in order to drive home
the necessary point but it's obviously a
very very risky choice and um another
crazy game is Valentina gunina's early
Karo Khan against pranish that is very
unbalanced as well uh but I would
actually like to go to the vaishali uh
Dennis lazovic game because vaishali is
suddenly taking a long think and it's
only move eight so Tanya can you help me
make heads or tails of this rather
unconventional Sicilian that we have
here and I think uh like you're saying
it's unconventional which is why
vaishali goes into a thing try to
understand how she wants to approach it
she makes the move A4 now this took me
by surprise a little bit because it's
not a developing move not a usual move
that you want to play but once you take
a deeper look you understand why the
move A4 she's trying to preempt and stop
the idea of black going A6 B5 next if
you would have made any other move A6
would have hit the Knight the Knight
would have had to fall back on either A3
or D4 and eventually the move B5 would
give blacks Bishop to B7 Square so a
nice little touch there taking time and
stopping Black's activity on the queen
side after A6 she falls back to D4 and
the queen comes back it looks like you
know white went ahead with the Knight
Black's Queen fell back white retreated
with the Knight the queen came forward
and now it looks a lot more sane to me
yeah it's like those movie scenes where
the time starts rewinding and the broken
glass is put back together uh there's
something very satisfying about watching
the pieces go back to where they really
belong white lost the tempo black lost
the tempo but when all is said and done
we now have what seems like a very
conventional night orif type position
I'm not I'm too lazy to count the Tempe
who benefited uh with this whole Knight
B5 Queen BH Shenanigans I don't think
anybody did I think the Tempe are even
and we have a position Tanya that has
been known for many many decades Gary
Kasparov was an early proponent of
What's called the skeven again uh
structure with black where you put the
pawn on E6 but you could also push the
pawn to E5 uh and timing that correctly
is one of the hardest things about
handling this position well I think
lazovic has his eyes on the Move E5
that is the big Central break you either
want to get B5 in to take that Bishop
out to B7 or you want to try to fix the
center and force White's hand with the
move E5 now that B5 is not an idea B6 is
not an idea with the queen on D4 and the
bishop on E3 lined up uh E5 is always in
the air but first Dennis decides to
finish his development and is also
eyeing the C6 Square he's saying I can't
get my Bishop to B7 but I can get it
onto the diagonal with Bishop C6 but he
let go of that opportunity to play E5
where Charlie immediately seizes it and
goes E5 herself and I like that she
didn't take too much time to make this
move
the best way to just get this match to
where it needs to be if you're the yogis
is just you know not to think my
teammates have it handled let me just
play a passive game and try to eke out
half a point no that is exactly how you
allow a miracle comeback for by Charlie
she believes that she can win this game
and single-handedly guarantee the
victory for the yogis I think that's
what we see from her last move E5 trying
to make Dennis lazovic as you said
regret not playing E5 himself but it
should be pointed out that black
structure here is incredibly solid as
passive as his position may seem white
might actually end up overextended with
her E5 Pawn now seriously pressured by
the queen and the pawn and look at by
Charlie original inventive play pinning
the bishop on E7 but what is her
response going to be if lazovic
completes the typical maneuver with
Bishop C6 that's what I'm curious about
and he's curious about it as well
call that Dennis we were talking about
this idea of developing the bishop to
the diagonal he El he gets it there was
almost forced by
Charlie 6 and vaishali answers your
question this is what she had in mind
she jumps in with the bishop to B6
forcing The Black Queen to perhaps D7
because you need to keep that Bishop on
E7 guarded as well as the pawn on D6 I'm
also trying to work out the tactics what
happens after d takes E5 because yeah
you can pick up the queen but black can
also pick up the queen on B4
yeah maybe Queen A5 there would have
reinforced uh the threat on Black's
Queens so lazovic he's not a I don't
want to say he's not a tactical player
everybody's Universal but he does prefer
quiet positions he is the Berlin player
obviously the Berlin would be
Unthinkable in this game because that
would literally hand white half a point
which I think by Shelley would have
taken so he's gotten at the unbalanced
position that he needs now I think he
has to time the move D takes E5
correctly again Tanya he could take the
pawn even here hitting White's Queen yet
again but yet again vaishali could slide
her Queen up to A5 and make sure that
the E5 Pawn is well protected once she
recaptures it with her own Pawn I guess
we're about to find out
that's a really nice idea you pointed it
out in the Lost move it still exists you
move the queen This Time It's The Rook
attacking the black queen not the bishop
and B6 but the concepts are the same and
where Charlie is in great form today
just an amazing play by her she plays
Queen F5 hitting that Queen forcing the
queen back because there was no other
good Square captures on E5 and not just
for a moment compare all of White's
pieces with black pieces and it's clear
who has the upper hand here
she is in phenomenal form as you're
saying and just look at black snide it
has no Prospect this is why vaishali
built up the battery it's a prophylactic
battery in the sense that it deprives
black of the move that he desperately
needs in order to coordinate his heavy
pieces and get the Knight over to D5 so
the pawn blocks one Freeway Exit the
Queen Bishop battery blocks the other
Dennis lazovic trying to build a third
exit for himself at all costs so he's
accepting the permanent weakening of the
dark squares because he desperately
needs more breathing room for his pieces
and by Charlie could play the tempting
move Bishop to F3 in order to try to
carve out her own pathway for her Knight
but I still think I still think Dennis
is very solid here as uh unappealing as
this position may look there aren't
really any specific targets for vaishali
to attack so I think she still needs to
maintain Precision uh to really
capitalize on this Advantage here
and I saw a feature chat saying that
vaishali will not stay an IM for too
long uh I think we can all agree with
that she does have two grand master
Norms already she is around 24.50 so one
norm and about 50 points to go but she's
one of the big talents from India with a
huge bright future ahead of her uh
speaking of bright future it looks like
Indian yogis have one up today as well
this looks like a great position for
white look at the other boards as well
everything in control Prague with the
black pieces on the top left I look at
that position we liked vaishali's
battery look at prague's Queen and
Bishop on the queen side just stopping
and taking control of the position
dominating White's pieces there yeah I
think Prague is flat out better Daniel
dubov was unable to light the spark plug
in the center he hasn't even played the
move F3 so he's nowhere near opening up
the center Prague has opened up the
queen side he's done his do uh getting
his pieces to incredibly active squares
White's position just seems very
unappetizing and that last move on the
top left Knight takes E6 is a clear sign
that do Bob is sort of conceding the
opening battle and one loss one loss
would immediately uh end this match
because all the yogis need is a full
point another game Tanya that's catching
my eye perhaps we could take a quick
look at the way that game is unfolding
because this is more bad news I think
more bad news for the levitov chest
Wizards on the bottom right I think
Valentina gunina only 11 moves in is in
big trouble on the board but even more
importantly on the clock
wow and it's it's evident why she's in
trouble on the clock but even more
evidence why she's in trouble on the
board because look at her pieces her
King is stuck in the center there is a
big pin on the Knight on D7 what on
Earth is that pawn on G5 even doing it
just looks so out of place meanwhile if
we just calculate the number of bonds
white has an extra Pawn already so it
looks like everything is under control
Knight G2 is the threat currently on the
board she uh pranesh G3 simply pushing
that Knight away you can't give a check
on G2 because that Knight would have
been trapped after King F1 you would
have just ended up losing it Valentina
garina trying her best to get the
pressure on that Central E5 Pawn that's
where she's relying for her compensation
here and and she's going to bring her
Bishop out to G7 I think we see why she
played G5 she's trying to and she's
successfully preventing white from
supporting the E5 Fawn with F4 but
that's not the only way that pranesh can
keep this Pawn alive he could take that
Knight get it off the board I wouldn't
do that pre prematurely because that
allows Valentina to open up the age file
maybe exert some pressure on H2 and the
other thing pranesh has to be very
careful about is a careless Knight F3
could run into G4 he does take on G6 I'm
just very curious how he's going to
follow this up maybe he wants to play a
well-timed F4 this is the Big Moment of
Truth yes F4 is on the board on the
board so it doesn't want to give the E5
pawn it is so key in wide position to
keep that Bond Bond alive otherwise
black just gets so much play in the
center that C3 weakness will be a
problem so F4 makes a lot of sense but
now the big question is going to be what
about white skin safety it's hard to
imagine white going shot Castle now that
F4 has been played are we gonna sassle
by white in this game a queen side
castling perhaps
that's totally not out of the question
because White's Pawn structure as sort
of un appealing as it may look visually
all of the pawns are defending each
other the bishop on D4 is so well placed
as the sort of you know villain in
White's entire construction it's
defending absolutely everything for
Valentina she castles King said she is
taking Desperate Measures and I think on
the next move she's gonna have to try to
explode that entire Queen side with the
move P6 with the eval bar the eval
bartanya has crept up steadily in
pernicious favor barring a cataclysmic
turn of events in this game I think he
might be the first one uh to dash the
levitov's Wizard's hopes for a miracle
comeback
but there's still work to be done on
that because it's just such a
complicated position and with the king
in the center anything can happen as we
can see on all other boards action is on
but vaishali is still dominating the
position with white her Knight in the
center on e4 that bishop and queen just
looks like more activity for her
meanwhile Daniel dubov I think we have
to go into that position Daniel dubov
against Prague is such a big game for
the levitar visits and it looks like
Prague has everything under control look
at that eval bar it is creaming that
Prague is close to winning here
he is indeed he is dominating now on
both crucial sides of the board we've
talked about the queen side for a while
that's where Prague was operating to
begin with but even in the center That
was supposed to be White's territory
that was where white was supposed to get
the E4 Pawn break which dupuff has not
been able to do instead he is conceded a
big Pawn Center and he is just reeling
he is reeling this entire match he has
not found his footing at all and he
hasn't found this pudding in this game
either he's just played the move Rook A1
Tanya I thought he should have tried at
least to open up some space on the
center with E4 but he is just deep in
the tank here rookie one could be met
with Rook to eight I love that noise
he's not careful that there could be B3
right you don't want to lose your Bishop
on C4 I was screaming how much I love
that move and then I realized that I've
just walked into the one tactic that
perhaps could be big trouble for black
but rookie 2 is still so tempting with
that pawn just one step away I'm just
wondering if we can actually make it
work
let's take a look with the analysis
board here yes I think that black has
them of Rook E8 to B8 this might be what
Prague is searching for by the way as
he's taking his time and obviously yeah
you lose the piece but after Rook B1
You're simply threatening to promote to
the queen with the black rug blocking
the white Rooks access to the A1 Square
I think that wins the game
but instead instead Prague you don't
need to take any unto risk and he makes
a a somewhat more measured move as we go
back to the live board he has played the
move a rook to A7 so he is trying to
fight Tanya for control of the a file
but he's doing it in a somewhat more
strategic manner that might have allowed
Daniel duboff to get active in the
center though with E4 yeah but E4 would
have allowed maybe Knight G4 and that's
exactly what Daniel Dubois did not want
because sure every pawn move has its own
consequences with E4 you do weaken that
F2 Pawn so Daniel's last move H3 takes
away that square he wants to get E4 in I
don't believe that Prague will give him
the opportunity to do it
I don't think he will either he will
play I think E4 himself as you're
implying and for Prague it's important
to play without risk a draw in this game
would be as close as it gets to ending
the match it would take some of the
further pressure off of his teammates I
think Prague has to manage the the team
score as well here and that's exactly
what he's doing he's playing without
risk he's playing without entering too
many tactical complications but at the
same time Tanya if you allow E4 if you
allow white to get active black does
have a bunch of targets right E5 is weak
B3 uh is weak and Black's Queen is tied
down to that pawn so I think this is
still a three result game but no
question that Prague should not lose
barring some sort of major blunder
E3 F3 G3 H3 do not try that at home this
cannot be good for white as you're
pointing out it is time to jump in with
the pieces Prague will not shy away from
this I am expecting D4 you're you're
bringing that Knight to the center frog
will bring that Knight to the center and
that will be very very difficult for
white what does Daniel do Bob have in
mind when he made this move F3 I just
don't understand that's just a tilt move
he got frustrated about the threat of
94. if we could bring him an
announcement the reason D4 I think
essentially ends the game you're calling
it Knight to D5 pushes the queen away
the queen is not trapped it has the C5
square but if I'm looking at this
position correctly uh and I'm not I
thought Queen A2 to go after the B2 Pawn
makes sense I guess white could play
Bishop C3 but in this particular
situation Barack could just play Queen
takes D4 and say hey I've got a pawn up
end game that I cannot lose and I'm
getting my Rook to E2 but no Tanya he
has not gone with D4 instead he's made
another sensible move he has played the
move Queen to C4 coming as close as
possible to forcing the queen trade
dubuff could weasel out with Queen A5
but I guess that would allow black to
infiltrate White's territory with Queen
E2 still everything under firm control
but D4 D4 definitely was a winning move
there missed by Prague that was so
tempting and I'm slightly surprised by
Prague deciding to not go for it because
it just felt like the kind of Moon that
he would love to make not Daniel under
normal circumstances would have loved to
keep the Queens on the board but it was
impossible with all these light squares
that have been weakened and after all
these trades it does look like Prague
still has everything under control but
now the C4 bishop and let's just point
out that if the bishops get traded
suddenly black spawns might become a bit
of a Target Bishop F1 King F1 firstly or
C6 Pawn is hanging you defend it with
your Rook the white Rook can step up to
C3 and Target the the B3 Pawn as well so
frog needs to be slightly capture right
now and that's exactly what I was saying
earlier right if white gets activity
this suddenly becomes kind of a three
result end game and he's also down on
the clock another game where things have
taken a serious turn for the worse if we
could go back to our bird's eye view
balancing Acuna uh has turned the tables
on pernesh you can see her Knight has
just jumped into B2 opening up a
devastating Discovery against the F1
Rook Valentina is now in a winning
position but uh conversely there is a
piece of bad news for the levitov chest
Wizards the board we haven't even looked
at is nihal sarin's game against David
Praveen I think nehal now might be the
one who has the best chances of ending
this match parabian is down in 10
seconds he's in a worse end game and I
think we should take a bit of a closer
look at this one because this game might
be on the cusp of being over unless
perovian essentially stays perfect and
and holds this together he's got to do
that for his team and he's playing on
just seconds on the clock he's got 11
seconds while nehal Serena's got over
three minutes it just looks like white
has got the bishop pair Advantage but
that light squared Bishop you can't even
call it a bishop right now it is like a
big Pawn as we say just defending that
C4 Pawn but with very little future
ahead of it cannot imagine it getting
into the game the only open fire in the
position is in nihal's control draw
would be the best possible result for
David in this one yeah a draw would be
the best possible result I'm also
looking at vaishali's game she is
knocking on the door of a victory she's
got a crazy position in her own right so
I think this end game is going to last
for a while
um I think we should actually go back to
the bird's eye view for a second because
we might have rushed into this game by
Charlie's game against Dennis lazovic is
getting crazy as well Tanya I'll let you
make the call shall we go there or is
there another one and we have to go
there right now because take a look at
the position on the bottom left let's
bring up the vaishali board night on E3
with a fork but one second what about
that F7 Pawn Rook F7 comes in with with
a check and it does and after King G8
the problem for vaishali isn't just that
D1 is hanging it's the black also
threatens just to take the Knight off
the board and then take on F7 amazingly
I think Dennis lazovic is doing all
right here if I Charlie could blame move
like Rook D4 Tanya it's chaos on the
board it's chaos because take a look at
what all is hanging group D6 as you
pointed out the Knight on D6 is hanging
The Rook on D1 is hanging the bishop on
C2 is hanging the pawn on G2 is hanging
with the bishop on C6 and the Knight on
E3 targeting is how do you keep
everything in control when you're
playing on seconds
this is unbelievable I actually don't
know
um
I'm struggling as well because the last
thing you want to allow is for the
Knight to take the rook and then for
black to take on D6 so there's a case to
be made for a move like Rook to F6 but
that's very underwhelming Tanya clearly
you don't create any threats with that
move 30 seconds now foreign this is
crazy but Dennis lazovic is somehow
staying alive and more over he might win
this game Queen to D2
oh 1961 she wants queen H6 what an idea
oh my God that is amazing stuff Queen 86
and there's no way to defend against
Queen 87 a mate and one that would be
unstoppable that is a nasty trick not
only for Knight D1 but Knight C2 as well
runs into Queen eight six and if you
pick up rook 26 is Rook D6 an option
here
not only that I think it might be forced
I think you might have to take on D6
because your Knight's hanging but after
Rook D6 you don't pick up the Knight
because then black picks up the Rook
with a check picks up the other Rook as
well a lot of complicated stuff instead
Dennis plays the move Queen A7 defending
that Knight on E3 and still G2 is under
attack oh my God oh my gosh he can take
it with the bishop forcing the king to
step into a discovery against the queen
that was the best move by lazumik he is
pulling out some heroic series seven
seconds now for vaishali I don't see a
move for her maybe Queen to F2 to cover
the diagonal but two seconds left she's
gotta make a decision she drops your
rope back and I think that might have
been a losing move just giving away uh
The Exchange there might also be yeah I
think just Knight takes D1 and Rook Cafe
it should win this for black
oh a draw by Prague though
yeah we do have a result on our top
board with Daniel duboff Prague that one
ended in a draw but I think we have to
stay on this with the players playing on
seconds and this could be a big board
for Dennis lazavic uh we've been
pointing out that the levitov need to
score three and a half points to take it
into the Blitz
that I don't want to say that's it but
nihal is also going to hold his position
that is a guaranteed draw against David
uh paraben so this match is yeah he has
just drawn and in fact uh yeah that's it
the match has been pocketed by the chess
Wizards who've scored the necessary one
point but definitely we should stay on
this game Tanya because this has been an
amazing scintillating Affair and ah it's
going to be a wasted effort for Dennis
lazovic who I think is going to finish
this one off yeah which is a bit
heartbreaking because what a series of
move that moves Dennis came up with I
mean queen is seventh that was
absolutely brilliant and so easy to miss
just shows immense bored Vision there by
the 17 year old Dennis and now he's
dominating vaishali goes down there was
nothing to be done Bishop takes G2 Rook
takes G2 everything ends in the mid it
turned badly but it doesn't matter
because the Indian yogis are the first
team to make it to the playoffs
they are and they're gonna make it in
very close fashion you can see the only
remaining game uh bottom right Valentine
Laguna has turned the tables on for now
she has a winning position the game's
not over because she has 20 seconds but
if she wins Tanya all that the levitov
chest Wizards needed there uh was a win
on the top board on Daniel dubov you
know we never assigned blame in these
team matches right precisely because
they're a team matches but dubov I think
is going to be largely blaming himself a
slightly better performance would it
very well might have yielded a win for
the chess Wizards and look at this
parnesh is also swindling as well Rook
H3 check and black skin is the one on
the chopping block
I mean whose King is more in
ding G5 or will prunesh fight for more I
think it depends on whether he knows
what the team result is what the match
result is and he says I don't care I
want to play on plays the move A5 he
still has Rook H3 check
just gutsy calls for the yogis and
that's what they've been rewarded for
probably pranesh maybe even if he knows
the match score that might even be more
of a reason to play for the win because
at this point there's literally nothing
to lose he might as well work on getting
a better individual score which of
course uh these team members want to do
if they want a place in the roster for
the next BCL season Tanya and if they
want a place in the roster in the
playoffs they're alerting their team
captain right now uh open h8
oh Queen AJ King G5 and there's a
Perpetual Queen d8 is a Perpetual there
and maybe at this point per National
you've got to take it and he he spots it
queen queen
she has 96. oh oh my God is not made but
it wins everything but you can just pick
up the Rook you just give a check the
King has to fall back to F5 and can you
just go Knight F4 usually does it that's
it
Rook takes F4 Rook takes H4 wins the
house if you pick it up with the queen
Rook F3 wins the house and this is all
over
and queen D3 wins the yeah everything
wins the game and oh what a heartbreaker
the chess Wizards are gonna end up not
winning a single individual round this
one is going to end two two and now
pranesh a rook to the good Rook F3 check
I think is the simplest just hunting
after the King this is gonna have some
fun here let me tell you figuring out
the mating pattern here
he's going he's got enough seconds to do
it you can't pick up that night Rook F5
check wins the queen and that means if
you fall back with the King Rook takes
F6 is possible and then the queen jumps
in to E7 uh this is just this is just
over and we see Valentina she knows it
she's shaking her head it has been a
disastrous day for the lavator visits
it has indeed oh and what a beautiful
mating pattern this is going to be the
classic Queenie for Rook C2 and then
Queen E2 a kind of a type of ladder
Checkmate although I don't know if
there's a specific name for it well
there's a name for what has happened in
this match uh and it is destruction that
is destruction thank you for saving me
there Tanya destruction through and
through a wire to wire Victory as the
yogis hold the final round they score
even more than they needed they needed a
point they got two
absolutely and not just the score but
also the games that they had vaishali a
brilliant performance today even though
she lost the last game what a show by
her Prague nehal pranesh they all made
great contributions to this very crucial
win for the Indian yogis
indeed they did and speaking of crucial
and contributions let's take a look at
the overall contributions by each team
member it was a story of Prague and his
sister if I surely set the tone Tanya
with that round one loss yes she lost to
perakian but she turned everyone's
eyebrows that loss was a fluke and in
round two she showed what she's capable
of defeating the Wizard's top board
Daniel dubov and Prague contributed
three out of four he was the top
individual scorer nobody scores below 50
percent Tanya try that on for size
and then on the other side we can see
that it was a dark board Daniel dubov he
really struggled today David paravian
had a great performance he has caught
three out of four previously in the
protest League that's been his
contribution and today as well he scores
three out of four but just one board is
not enough Dennis lizavic with a 50 and
gunina really struggled on the last
board I think with Daniel dubov and
gunina's performance today it was just
not Lavita Wizards there
no it was not but they are still
obviously in the tournament they only
now have one strike because this is
their first loss of the PCL season and
of course the yogis are officially
through they are three and oh they run
the table and they are going to be a
force to be reckoned with in the
playoffs now the big question is who
will they face in the playoffs the
Shanghai tigers and the Gotham Knights
are incredibly well situated and they
will be facing off uh tomorrow and the
lava top chess Wizards obviously this is
no time Tanya to fall asleep on them
they still have great chances to make it
into the playoffs as do our next uh Team
the Garden State passers
absolutely we've got a big big matchup
coming up with as we can see on our
scoreboard the teams have to have three
match victories to make it to playoffs
if you lose three matches you're out of
the protest league and these are our
standings lavator Wizards had a tough
loss today but Daniel they have had two
match victories they just need one more
to seal their spot and you know what I
think we all want to see them in the
playoffs because it's just such a strong
theme
they do yeah we absolutely do and some
of those teams are 0-2 uh you shouldn't
fall asleep on them either like the
archbishops of course you should fall
asleep on the Charlotte Corpus but hey
we will be back next year we will learn
from our mistakes I can swear I can
swear it time you know I'm gonna say it
I'm gonna make everybody know I want
everybody to know who we have playing
for the Canada chess Bros some dude
named Magnus Carlson is on the roster
and he will be playing in this pivotal
match between the Garden State passers
featuring Samuel savian who's been
Unstoppable and the Canada chess bras
and you can see there it's coming up at
10 A.M Pacific today yes that is five
minutes from now ladies and gentlemen so
we are only a couple of minutes away
from our second match of the day but
first we need to fill our coffee cups we
need to give everybody a chance to put
off their work meetings for another
couple of hours because you won't want
to miss this match will we will you
Tanya not at all the world champion he
will be back as well
the third his team taking on the chess
bras you don't want to miss this one no
you don't we'll be right back we'll be
right back ladies and gentlemen with the
final round the final match of today
featuring Magnus Carlson Samuel Sevin
James Canty's team it's going to be
fascinating it's going to be close but
first we're gonna go on a short breaker
watching the protest League don't go
anywhere we'll have Canada chess for us
and Magnus Carlson coming up for you in
just a couple of minutes
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
or loss is all on one's shoulders it's
easy to feel alone
those lonely Days Are Over oh my
goodness
the protest league is back
once again in chess teammates matter
there it is a smile she clinches the
match What a Feeling to win a match for
your team welcome back PCL
a unique collection of teams each with
their own personality of different
colors shapes and sizes
there are gnomes and knights chess bras
and Bishops
and whatever the heck this is
the PCL is the only place where the best
players in the world risk their fate
alongside content creators and players
from different levels ages and
perspectives five checks first is light
checks a little triangulation
entering its Fifth Season 16 teams will
reboot the
with a new form and new schedule only
one team can be crowned the next PCL
champion
my friends it's the 2023 Pro chess
League which team can Rise Above the
Rest they won't be able to do it alone
yes Chelsea's gonna win it Chelsea's
gonna win it
and Pablo
wow
welcome back to part two of our Pro
chess League Wednesday coverage Jam
Daniel nerdinsky and international
Master Tanya sajdev bringing you uh
analysis and commentary of today's two
incredibly fascinating matches one of
them has already concluded and one team
the Indian yogis have made the playoffs
on the strength of a wire to wire
Victory against the monster levitov
chess wizards but boy they didn't look
like Wizards today it was the yogis who
looked like the Wizards nine and nine
and a half six and a half Tanya what a
whip
what a win Daniel that wasn't even
though the match has concluded it's
still on our minds what a dominating
performance by the Indian yogis the
levator failed to win a single match and
I will say this when Indian yogis
perform the way that they did the day
against the wizards one of the strongest
themes currently what a performance the
Wizards have had so far Indian yogis did
it without with it without the man who
beat Magnus Carlsen with a team with an
average age of 18 years this is a team
that's definitely vying for the top
spots in this season of the protest
League
it is indeed they have made it and the
Wizards will try to come next they need
one more win to make the playoffs let's
have a quick look at the top of the
standings you can see the yogis there
are still perfect and there are two
other perfect teams that are facing each
other the Shanghai tigers and the Gotham
Knights one of those two teams will be
the second team to join the Indian yogis
in the playoffs and of course one team
has already gotten eliminated but uh we
don't see that team here and I don't
know if we should show that team Tanya
I think we should stay here
let's just take a bit of course I mean
like I think it's just the brutal format
of the protest league and we know that
three losses and you're out three wins
you're into the playoff and that's what
the teams are vying for let's just
smooth over what
I don't know if our producer feels the
same way Tanya I feel like having heard
that no no no no there we go well we're
not going to talk about the team on the
bottom but the unicorns the Blitz the
Bulldogs a lot of teams are still one
and one and those are not teams that you
want to fall asleep on let me make a
crazy prediction Tanya the St Louis
archbishops have their back against the
wall but they've won the PCL before and
I have a feeling that we will still hear
from them I am so shocked to see them at
the bottom of the table with two losses
one more loss and they are out of this
season Daniel and the Saint Louis
archbishops are three times winners of
the pro Chastity so I completely get
your a feeling that they're gonna make a
comeback but they've got no margin for
error they need to win three matches
they do indeed and not a lot of margin
for error uh for the teams that are
playing next so let's have a look at
first of all the Garden State passers
their roster features the MVP why do I
say MVP because sam7 has seven and a
half out of eight let me repeat that
seven and a half out of eight in his
first two matches he has been carrying
the team but he's finally had
reinforcements arrived with Alexander
Bortnick Linderman and others so it's
not a one-man team Tanya
and just to take your point home some
Savion has seven and a half out of eight
that is more than what the world
champion has on the top board Who
currently has a score of seven out of
eight that is the Beast that Sam savian
is
Sam sebien has made a name for himself
in the last few years as one of the top
American players but he will need one
more very strong performance today
because he is facing a team that has the
world champion Magnus Carlson is playing
for the Canada chess bras he made his
presence felt immediately with a 4-0 uh
with a 4-0 performance in the first week
but last week he suffered that shocking
loss against vidit that was a loss which
sent the Canada chess for us to a
shocking comeback loss Magnus Carlson
Tanya he is not going to forget that one
for a while and he is going to try to
well he's going to try to erase that
memory with a redeeming performance here
in week three and it's not just that he
lost that game to visit he had a
Checkmate in three he could have wrapped
up the match for his team
his team 100 8 out of eight he missed a
mate in three and eventually blundered
and lost that game which definitely was
a heartbreaking moment but we know one
thing about Magnus he doesn't
pay much heat to that we saw his
frustration on camera at that moment
he's definitely moved on he knows that
he needs to deliver today or his team
and of course he plays all sorts of open
how many games will the Canada chess
bras and Magnus Carlsen play one D4
throughout the match today Tanya that's
an incredibly hard question to answer
because most of the players on the chess
bras are capable of playing both E4 and
D4 we've got a couple of choices there
Tanya what does your intuition say over
six and a half or under six and a half
lean seven or five yeah I don't know how
you can start half a game with D4 but I
think
seven or over
five or under
six where does six fall in in the whole
situation then well I'm gonna we'll have
a chat figure that out
how to make my prediction Daniel I think
we are going to have over six and a half
games starting with one D4 from Canada
chess bras
and we're getting where that six is
under and seven is over I don't know how
under over works I'm totally
embarrassingly amateurish when it comes
to like betting I never even know what
people mean when they say over under so
I'll let the chat figure this out we'll
figure the commentary out but 1d4 it's
obviously gonna feature in most of the
rounds games today and let's take a look
at who might be the ones playing one to
D4 let's review first and foremost the
uh lineups samsetian Bortnick veronic
and Carissa Yip almost the same lineup
uh Tanya that won the last week's match
with the exception of board four which
is very capably replaced by Carissa
oh a hundred percent Carissa is such a
strong player she's a former U.S women
Champion she's 19 years old she's super
strong she is an international Master
already plays very aggressive chess but
what you were saying about Sam Bortnick
Mishra these were the key star players
for the Garden State passes in their
previous matchup they they handed out so
many punches and took the the win home
for their team and they come back with
the with a very similar lineup
the youngest Grandmaster in the history
of chess my youngest Grandmaster is
making an appearance and in the first
round uh ABI Manu Mishra will be facing
Yvonne scharich who is a Croatian
Grandmaster very very strong addition
for the Canada chest press and of course
the world champion will start off with
black against the Garden State pastors
board for Carissa Yip not a walk over
win for Magnus Carlson Carissa is
dangerous with the white pieces and I
don't think Magnus Carlson is viewing
any of these games as kind of an
automatic win because he's got a big X
on his back everybody wants to be fitted
everybody wants to be the guy
um who defeats world champion
I don't know if everyone wants to be
with it there because you remember with
it almost was checkmated by Magnus in
just three moves he did get very lucky
but of course let's bring up our match
format Daniel eight and a half points is
what the team needs to wrap up the match
that's the golden no no if you don't
know the format Where Have You Been Just
Kidding we won't pick on you the time
control 10 minutes 32 second increment
it's a beautiful cross between Blitz and
Rapid first team to eight and a half
wins the match Everybody Plays everybody
and uh we'll talk about the tie break if
we get there that'll only happen if we
get an eight eight tie unlikely I think
but I think we are very likely Tanya to
see a close match here and in order uh
to be the second team to upset the chess
bras one of the pre-tournament favorites
one of the players on the passers has to
prevent Magnus Carlson I think from
going 4-0
uh absolutely but the thing with the
protest league is that every board and
every game matters with Magnus even if
he scores for zero it might not be
enough he does need the other members to
perform as well he needs these other
boards to show up and one of them is the
board four now the Canada chess bras
they have been playing with Jennifer you
in their lineup today we've got melee
Jade instead Jennifer you had a tough
first two weeks and it just comes down
to this board for will melee Jade be
able to snatch some of these key points
even if it's half a point even if it's
just a point against the top players
from the Garden State passes and we've
seen the best teams put in the
reinforcements uh exactly when they've
needed him Jennifer you after two
matches might feel a little bit jaded uh
no no pun intended so melee Jade fresh
reinforcements she wants to make her
presence felt in her first performance
for the chassis not leaving not leaving
it mysterious as to his intentions in
round one he plays a king's Indian Tanya
obviously uh he knows who's commentating
and really that is the only reason that
he's made his opening choice
he's paying his respects to you Daniel
this is what his opening choice is about
he says you know what when I want to go
for the win I want to play the king's
Indian defense and he goes through the
most aggressive line and now it just
comes down to what are the Dynamics in
this position and to answer that well
some of them oh I can point that because
I do like playing this position from the
white
be Daniel in fact where white has got
the idea sometimes to go Castle but very
often to actually Advance with the Jeep
onto G4 as well not anymore now once the
Knight comes to H5 the point is that if
G4 arrives on the boat you'll jump to F4
white never wants to recapture the
Knight white never ever wants to open
that Bishop on G7 very often black
sacrifice is a pawn to be able to do
that I think he just made an excellent
point of very common sort of rookie
mistake in the king's Indian I could
show this on the announce board really
really quickly if white plays Queen D2
you might think that you're stopping
Knight F4 and let's make a random move
for black right Knight C5 would be more
likely but as you're saying you never
want to play G4 because even if Knight
F4 involves upon sacrifice you would
sacrifice and you often do sacrifice a
lot more than just one Pawn in order to
get this bishop to operate at its full
capacity on the long diagonal this is
the last thing you want Tanya so very
important for melee Jade to avoid the
tempting G4 and she's just playing it
she's gone G4
whoa I do not like that shocking choice
and look at Sam's Savion he is
absolutely surprised as we he can't
believe it because this is the dream
this is the big dream of everything and
it's on the board white did not even win
a pawn in this one you've allowed that
G7 Bishop as a king's Indian expert
yourself Daniel this is got to be your
dream
is I mean that you don't you never get
this kind of position and Sam might just
leave his Pawn on F4 and say hey take it
I'm gonna Focus instead on the queen
side I think he's gonna go Knight C5
Force the bishop back and run this
a-pawn up the board white will simply
lose this game outright if he can force
white to further soften up her Knight
Tanya because Queen F6 is just on the
deck here this is this is a nightmare
and this tells me that mainly Jade just
probably isn't a habitual 1d4 player I
think she might be an E4 player uh
typically so might have been a sort of
choice to surprise Sam in this game but
he's gotten all he can ask for in this
king's Indian
well I am still shocked with this
decision Vision to give up the dark
Squad Bishop he goes for your idea the
Knight jumps onto C5 you can't pick up
the F4 Pawn you have to fall back with
the bishop and black doesn't even care
Daniel you call this side I think you're
just calling out the action the a pawn
is stepping up to A3 if Queen goes to F4
the Knight on C3 will be hanging the
other idea break into the center get
your queen up rook E8 targeting that E5
white still hasn't castled this is going
to be busted right out of the opening
and while some Savion does that this is
our opportunity to get the bird's eye
view because the games have started the
action is on that one looks like bad
news for the Canada chess Bros and some
pozzer has started his game on the lower
right I'm having a hard time reading his
name uh but I don't think we're missing
nobody would have heard of him anyway of
course the world champion has black
against Carissa Yip that game has just
begun we have a Vienna opening in
top right we have got Olex Center
Boardman who was one of the critical
pieces of the passers win last week the
new look passers as Bortnick was a week
two acquisition he's got black against
Eric Hanson in an alicon but I think
that we should watch Magnus Carlson's
game unfold Tanya uh because we already
have a very unbalanced uh position in
the early going of that game
yeah let's do it because as you were
pointing out Knight on A5 that's the
edge of the board but the advantage is
that Bishop on B3 can be picked up and
very often that means an imbalanced
middle game which is exactly what Magnus
is hoping for he of course wants to
score a win with the black pieces in
this one even if it means taking a
couple of dodgy decisions in the opening
just to imbalance the middle game Magnus
one of the best in the business at doing
exactly that when he wins games with
black we take it for granted that it's
easy to generate winning chances uh from
the black side but so many top Grand
Masters actually struggle against that
and I like the way that Carissa is
handling the opening it's also tempting
to play passively when you're facing the
world champion Carissa is not changing
her style I think her best chance in
this game Tanya without question is to
get something incredibly Dynamic
tactical and get an attack going against
the world champions King he is capable
of making mistakes in Ultra sharp
positions he's only half human but the
best way to show that he's human is to
go after his King
hmm
speaking as a friend you know if anybody
knows it's got to be you we've all seen
those games
brawls against Magnus we're all well
aware Daniel if anyone has the answer of
how to get to him it would be you and as
you're pointing out you have to pay
aggressively you have to pay fearlessly
against Magnus because if you let that
get into your head I mean you already
got very little chance against a player
like Magnus but then it is almost none
and Karissa Carissa with that move F4
makes it clear that she's gonna try her
best to create a Chaos on the board and
it reminds me of this famous saying by
Mikhail Dahl about these kind of
positions that you know you've got to
drive your opponent into a deep dark
Forest where there's a path to get out
which is only big enough for one of you
and I think that's where you might have
the biggest chance against the player
like Magnus and that's all we're two
plus two equals five right you don't
want Magnus to add up the numbers and
get irrational result you want him to
start feeling nervous about his ability
to handle the complications but all of
that of course is is talk you have to
walk the walk and actually get that kind
of position because Magnus he's so good
at channeling the position into the
direction into the kind of situation
that he wants so what is he down here
he's pushed upon to D5 moves the Knight
back to E8 by the way Knight D7 might
have run into E6 so he wants his light
score Bishop to control these key
squares in the center and he is telling
Karissa hey why did you take my Pawn on
A7 if white takes it with the bishop
that runs into an easy tactic takes in
Bishop C5 is a fork but I I would be
seriously considering Rook takes A7 if
I'm Carissa call magnus's Bluff I'm
curious what the world champion has in
store against Rook takes A7
you gotta calculate all these lines
where Magnus might trade on A7 and push
that pawn to C5 blocking your bishop and
potentially trapping it on A7 and
Carissa decides to not go for those
complications instead she makes sure
that she's got control over the center
with these are exactly the kind of
chances that you can't miss against
Magnus Knight D3 I still like White's
position because of the stronghold on E5
it looks like things are still under
control but Daniel I agree with you she
had to take a small thing there or a big
thing and then decide to go for that
pawn on A7 yeah because now the
situation is stabilized and the world
champion is going to try to exploit his
Bishop pair well Carissa Yip is part of
a Garden State pastors team that changed
its look completely going into week two
they are now one of the most fearsome
teams in the league and a lot of that is
due to their Captain fide Master James
Canty if only we had Mr Canty to join us
here to talk about the games but
unfortunately he couldn't make it oh
wait a second
when you call a Jedi a Jedi appeared
as soon as you we hear everything okay
Don you just like the prophet Dania how
you doing Tanya hello Dania I like that
Tanya and Dania
but we really wanted you here because
this is such a big match that we've got
going on and the position in front of us
we were talking about how fearlessly
Carissa played the move F4 what was your
feeling at that moment were you a little
terrified no I mean you gotta let me let
me tell you something Tanya Karissa yep
will hit you in your lip Okay this
is definitely one of those that is
really strong and aggressive and she'll
take it to you every single time so I
definitely love her aggressive style
absolutely we got Carissa and then we
got the top three it's like the big
three in like basketball or football or
whatever sport we got the big three on
our team with Sam Bortnick and Mishra
they are going crazy I mean they
literally I think score like 10 points
between the three of them that's
ridiculous so and then we bring Carissa
in here and Carissa all we got to do is
just hold off big mag hey Magnus you can
do whatever you want but we're gonna
take the rest we're gonna take care of
the rest of your team at the same time
test rods are cool we love them but we
want we're gonna take them down this
match so oh Carissa missed her chance to
take on F6 now I feel like Magnus is
fully in control of the game he's gonna
play F4 that night on E6 is such a
monster but listen you're expecting
Magnus James I think to win a couple of
games and as you're saying you've got a
huge Supporting Cast one player can't
win the entire match they can only Score
Four Points so Sam sentian in it seems
like this is the time for him to put
through another monster performance
that's what you what you'll need from
him James absolutely Mr Sam I Am Green
Eggs and all the ham he wants it all
that's Sam Sam is a monster we know this
and he every every time he performs he
always performs that's why I love my man
Sam so Sam is playing with the king's
Indian too we got that nice Bishop you
know how we like kings Indian so that's
looking good already as I'm taking a
look at that board still Rooks on A6 we
got the bishop on E5 he can play F3 open
it up play H5 as well King G7 Rick h8 is
nasty there's some nasty positions for
uh for Sam right now so I'm already uh
already counting that as a dub there but
of course we still have to wait
yeah well let's go to that game actually
because Sam sebian is playing a textbook
King's Indian game uh first we're gonna
go to the bird's eye view really quickly
bottom left you've got a pretty balanced
end game I think actually Mishra might
be slightly better there so more good
news for your team and Vortec has
definitely solved all of his opening
problems and also stands better so James
I'll give you the choice if we go to Sam
savion's game where do we look at board
Nick's attempts to win that game with
the black pieces against Eric Hanson in
the morning game definitely gonna go to
the important game definitely gotta go
over there yeah uh board naked that's a
heavy situation too
let's go
let's go guys it's a monster bring the
energy baby that's right exactly you
know James he's got a knight on G4 he's
going for white skiing he's got that
Bishop on E5 the C3 Knight can be taken
up the queen can go to H5 hitting that
pawn on each oh
it's there yeah oh my God tactics here
wow let's see
really nasty also the good thing about
this is that uh you know uh he's he's
comfortable important you know how he
likes to play the aliak and like the
only one in the world that plays it yeah
religiously against anyone you know I
don't care who you are he's gonna play
it and he played it here and he got a
nice position out of the opening here
we're up on time and this is very nice
for her
shrimp D4 might win the game because 94
is not possible Bishop D4 forces rookie
two and then maybe Boardman could drop
the bishop back and open up that parking
space for the night I think this has to
be essentially a forced win at this
point and he's got seven minutes seven
entire minutes to figure that out James
mean board Nick would win this with
seven seconds I think with seven minutes
I mean I don't want to say he's got this
in the bag but this is getting pretty
close
yeah oh yeah
get this man off the board Bortnick is
swinging of course you know I love the
chess bras and I'll spending time at
their house when I was there but uh it's
uh not today we are not friends
we are not friends today and the other
day friends not right now Bishop D4
rookie two on the board
yeah this should be six and then 94 and
he's got Queen H5 on demand and then
he's so such a mature player he's gonna
take his time because he smells blood
and a black win in round one would set
such a good tone let's go back to the
bird's eye view really quickly James
because I do want to get your closer uh
views on that seven game which is a must
win and that game is not over Sam still
needs to demonstrate precise play so
let's travel on over to sebion land Sam
I am
James have you ever had a position
that's going out of a Kingston this is
like if you could construct the dream
position with every piece on a perfect
square this is what it would look like
this is a movie yeah yeah exactly right
he's Indian you know how hard it is to
play but this is just this is beautiful
I mean how did Rick get the B6 obviously
it went up to A6 but look at the Rook
it's on B6 usually the rook's like on E8
or somewhere where on a closed blocked
uh um file here it's not the bishop
takes on F5 I mean everything looks
beautiful here right Queen on F6 before
Sam I think he's he's gonna try to end
it here and now yeah boom there it is on
the board
oh my God Bishop C3 Queen D4 this one's
over it's in the bag
wow in contact with the Rook because
Bishop C3 Queen B2 you pick up the
Knight and now Queen D4 check the D3
Bishop Falls everything this is gonna be
your first point James yeah we can just
see she can probably just hit the button
there she's very strong but this one is
uh Sam I Am it's different it's just a
little bit different right there
decided to trade that Bishop for the
night on F4 were you following the game
and that was just yeah yeah definitely I
thought it was it was in fact uh every
Kings Indian player knows that you have
to play Knight F4 in those positions and
we'll sack that pawn every single time
and when it happened I was like she just
hey hey we'll take it freebie like
that's literally a freebie and we felt
really good when that happened so
and now now we're converting this point
so it's pretty good
you're going to take the full point here
James looking pretty good for your team
always a pleasure to have you on but we
will let you enjoy the games in peace
James Canty always a pleasure good luck
to you and your team pleasure Dania and
Tanya passes for the win let's go
good luck James oh my God and passes for
the win as James said well they are
getting the fire on the board as Sam
Savion after that big Miss big
inaccuracy not a mess but really A
shocking blunder I would say even though
it doesn't lose material by mainly of
giving up that dark Squad Bishop he has
just flawlessly converted this one but
other boards are not that easy so let's
bring up our bird's eye view it looks
like Sam has this one under control
does indeed now does the world champion
of his game under control I think he
does he has gotten it into an end game
it looks like a technically winning end
game for Magnus Carlson although that
evil bar actually is not as convinced as
I am Sam I Am Alexander he's still
trying to finesse a win out of his
massive initiative in the middle game
and okay Mishra against uh Sarge I think
that is the likeliest game to end in
peace so Tanya I'm gonna put you on the
spot I'm experiencing some decision
anxiety where do we go where do we go
what do we look at I agree with you with
the Magnus against I am Parisa yep Sam I
am but we're gonna let that one be for a
bit we're
up to the top right board because Eric
Hansen was making his debut in the
protest League let's bring that one up
and go into a bit of a deep dive with
that we see all of Black's pieces botany
with all his pieces centralized but I
look at him on the camera he looks a bit
phased by something he's just throwing
his hand in the air yeah I don't know
what's going on there I think he was
hoping to win this uh a little bit more
smoothly but hey is that black he's 25
moves in and he's winning in an alkyne
so it can't really go get much smoother
than that but Eric Hansen that's where
his Blitz and bullet experience really
comes in handy he is a weasel he's not
giving this one up without a fight look
at what portnick just did there Tanya he
just took the pawn on C4 and he moves
back to E5 he's in no hurry he's
enjoying his position and he is milking
uh I was gonna say sam Savion no Sam
would not have a position like this Eric
Hansen's clock down to zero I don't see
any realistic chance for the chess bra
here
yeah he's down upon and all the
compensation seems to be with the black
pieces that Bishop on D4 is an absolute
monster F5 you're pointing at and asking
big questions you can't go to C5 you
have to call back uh Knight C3 is not
possible because you pick up the Knight
you pick up the Rook on E2 you have to
go back to D2 and that is coming in the
way of your own Bishop E2 hangs
everything hangs f51 on the spot E2
would have hung there and F5 just won
the Knight on e4 instead board Nick so
solving this tactically okay where is he
gonna go from here though does he want
to go Knight to E1 and is he allowing
Eric Hansen to force the queen trade if
Eric enforced the trade of queens and
get into a pawn down end game I think he
gives himself a serious fighting
transporting missed out five happening
he should still be winning though
it is about narrowing down your margin
for error F5 as you pointed out was game
over Knight E1 he goes Queen C4 no more
F5 right now but this is dangerous you
can't pick up that Bishop on G2 Knight
G2 King G2 but you need to really Rush
with it he goes Knight F3 check instead
so white has to trade on F3 and there we
go I think Queen E2 is a very wise
decision is it fun to defend the ensuing
end game with 30 seconds left no does he
give himself a fighting chance to draw
absolutely I still think Bortnick should
be able to finish this he's still three
minutes up on the clock that is an
eternity for these Ultra professional
Blitz players But Eric Hansen is not
gonna go gentle into that good at night
speaking of not going gentle into that
good night Carissa yep she is coming
very very close to holding a shock draw
against Magnus Carlsen I think we need
to look at Carissa yip's attempt to hold
half a point against the world champion
what a tone that would set in this magic
word for Tanya have been so Stellar in
the PCL thus far
absolutely that would be a big big save
of half a point against Magnus and take
a look at the position it looks like
garissa has done everything right she
has an extra upon but of course there
are a lot of weaknesses in White's
position as well that pawn on D3 now if
white black was to capture the bishop
after Rook takes F4 Magnus can go on to
win that pawn on D3 it might even just
be his best chance in the position
I think there might be B4 in that
position and with every Pawn that gets
traded the game moves closer and closer
to a draw but man having this against
Magnus I can attest a Tanya to the fact
that one of the most nerve-wracking
feelings is when you can sense how close
you are to drawing a player like
I normally would but Harissa she's
definitely close to drawing I think
Bishop F4 to D6 that might be the the
key to the kingdom and she's played it
and if Magnus advances his Pawn to C4
white could force another pair off the
board with the Rook to E5
I'm really scared about the attack
against White's King and The Rook
because we see all of these uh The Rook
on D3 The Rook on E1 it just looks like
the King on H2 can be in a lot of danger
imagine Daniel Black's Knight landing on
G4 and that's a Checkmate it's not no
any ordinary check in the position and
I'm just wondering is Magnus going to
get over ambitious and not care about
that c Pawn not try to advance it going
into the trades that you were pointing
out but instead find a way to activate
his Knight but I'm struggling I'm
struggling for a route to get to G4 yeah
and by the way Alexander vortic has won
his game Hanson blundered a piece wow in
that time pressure now we expected uh
certainly convert not as quickly as he
did so that's a full point and of course
Sam Sevin has won his game against melee
Jade as well abhimanyu Mishra that game
is going to end uh in peace he will be
drawing uh he will be drawing Ivan
search that game should end shortly
let's stick to this huge game a draw
would be Unthinkable and Carissa she can
play rookie five but she can also leave
E5 for her bishop and threaten Rook F6
this is very much a three result game oh
my God I think the should be five might
be winning
it was winning because Rook F6 was
Unstoppable oh
rewind with Bishop E5 because Rook
F6 simply Unstoppable there
yeah
but you're giving a ladder checkmate
with the other Rook coming on to G7
after Rook F6 if the king falls back and
it would have been very difficult for
Magnus Bishop before rookie for and I
think this has turned around a little
bit now because black has got threats of
rookage for Rook D1 check and this can
get very tricky with the central past
pawns combined with the attack against
White's King
OMG oh karissa's gonna be kicking
herself and she's I think losing the
threat of this game it's gone from
winning to potentially losing just a
couple of moves Rook H4 King G1 and Rook
D1 is not Checkmate because white can
block with her own Rook but even if
Magnus trades and plays King F5 there
Tanya these pawns are looking more
menacing than ever Rook H1 is also
possible Magnus plays just that he's not
missing this chance I think he's gonna
go King F5 and Karissa I mean she will
need a perfect perfect game here with
only a minute left what a shame and how
close was Carissa to delivering one of
the biggest results of the PCL thus far
what an effort is one small bishop move
away that's how far she was just from
Bishop to D6 Bishop to E5 with a big
threat of Rook F6 not only winning the
Knight but check meeting ideas against
magnus's King it was missed by her and
now it looks like these spawns are going
to be unstoppable right now the C4 Pawn
is attacked so you can't really hurry
with D3 King D5 there's Rook D6 check
and then coming back but I think Rook F2
and Rook takes B2 might win the game
because then if white takes on C4 then
the king
slides over to D5 this is the same exact
thing because Bishop A3 which has been
played runs into D3 and their Carissa
can simply resign because the pawn is
Unstoppable let's all take a second to
acknowledge that you cannot blame
corroso for mission missing Bishop E5
sometimes you yourself don't even
believe uh that Magnus Carlson could
possibly have blundered and when you get
into that defensive frame of mind it can
be very hard to find a move like that
which turns the tables oh man I think
ignorance is bliss in this case I think
Carissa shouldn't check that game
because I think it'll be tougher to
recover once you find out how close you
were to defeating the world champion
but you can also believe the fact that
you came closely defeating him there's a
lot of positive to take away from that
it was an incredible game really played
by her start up until this point of
course against Magnus it is difficult to
defend these positions Knight D4 D2 big
threat in the air and with that Karissa
throws in the towel she resigns uh but
it doesn't matter for the team result
because the Garden State passes with two
wins and a draw have secured the round
Victory they have secured the round
Victory uh but they are further from
eight and a half than they otherwise
would have been the world champion has
one way or the other by hook or by crook
he's managed to pull out a full point
samsabian has done the same he moves to
eight and a half out of nine in his
first nine games ABI Manu Mishra has
been solid as a rock I think a draw with
Yvonne sarge is a great result for the
passers and they lead by a point things
would have looked a little bit
differently Tanya but if you're the
pastors for James Canty you really can
can't complain about a first round
victory
you're taking
us with
with front they've got Ivan sarish
they've got uh Eric Hansen they've
really mixed up their lineup for this
match but it looks like the Garden State
passes are the ones doing the punches
and the Daniel round two will will the
Canada chess bras be able to make a
comeback there is only one way to find
out a world champion will have to step
up his game or find out if the chess
Bros can erase this one point deficit
when we come back here in the Pro chest
lead stay with us we'll be back in just
a couple of short minutes
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the bow tennis
sisters um
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
chess.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
where does that come from that kind of
even Keel like kind of level-headedness
I mean a lot of people get really big
headed and very very confident when they
like get on a roll and you're just like
I didn't play well
gotta be better next time
I mean you can never relax I mean I do
that so I don't relax I keep the same
amount of energy and concentration
during the tournament
[Music]
foreign
we're back at the pro chess League it's
a delightful Wednesday with two really
really interesting matches one of them
has concluded one of them is one round
in the Garden State passers on the heels
of a comeback week two Victory are now
leading the Canada chess Bros by one
point International Master Tanya sajidev
it's been an impressive display for the
passers in the last five rounds that
they've played Sam sebian is a big
reason why as we reviewed the individual
sports
this is what is amazing about the
protest league right the Garden State
fossils had a disastrous start in week
one and they were so quick to change
things up get the new players on their
lineup and change their match approach
they had a stunning week too and they
stopped against the Canada chess bras
with a win but it's a win with the
smallest margins two and a half to one
and a half Magnus Carlsen got the job
done for his team but now it's time for
the other team members to deliver
indeed it is and round two is upon us
let's review the matchups for this round
in particular Eric Hansen suffered a
very painful loss with the white pieces
against Olex honor boarding it's his
first appearance for the chess for us so
he is gonna have to rebound but not just
against anybody how about black against
a Sam sebian who's got eight and a half
out of nine points melee Jade will I she
committed a big big error in round one
and once again Tanya we talk about it
all the time in the PCL you don't get an
easier pairing just because you've lost
in this case yeah welcome to hell that's
Olex Center Bortnick with the black
pieces
it gets tougher and tougher every round
you know in open events you can go you
lose a game and then you're playing
against somebody who you have a good
shot against here you lose a game and
you're playing against Alexander botnik
who was an absolute beast in round one
taking down Eric Anton Eric with the
white pieces uh lost in a disastrous way
in that one and we've got karisaya
playing against Ivan sarich now Carissa
lost to Magnus which she was a brave
fighter she needs to keep that up and
save some points
yeah I mean she has to do something
similar to what vaishali did in the
previous match where she loses her first
game in painful fashion not the same
thing uh but she came through and
delivered a second round Victory against
uh the top Board of the chess wizard so
we'll see how Carissa handles her task
first and foremost Sam Sevin is going to
be facing Eric Hansen that is the
Marquee matchup of the round we're gonna
keep a very close eye on that and
Samuel's I mean it really you can't say
it enough when you've got someone on
your team who has an eight and a half
out of nine score Tanya you know that
you've built up a good roster you just
know I don't know you just know when you
got eight and a half out of nine what an
MVP he's been for the Garden State
bosses he's really delivered there for
the team and look at him he looks
confident he looks ready to go I think
he's a little superstitious as well he's
been wearing that same jumper every
single week Daniel
I hope it's been through the laundry
machine a couple of times or I'd be glad
that there's nobody in his room watching
him play but chess players they are
superstitious whether it's pens uh or
you know the same jumper or the same
sweater you're gonna do whatever you got
to do uh to put your mind in the right
place well Sam has put his C Pawn onto
the right place he's been playing the
English a lot in the PCL he can play
whatever the heck he wants D4 C4 E4 he
seems to know it all and this is a
Mainline English you can think of this
Tanya as a reverse Sicilian I think
that's a easier way for some players to
conceptualize the philosophy behind
playing this with white it's like a
reverse accelerated dragon
yeah absolutely the structures are very
similar and that's why whoever is a
sicilian player with the black pieces
often answers with the King Pawn move
against the English opening as well
because the ideas are so similar only
the colors are reversed now Sam chooses
the move B3 uh the idea of course is
understandable you want to put that
Bishop from C1 on B2 Target that E5 Pawn
eventually white will put the pawn on D3
bring out the B1 Knight to D2 meanwhile
black needs to start developing Bishop e
Savage shot Castle F6 to defend that
pawn block that Bishop out in B2 and
that's how I'm expecting the game to
develop but I am surprised that Eric is
taking such a long time to make his next
move and he suffered from this in the
first game he was five minutes down at
some point against Alexander boarding we
know how much Eric likes his time
pressure but a 10 plus two time control
often lures people into a false sense of
security you feel that it's a rapid game
I can take my time one five minute think
later you're basically an acute time
person so he develops his light Square
Bishop not to E6 which is pretty
standard but to the more aggressive
Square on G4 I'm anticipating Bishop B2
and one thing that you have to avoid is
a premature E4 because oftentimes you
get extremely overextended with the
center and especially if there's a
bishop on the long diagonal the last
thing you want to do is give that Bishop
more control over key squares on that
diagonal so I'm anticipating maybe
bishop B2 F6 and if Sam could play D4 in
one Fell Swoop then he wants to maybe
that's one of the reasons why Eric got
his Bishop to G4 he wants to be able to
take the Knight on demand and increase
his control over the D4 Square
oh he definitely wants to try and get a
D4 break in the whole position revolves
around activating that Bishop on B2 once
it gets there now Eric's last move
Bishop to G4 also hints at a potential
Queen side castling in some positions
you want to play Queen D7 not only with
the sly idea of Bishop H3 trying to
trade off this strong light squared
Bishop that white has but also
potentially looking at a queen side
castling where the knights and the queen
and the D file it all seems to protect
Black's King in a good way so Bishop G4
it is not the most popular approach but
definitely the most difficult to combat
with white if you're not sure or you
haven't prepared how to respond to it
and he's gotten same Savion to take a
minute and a half in return probably
deciding between Bishop B2 you could
also throw in the move H3 to prevent
black from building that Queen Bishop
battery so a lot of decisions to make in
the early going that affords us a good
opportunity to travel back to the bird's
eye view because all four games have now
officially started including the world
champion who has the white pieces
against Abby monumentra that was a game
I was really really looking forward to
because ABI monumentra has been
incredibly tough to beat he's been
unbeatable in the protest League thus
far I don't think he lost a single game
in his only appearance thus far in week
two but he will have to pull out his
A-Plus game if he wants to hold the
world champion with black so we've got
that game on the lower left a pretty
unorthodox opening there I don't even
know what opening that is uh shall we go
to that game or should we go to the more
advanced game on the top left or melee
Jade I think has a great position
um against Alexander important
I do like the idea of jumping into the
top right game simply because you got
more moves there and of course we'll
visit the abhimanyu Mishra Magnus game
in just a bit but let's take a look at
the botnik position that we've got now
melee Jade definitely a shocking loss
well not the result but the way she
played with white in round one but it
looks like it's a lot more under control
in round two for her I like that unusual
place of the queen on A6 from where it
eyes the C4 Pawn as well as the A2 Pawn
the Pawns in the center we call them the
hanging Pawn structure in chess and when
that is the case white is often trying
to look for an attack but I don't see so
many pieces for botnik to make that
happen uh black meanwhile has
centralized both Rooks placed the queen
nicely the knights in the Santa you
can't really Advance one of the pawns
because it does weaken the square next
to it you're pointing it out if you play
D5 you want to try and get it in at the
right time but it weakens the C5 Square
but you're making the right point the
queen on E2 is also very vulnerable it's
making D5 impossible for the time being
because black simply takes the queen on
A6 this literally is the best Square on
the entire board for Black's Queen
rarely does black have an opportunity to
get the queen to that square when you've
got the hanging Pawn structure melee use
some really really Sleek tactics in
order to get her Queen there and to
trade the light scratch Bishops what
what white wouldn't give to have a light
squared Bishop right here on D3 to
protect the C4 pawn and to make D5 and
C5 a lot easier to achieve so black has
solved for opening problems but now it's
up to melee Jade to hold her own in this
complex middle game what kinds of things
would I be thinking about well there's
the obvious idea which is stacking the
Rooks on the C file and pressuring C4
but there you have to be careful right
if you put the Rook on C6 you've got to
reckon with Tempo moves like 95 and just
because D5 is not possible now doesn't
mean Bortnick has abandoned hopes to
push the Deep on I think he might try to
slide the Queen onto a defended Square
so that D5 once again becomes a
realistic possibility
it does seem like it's going to be a lot
about Tempo speaking of tempos you can
also think about a move Knight to D5
hitting that Bishop on F4 because the
queen on E2 is hanging but I don't think
it helps black because white simply
falls back with the bishop and then what
is your knight really doing there Daniel
yes it's in the center but once I defend
my queen you're once again going to be
running Helter Skelter with it you can
fall back with the bishop to G3 so that
would not have gotten black anywhere
it wouldn't have and instead melee Jade
slides your queen back to V7 and to help
us process everything that's going on
right now is one key piece of the Canada
chess bras Grandmaster Aryan tari the
Norway number two uh behind someone
whose name we will not mention is here
uh he is joining us Grandmaster
aryantari welcome to the show great to
have you
thanks for the introduction Daniel nice
to be with you you guys
Jasper had a tough uh first round so I
hope I hope we can bounce back
we didn't bounce back from that match it
was permanently traumatic and we have
withered away into nothingness so thank
you that was all thanks to your team now
your team is doing okay I think in this
specific round if we could go back to
the bird's eye view
um Aryan I'll essentially give you the
choice but Eric Hansen has a crazy
position uh against Sam Seville there's
another game that you want to look at a
little bit more closely it's your call
wow uh that's that game is really crazy
now Savion played Rook takes C6 he went
for sacrificing the The Exchange
uh we were followed by followed by Queen
C2 uh which looks very dangerous for for
black uh because the king is very open
uh and white will follow up with like
Rook C1 but at the same time Anything
Can Can Happen like like is an exchange
up so uh he has to play play very
accurate
yeah geez Tanya what do you I'm not
making heads or tails of this position
but I don't have any Eric Hanson
one thing's clear some Savion is going
for blood in this one with that
sacrifice I think we should get that up
because this position just as you
mentioned Aryan Anything Can Happen
black has an extra exchange time is of
the essence black trying to get rid of
the strong Bishop on G2 how does it
continue because you actually give up
the C6 Pawn now
well he gives up the C6 Pawn he's
probably gonna follow up with Queen D7
uh because you really don't want that
Queen to be on Beyond C6 but at the same
time I like the decision of changing
that that's uh monster Bishop on G2
because once that knight from FG would
move uh the bishop would be really
really powerful on on G2 so now I think
yeah Queen D7 played and obviously white
is not gonna trade the Queens here
because uh you have to always remember
when you're attacking uh and you've
sacrificed material you don't want to
trade Queens so indeed he plays Queen C2
and now uh probably Eric is thinking
about developing his Bishop to get
connection between his Rooks
yeah Bishop D6 that also over protects
the C7 Pawn so looks like Eric has
beaten back the sort of first wave of
attacking maybe you should start
thinking about launching an attack of
his own with H5 now that the king uh has
lost its main protector as well as one
of White's main attackers the bishop on
G2 uh has been traded but as we uh wait
for Eric to make this decision just
wanted to ask you more generally we can
look at the world champions game uh as I
ask you this question but Aryan having
Magnus Carlson on your team does it make
uh you and the teammates more nervous or
sort of more motivated to make your own
contribution so what is it like to be
the team that has the world champion
uh that's a that's a good good question
uh because uh first time I played in a
team with Magnus that was back in 2015
then I was quite nervous because I
wanted to impress him uh but now I
played in a team with him for for so
long that I I just feel very motivated
because Magnus is a like
uh Real Sports person he wants to always
win uh doesn't matter even which sport
he plays uh and he always
wants to dominate so uh it just gives a
lot of motivation
and we see in in his game look at this
position in his his position looks looks
very very nice we can see the the
structure uh black has double pawns on
F7 and F5 and also the Knight on D6 is
very very strong Pawn on D5 also weak so
I think it's a great position
looks super nice and you you were
talking about uh playing on the same
team Aryan and just the motivation it
provides and his competitive spirit I
want to ask you a little bit more about
being part of the Canada chess bras now
we saw in the first week you guys are
actually playing from Canada how much
fun was that and are you are you missing
it a little bit with the team being
there there were a lot of videos on the
internet of you guys having such a great
time
yeah it was a lot of fun being there I
was there actually for like two weeks uh
and yeah I was very very social not only
like chess uh we were yeah going out to
restaurants uh watching NBA uh going to
bars uh just uh having a great time
great great time at the chess bro house
and also we played the first uh protest
League match against dania's team from
from the house me and Magnus were at the
same house so uh it was cool I really
missed it uh it's like uh two two weeks
ago now
I hope hope we will do the same again at
some point
and wow we've got Eric who was at the
Jazz Bra House of course you were
visiting him who is playing this week as
well uh and as we were talking about his
position we see developments there so
let's get the bird's eye view one more
time and Aryan asked your opinion on the
four boards that we have in front of us
and the one that you'd like to go to
uh yeah we can go to or let's go to uh
maybe bortnick's game against the
uh uh uh oh let's like because we didn't
watch that game uh looks looks quite
quite interesting black is trying to
black is actually sacrificing a pawn
here to get control over the D5 Square
uh-huh no no actually I saw it B5 is
that possible
Knight takes B5 Rook B1 uh Rook B8 E8
looks pretty good for black honestly
maybe rookie five is that a move
yeah
I mean if black can take the pawn on B5
black should be doing very well I think
because uh White is an isolated pawn and
black has like very nice Square for the
knights on D5 he she actually takes that
one so portnick definitely has to prove
something here uh
yeah I guess he's gonna play maybe
bishop C5 is is also move Bishop C5 and
just try to okay it goes through Rook B1
first
okay so we're gonna step up with Rook B8
I don't see another move and she plays
it plays it fast and botnik doesn't seem
very happy with his position
yeah because actually if uh black just
gets to stabilize the position uh it's
very hard for white to to win such a
position because black has a nice Square
on D5 and it's very very solid uh now
actually A4 seems like a seems like a
threat that wins a piece but uh oh yeah
actually it is a threat but because
Knight D6 you can maybe go
I was gonna say queen A3 but then you
can take on B1 so yeah black should be
yeah black should be doing okay here for
sure maybe just move I think
melee Jude probably has to be there we
go great call careful about her clock
situation because no better player than
board Nick it's a squeeze a win out of
his opponent's time pressure but uh
Aryan uh thank you so much for providing
your Insight we'll let you enjoy the
games in peace Grandmaster aryantari big
part of the successful Canada chess for
us team thanks Aryan so much for joining
us thanks for having me before we let
you go I just have one question and I
have to put this in are you having fun
streaming because we've been having so
much fun watching you and is that like
an alternative career or something oh
that's that's nice to hear uh actually I
had my own channel on on Twitch like two
years ago I was streaming a bit uh but
uh then I didn't stream on my own
channel for like I think it's like two
years now but uh when I was at the
Jasper house I was I was obviously
streaming there was uh was a lot of fun
I might uh take it up again
uh yeah I I enjoy it but you know like
having Magnus next to me and playing
Blitz uh you just uh it's easy to feel
feel stupid but it's uh it's it's very
very fun
foreign
and we wish you and your team all the
best
thanks a lot see you guys
see Aryan well we look forward to seeing
Aryan on stream and as we go back to the
bird's eye view I mean this is a great
position for melee Jade and the first
round it was going to passer's way right
now I think the Canada transparas are in
a great spot because Ivan sharich on the
lower right hand side we haven't looked
at that game yet but I feel like he's
just crushing Carissa Yip with just
massive tactical threats in that
position the world champion still has
these things
there's nothing even to talk about it
would just zoom in on that for a second
Carissa might just resign here because
she's losing a piece she's resigned
that's it she's resigned why did she
resign because if we look at this
position after only 19 moves Tanya just
black is CL I thought black was up a
piece here but no she wasn't and
Carissa's just not able to show the same
form that she did in her first game
there's nothing to play for she's down a
piece and a big big win for the chess
Bros
wow and with that they take Advanced
storage defeats karisaya takes the least
lead in round two but of course the
action is on everywhere we do know that
the chess bras are currently down one
round they're looking to make the
comeback and take a look on all our
boards it looks pretty even but the
bottom left is where I'd be really
borrowed the youngest Grandmaster up
against the world champion but it looks
like the eval bar is screaming that
Magnus has done everything right and
take a look at that pawn structure he's
got that extra deep on with the double
pawns on the f file this looks like bad
news the B6 Pawn is hanging so many
tactics actually you can perhaps you
pick up Knight B6 or is that too greedy
I think you most certainly can I think
you at least have to think about it
because if you don't pick up that pawn
if white drops the Knight back then
Mishra could take on D4 and that's
exactly the way that you lose this
Advantage if you're the world champion
he's also up six minutes I think that's
another reason why I'm feeling very very
pessimistic for the youngest Grand
Master in the world So currently Magnus
is up a pawn right black has six pawns
white has seven Knight takes B6 is on
the board and queen B5 here is what I
think Carlson was calculating maybe the
move D5 can be played counter-attacking
Black snipe but I'm not totally sure
that this is over I I don't think it's
over
I mean there's some Precision that's
required here right the Knight on B6
doesn't really have a retreat Square so
you have to find a way to counter attack
you don't want to go all the way to A8
definitely going to get tough then
Knight D4 is hanging that's not a square
your knight belongs in but D5 I like
that move after D5 black can at least
look at picking up that Knight on B6 you
pick up the Knight on E6 white picks up
black picks up the Rook on D1 and after
Queen D1 just watch out don't pick up
the E6 Pawn with your queen there is a
background problem yeah I'll show that
on the analysis board because Carlson
with plenty of time uh is going to take
some time to think about this if he goes
D5 which I think he will Abby Manu has
to already be thinking about whether
it's worth going for this end game as
you said not Queen takes C6 but I'm
pessimistic Tanya because Carlson can
win these In classical chess I feel like
within the confines of a game where his
opponent is 30 seconds Queen the D6
might decide the game immediately
according to the eval bar so I be Manu
has to to keep the knights on the board
I think and try to go after magnus's
night after Knight C5 maybe E6 works out
for white the Tactics get really really
crazy but Carlson has to calculate a
position like this and actually properly
evaluated because he will be down a
piece here if abimanu keeps the knights
on the board never mind it's a moot
point Carlson has made a different move
we go back to the Evolve bar he's
refrained from D5 instead he's trying to
force the Queens off the board that's
given black I think some very decent
drawing chances after the trade
yeah you can share and you can pick up
the D4 Pawn while he decides to pick up
the pawn first queen B5 shade now the
big problem for abhimanyu Mishra is also
the clock Daniel he's down to 25 seconds
the Knight on D4 it's been nice move by
Magnus just sidestepping a discover
check by the night
I feel like that was a really really bad
move by Abby because it's given white a
fully sort of rectified Pawn structure
on the queen side the reason I think
he's done that he's trying to keep the
B6 Knight at Bay but he's fighting a
lost battle because his own pieces are
stuck in mud on the deep I think Carlson
he wins these games you know 99 times
out of 100 I'm not even exaggerating I
don't see Mishra holding this with 15
seconds but you never know we've seen
how good he is in acute time pressure
Roxy it is another excellent defensive
move in Hanover
and Magnus is not pleased with the fact
that he allowed abhimanyu's Rook to
escape out of this pin because if the
Knight would have moved even a rook
trades a nightborne ending would have
been completely winning but Magnus still
dominating the Rooks are alive but the
Rook enters E6 what a move pick up the
G7 Pawn E6 will fall eight seven will
fall the clock will fall the game will
fall The Rook will fall as well and the
game does indeed fall abhimanyu Mishra
suffers his first piece of loss but it's
a good person to lose to if you are
going to lose a win for the chess bras
on two boards they leave 2-0 I think a
huge huge game is going to be melee
Jade's Affair against Alexander boarding
as well as Eric Hansen's game which I
think we have to get to because that
position is getting crazier and crazier
that might be a draw I think wow Nick is
going to succeed in swindling a win out
of his game let's look at this position
where black is down a piece but has that
Monster Pawn on B3 Tanya what do you
make of this is this winning
yeah
if it was black to play Eric would be
winning with the move Queen A2 but he's
one move shot he brings the Knight to D2
just in time to defend that Queen on B2
Knight C4 and the tactic you're playing
Queen takes B3
oh that's the point Eric has missed this
oh yeah Sam misses it he was winning
with Knight C4
Queen B2 right you just oh Queen C2 no
now it takes him no but now takes a
knight B3 and white Russia rushes his
King to the queen side and again Sam
Sevin his time pressure does him in
B2 and black was very much still in the
game he had to keep that beep on alive
there was no way to get to it Queen C2
and now you're pointing out just trade
the queen pick up the pawn on B3 and
that's what you need to do because
otherwise you can't go Queen B3 the D2
Knight is hanging Knight B3 is
impossible the queen on C3 is hanging I
don't see another move you gotta trade
the Queens the thing is if Sam is not
confident in that ensuing end game you
could also lose that if wax King reaches
the queen side quickly so given the
match situation he might actually take
on B3 and he's okay he's declined to
draw here he has taken on B3 he's going
after Henson's pawns on the king side
very often is not about who has the
extra Pawn but about the passers he
needs to not care about winning that
pawn back he has to just start pushing
Queenie one B4 give a check push that
pawn it doesn't matter how many pawns
you lose literally about the passers can
the Garden State passers pull it out
here no I think Savion is winning
because Eric couldn't play B3 in that
position because his King is so much
less safe it's susceptible to the checks
I think Sam is going to be first of the
party with H6 his passer is going to
prevail
it's over Queen C4 Queen C4 was a mate
and now he picks upon
wow this is heartbreak forever
your choice of words
Unstoppable
wow and Bortnick won as well again
he does it again he leaves we see Eric
Hansen on our screen he is devastated
right now just everything went wrong in
that Queen Pawn ending what a win by Sam
unbelievable he was worse at some point
in the middle game we didn't look uh at
it when Hanson was better and Savion
missing the smoother win but going for
that Queen end game and a great judgment
call deciding that it would be tough to
defend with black as we review the
second round score somehow Tanya somehow
the Garden State Masters are able to
hold a tujutai conceivably this could
have been 3-1 or even if melee Jade had
held a draw three and a half very easily
in the chess Prosper instead they will
have to put off the comeback for at
least another round
wow and that if Eric would have managed
to save that half a point against Sam
they would have been back in the match
with a level score but going into round
three they are trailing the Garden State
passes by one round they're down four
and a half to three and a half they need
to win one match to at least one run at
least to level the score but it's such a
small margin this match is wide open
Daniel
wide open Indeed it can change at the
drop of a hat every result has the
capacity to change the course of this
match Magnus Carlson is going to have to
continue putting through a perfect
performance for the chess bras and we'll
see if he can do that and before we go
on break we wanted to remind you that
this month we celebrate women who have
changed the world with our March Bots to
challenge Mary Jackson NASA's first
black female engineer or test your
skills against Ada Lovelace often
recognized as the first ever computer
programmer what lines will Visionary and
activist Malala yousafzai bring to the
chessboard don't miss your chance to
find out as these Bots will disappear
once March ends head over to chess.com
play slash computer or use x Glam whim X
Glam w h i m women's history uh month in
chat to play now so ladies and gentlemen
the chess bras and the passers will play
now no no first play after a short break
we'll give the players a chance to fill
up their coffee cups we will do the same
oh my goodness round three of this epic
PCL match is coming up in just a couple
of short moments
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I
can also change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of
you know anyone trying to develop their
chess game if you do find you know style
of play that you enjoy that's good but
you could also try to sharpen it by
implementing you know on another form of
uh
into your bag as we would call it
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
thank you
foreign
all right well Wednesday clearly isn't
cleaning day for the world champion I
don't even want to comment on what's
going on behind him this we we might
need to talk to the world champion about
that what we will not need to talk to
him about is his play on the chessboard
that is as clean as it always is he's
won the first two games uh Tanya I mean
we can sing his Praises for hours and
hours at the end of the day his resume
and his performances week in and week
out they speak for themselves
cleaning out the competition and that's
all that you need to do when you are the
chest see what you did there
learning from the best here Dania but he
has 16 world championship titles and
that is just incredible stuff Magnus
Carlson is the goat if there ever was
one
he most certainly is and we take his
performances for granted but to go 4-0
in the PCL that's only been done once
this season by someone not named Magnus
Carlson I'm stalling because I don't
remember who actually it was either way
it was way e in his first match for the
Shanghai Tigers who incidentally sit at
two and zero but Magnus Carlsen is just
a cheat code and he's been a cheat code
thus far although he came very close to
suffering a shock defeat at the hands of
Carissa Gibb in round one we review the
overall scores through two rounds as the
Garden State bouncers lead four and a
half three and a half four points away
from that golden eight and a half score
which they could conceivably achieve
with an easy 4-0 victory in this round
what's as easy as that right
absolutely Daniel and as you were
pointing out this is our lineups for a
very critical round three that's coming
up four and a half to three and a half
against the Canada chess bras now what
was boring to me was the bottom two
boards for both these teams they have
barely scored and now in the first two
rounds between the four players of the
bottom two boards they have raked up
half a point and that's just not enough
you can have the world champion on your
team but if the other players are not
performing it's not going to be good
enough it's not going to get you the
result that you want some Savion will be
taking on the very creative Croatia
number one Grandmaster Yvonne sarich
botnik against Magnus that's gonna be a
fun one Daniel
it is indeed all I'm looking forward to
board Nick with black against Magnus and
Magnus might consider playing one E4 if
he does let's see if Alexander portnick
sticks to his guns and plays an alkyne
against the best player uh in chess
history that would be an incredibly
gutsy decision it led to a victory in
round one against Eric Hanson oh my
goodness we've got some exciting games
for you today the Garden State passers
they're gonna try to solidify their lead
we are off with Sarge against sevian who
is 18 and a half out of nine wow black
system okay okay I can get behind this
I like it I like the strategy behind it
I mean he's played the move G3 and it
puts Sam into a thing Sam has been a
Powerhouse of a performance so far so
it's a good thing to get him out of
theory to get him to think early on and
he reaches that and he says I'll play
copycat goes G6 for the fianceato
himself
small correction by the way Tanya um our
very hard-working team informing us that
there were other players including
Hikaru Nakamura who have gone 4-0 which
honestly uh just speaks to how
ridiculously strong the PCL is so Magnus
not uh in as Elite of a crowd as I
thought he was but uh he's still Magnus
Carlson in any case this opening has
gained a little bit of popularity in
recent years I call it the Gluck system
um traditionally the black system
involves being kidding uh developing all
of the knights and then playing G3 and
here's Sarge has deviated a little bit
with Pawn to C3 how unusual is this
Tanya we're almost in some sort of a
perk
wow and with that D4 was the idea but I
liked this move by Sam it stops IT
anticipating a break in the center
already places The Rook on the e-file
hitting that pawn on e4 and now it is
again Sam's turn to think as D3 is
played it's a very slow start Daniel
this is going to be a long strategic
fight and I think that's exactly what
the Canada chess bras want against Sam
Savion who has been a monster so far in
this format but we do have liftoff on
another very critical board so let's
bring our bird's eye view as I do spot
that the world champions game has
started now botnik is the other player
for the Garden State passers who has
been Unstoppable today
he has indeed his alakyne has been
Unstoppable and that is why Bortnick has
repeated the oh my gosh alecai against
the world champion what could be better
than that Magnus Carlson though has come
prepared I have no doubt in my mind
Tanya that Carlson prepared specifically
against the Alex crazy as it may sound
because top players face these
unorthodox unconventional openings
rarely historically they have struggled
sometimes to demonstrate uh as precise
of play as some lower rated Grandmasters
would who face these openings more often
in open tournaments so Magnus Carlson
has done his research he's transitioned
the game into an early end game what do
you make of this is white better are you
impressed with this choice
I don't know
hard to evaluate this it's hard to
evaluate the one thing that stands out
to me that white has a very very slight
lead in development here you can go C3
next pushing out that knight from B4
black has got to develop that Bishop to
G7 right now go shot Castle White has
control of the open D line for now and
that just gives him a slight slight edge
of course black spawn structure is super
solid and no weaknesses it looks very
even and even though our eval bar seems
to say that it's better for Magnus it
makes me think that that has a lot to do
with the control of the open D line the
Knight can land up to C4 as well from 93
Knight C4 this will develop slowly the
one thing we know about Magnus is his
exceptional end game play and I think
we're in we're a technical master class
in this one
we definitely are I think Bortnick can't
procrastinate on this the problems that
he's suffering in these positions his
lack of space his lack of development
are two issues that he needs to address
sooner rather than later because Magnus
once he gets that long-term domination
he is not going to let you go Carlson is
investing a long time into uh his move
11 choice I think he's deciding between
A3 you pointed out C3 or he could leave
the Knight on B4 for the time being and
instead focus on reinforcing his E5 Pawn
which he can also do two different ways
he can play f for or he can try to
address two issues at once and defend by
developing his Bishop so a lot of items
on the menu here for the world champion
his time management is an aspect of his
dominance that we don't talk about often
you almost never see Magnus in crazy
time scrambles and Rapid time control
that's such a valuable skill but here
here he's investing almost two minutes
over two minutes on this move
Daniel while he's doing that I had my
eye out on the bird's eye view and I
would love to get that on because there
is absolute Madness on board on one of
our games and I know you've spotted it I
look at you and we've got to go do that
what is going on on that bottom left
board abhimanyu Mishra against Melly
Jade what are those pawns that it looks
like it looks like there's something
wrong with this position H4 G4 G5 F5 and
both have Castle kingside this is insane
what in the world the last four moves
all look like Mouse lips and yet if you
look at them more carefully they start
to make a certain degree of sense let's
rewind back to normal time move nine the
position was totally normal this is a
standard semi-slave Catalan structure
white makes the move age four okay this
is a little bit off the wall but you're
preventing black from playing G5 you see
this idea sometimes black with H6 okay
whatever and now the craziness begins G5
by melee JG insists on pushing that pawn
cements tonight and Monday says you want
some of that I'll give you some of that
with G4 interrupting the protection of
the E4 Knight this tries to undermine
the F5 Fawn but it comes at a very Hefty
price tag on your mind goodness gracious
I mean I'm still making sense of what
we're just seeing that last move by
abhimanyu G4 if we can just do a you
know like a a loop play of that G3 to G4
Daniel how do you make this move I mean
can you even get this one you could give
me five chances to come up with a move
in this position with white and G4 would
not make that list
is the youngest Grand Master in the
world he knows what he's doing
I was gonna say there's one list he has
made and it's the youngest GM's in
history I think that we should break
this down a little bit let's open up
another analysis board
um and melee Jade has just played Knight
63 the reason the move G4 actually makes
sense to me is because F takes G4 is
Unthinkable and the reason for that is
that Queen to G6 comes with devastating
effect it's not just a Perpetual check
no no no why it's just gonna take all of
black spawns you could have also
captured E6 with check and the secondary
idea of G4 let's make a random move for
black whatever Asics by trading on F5
white is also seriously weakening the D5
pawn and after cdcd you could play
positionally with C4 or you could
potentially move the Knight away and try
to hit that pawn with your Bishop your
king meanwhile Tanya is weakened no
doubt about that but black doesn't have
the Firepower on the king side really to
take advantage of White's weekend King
just yet
what an incredible idea and if we just
go back to this moment there is a line
that I have to show I because I could
not get my head around G4 and I started
looking up what happens if instead of
the trade and I just want to show this
through because it is stunning it will
blow your mind chat it will blow your
mind Daniel if black was to take on G4
immediately white ignores the threat on
the night goes Knight E4 after you
recapture you again ignore the threat on
the night let's say you go f takes E4
here and you go Queen E4
sorry D takes E4 Queen E4 and you ignore
the Knight on F3 if black was to
recapture you give a check on G6 King h8
you pick up the pawn on it six King to
G8 you give a check on G6 Intuit and now
you ignore the bishop hanging on G2 and
you capture the pawn on G5 and white is
completely winning what is this chest
you pick up that Bishop on G2 King G2
Rook H1 made is
Unstoppable you can't fight against this
this is game over this was abhimanyu
mishra's idea and the only reason I was
able to find it is because I had help
here this was unbelievable
and all of this had to be foreseen
because once black takes on F3 two
avoids minor pieces are hanging and
obviously abimano could not be satisfied
with just a Perpetual check so melee
Jade correctly avoids that line that was
definitely worth showing Tanya thank you
for that so instructive a great
illustration of the fact that the open H
file actually can favor white Under the
right set of circumstances melee Jay
trying to make sure that those
circumstances don't become reality she
moves her King up to G7 and says hey I'm
going to I'm going to defend the G6
Square myself right you're not going to
do it I'm going to do it for you says
the black king now black is seriously
contemplating FG and queen D2 is
abhimanyu's last move it's awkward
looking but the idea is clear he wants
to meet FG with Knight takes G5 uh Tanya
but the Eva bar not a fan of that move
and maybe it's because black can now
swing her Knight over to F6 and pressure
that G4 Pawn with a minor piece
yeah but if you do that if you go Knight
F6 then Queen to G5 is hanging right so
switch that and I'm just wondering if
this is Black's opportunity to actually
block that diagonal with a push of the
pawn you could maybe potentially go F4 I
don't know if that's a good move or not
and then follow it up with your idea of
Knight F6 trying to get it to G4 or to
E4
you could also go the other way maybe
Knight to B6 is a more sensible way of
untangling your pieces
um also thank you for correcting that
I'm going to pretend I never said
anything the worst thing would be if
melee Jade plays Knight F6 because then
we'll know who to blame but Knight to B6
I think makes sense because the C4
square is an outpost for black snipe
that you can't sleep on once the pawn
reaches C3 white no longer has the move
b2b3 that's a very typical way of
supporting the C4 Pawn so black could
play on both sides of the board here but
I'm getting concerned about melee's
clock because she takes on G4 she's
already spent half her time in the
position is not getting any less complex
unless of course black trades on G5 and
gets the Queens off the board but that I
think is a clearly worse end game where
black will be left with a very very bad
light squared Bishop I wouldn't do that
well it's happening Knight G5 and now it
is up to melee Jed and she goes for this
end game a picks up that Bishop
everything has been traded off and as
you're pointing out look at that light
Squad Bishop of black The Rook on it
still not developed this is going to be
a tough end game Mishra he needs to show
good technique to take this point home
but I think it definitely favors white
even though our eval Bar says that it's
sort of even that Bishop bear The Rook
on B1 on an open file E4 Central break
ideas the G4 Pawn being weak this looks
like it could be a point for the Garden
State bosses
well I know one man who probably agrees
with you and that is the team captain of
the passers a player a commentator and
now wearing the captain's hat FM James
Canty joins us once again to share his
Insight on the current state of the
match Canty you've got a one point lead
how you feeling right now no you're
feeling good it's not over yet it's
definitely not over but we're feeling
really good we're hanging with them I
like the fearlessness in the kid right
nishra is just you see the face right
there I don't care if you if he's losing
he's going to be looking like this in
the ward with his mean face Nick is
scare you don't look at the camera when
you play this guy right so it could
definitely psychologically mess you up
but no the kid really is like very
strong and it's also very angry because
he lost the magnets in that last game
too as well so he's doing it here I
think we're gonna get to pick up this
point and like we're looking good I also
see the aval bar and Carissa yip's favor
so that's a big game you know Carissa
Yip will hit you in your lips so let's
see if Eric want to get caught with one
right now I don't know but uh it's
feeling good
let's
just picked up the pawn on C4 so would
that be something that might worry you a
little bit with white or you don't care
oh yeah we got the bishop here Bishop
here equal to upon is what they say a
lot of times and also the E6 pawn and F5
F E6 and C4 weak G4 weak what else
everything week of course there's a lot
of things week around in Black's
position so I think we'll be able to
pick that up Black's not developed all
the way so we're feeling real good about
this maybe even get it Rook to the G
file if possible e45 rookie one rookie
four something like that lots of play so
I think we're feeling really good about
this one I'm not working well we have to
go to the Carissa game though because
crazy things are happening so he's just
sacrificed the bishop she's made the
most Charisma of all time Bishop to G6
is what we see on the board we have to
go to that game because Eric Hansen's
position is on the cusp of falling apart
candy this is your style of play I can
see how you assemble the roster
calculation over everything Queen
yeah yeah we in the element right now of
course she did her puzzles this morning
right of course but puzzles for
breakfast lunch and dinner that's how
you do it out here Bishop G6 is a very
nice move here Queen E6 is there Bishop
H5 Pawn takes E5 there's even stuff like
Knight to D5 in certain cases of course
this is what you see I mean there's the
look I didn't even notice it's hard to
even notice that the f file is about to
open Daniel do you see all of this Tanya
Daniel the F files opening
this line this line is going to make you
so happy if Eric actually picks up the
pawn on F4 with Knight F4 saying I'm
talking about it I'm attacking your
phone Karissa is not going to Blink
before she captures that night you take
the Rook back the queen comes into E6
notice that bishop and G6 spinning that
pawn on F7 and Checkmate on the board
right and made on the budgies this is
gross here I mean it's pretty rough for
enhancing enhance is my guy but right
now I'm loving everything Carissa is
doing to him right now so this looks
amazing I mean it's hard to lose this
one with the white pieces here look at
Black's even development or lack of King
safety not there for Black's King as
well I'm gonna count this as the as two
of us that's two so that's six and a
half for the passers
six and a half oh my gosh Harissa is
just coming back stronger every game
Kenzie she came that close to holding at
least a draw against Carlson she was
really one move away and it's really not
all about the results especially when
you're the bottom board it's all about
can you score that one well-timed upset
and Carissa is the perfect person I
think to do that for you oh absolutely
of course as we say Carissa it will
definitely hit you when you live chat
says it as well I see it that's correct
right there on those yep in the feature
it's correct and Eric is getting caught
with a mean one right now across the
across the lips so this one is very nice
from Carissa I'm very proud to see her
go so strong and like attack and not be
you know not be afraid and also even be
discouraged I mean you lost the Magnus
and if she looked at the game you
actually had a winning move Bishop B5
right so you're playing good chess here
just keep up the same mindset and also
the same chest that she's doing and we
we're gonna have some nice wins here on
board four
James Daniel I mean this position I'm
struggling to find a move for Eric that
even keeps the game going so nothing H5
is hanging the pawn on E6 is hanging I
mean he can throw in the topper right
now and just resign there's nothing you
can say yeah I can give you a raise time
that's beautiful that's like correct
exactly yeah get a good time you're a
raise guys that's exactly right
do you see another
well I'm appointing myself the resident
expert in pulling out completely boss
positions I thought Eric should try
Knight takes F4 and King E7 when you're
at least trying to recapture one of
White's pieces instead Tanya I think
what you're saying is coming closer uh
to reality Bishop takes H5 and you're
right I mean white is completely winning
here it's just we've seen so many PCL
games where crazy stuff tends to happen
in time pressure I think Carissa just
needs to avoid thinking about the
significance of this game and what this
would mean for the match just play the
way that she has played in the first 20
moves of This brilliant tactical effort
right yeah just just keep playing right
and then don't worry about who you're
playing just play the board Bishop takes
H5 looks beautiful F6 C5 maybe is even a
move B5 you can throw in there I mean
she's just she's winning we got good
time okay time we need to move a little
bit quicker though 330. I mean that is a
little scary but in this position
you know you're getting a piece you pick
up the piece
thinking
Bishop takes H5 Carissa I think Tanya
she's probably considering Fe but I
would not allow Black's Queen to get
into the game and Bishop takes H5 on the
board but you're right every second is
golden right now and this is the big
moment this is where I think Carissa has
to be accurate maybe Rook takes F4 to
meet for cage five of The Rook up six
that boy's swinging what else do you do
after that yeah that's a nasty move Rick
F4 H5 Rook F6 I don't see a move after
that yeah that is beautiful there
yeah we feeling good here let's go past
this pastors for the win baby let me
look at these other boys Carissa looking
good Niche was looking good
ordnick is holding that's what we need
so we need yeah well let's go back to
the bird's eye view for a second is
Bortnick does he have realistic drawing
chances he's been worse ever since the
opening alakina gets Magnus I respect
the Hustle but it does look like the
world champion putting together some
excellent preparation he's down upon in
the end game is your guy can he hold
this James
I hope so I hope so right because I mean
you can't anything happens with Magnus
here it's very tough I mean you I mean
it's just hard it's just hard it's just
Magnus right so yeah it's looking rough
to the invaluable bar going up and
everything so oh man we just need to
hold this man off somebody hold him off
with that Sam Sam I Am we helping yes
Sam
Sam I think is the big X Factor game
because he's down upon but these end
games are always so hard to evaluate
it's 50 50 right like you see them
drawing you can see why winning this and
Sam doing the right thing I think which
is to exchange as many King side pawns
as possible
yeah
and James what would you what would be
your reaction would you trade on H5 or
will you keep the structure the same way
because for me allowing H4 is also a
little scary uh do you think that Yvonne
right now is going to trade on H5 is
that what Sam is hoping for uh you know
he might even play H4 here yourself is
white which is a strong move H4 and then
you you keep everything connected that's
a really nice thing about it yeah I mean
end games are nice too I don't like
separating the pawn so gh5 I really
don't like I would rather play H4 or
even just pg3 I don't like but I just
don't want to separate these pawns maybe
some weighty moves like Rook B5 to play
Rook B6 and A6
maybe King G3 Rook A2 and then H4
Checkmate your team wins this time they
Never Say Never Never Say Never but uh I
didn't see him
probably Sam has the center control but
this is this is The X Factor game of the
round if you guys can hold on this board
ABI Mani Mishra has it under control as
does Carissa Yip so James as we reach
the climax here in round three we'll let
you enjoy the games uh in peace we
really appreciate your Insight always
great to have the team captain uh
providing uh his thoughts so FM James
can't see you wear many hats will let
you keep wearing the captain hat as we
head into the final stages of round
three Thanks James
Tanya and Dania thanks for providing the
great commentary we'll see you guys
later
thanks fans
wow that was a nice little trick I mean
imagine if Sam actually took this point
with Rook A2 and H4 mid and James with
completely completely lose his mind on
that but and right now it could happen
rookie to check just don't okay it runs
and do a Checkmate the problem is that
you might be allowing white to escape
the little cage that blackstroke has
White's King and instead Sam drives the
pawn down to H4 I like this move because
he's fixing the weakness of the H3 Pawn
if white gets careless black could
conceivably come around and take the
spot and then come all the way back and
stop the a pawn a lot of Tempe are
required to do that so if I'm Sarge I'm
making a Mad Dash over to the queen side
the world champion unsurprisingly has
converted the full point in that end
game so he's on three out of three one
game away from yet another perfect score
I think we should go back for a moment
to the bird's eye view because some
other games are competing for our
attention Carissa yep still with some
work to do if she wants to defeat Eric
Hansen
yeah last time we checked on this one we
felt that Carissa Yip on the bottom
right just looked like so dominating you
you've got an extra piece but like
you're saying you have to show a little
bit of technique and the clock is
running low for both players we see
Eric's got a minute karissa's got about
two and yes winning but there's work to
be done but look at that bottom left
board
in this ending against Melly Jade I like
Black's position here
I do as well I think melee Jade has
great chances now to use her big Pawn
majority on the queen side but I'm man
so many games are reaching the sort of
den you want I think we should go back
to the Carissa game because Eric Hansen
is I think managing to create better
chances than he's had really in the last
10 moves or so and then we can catch uh
the uh of the monument mystery game as
well 30 seconds for Eric this is a game
that the pastors have to capitalize on
especially with Bortnick losing to the
world champion
absolutely it is a big big board for the
Garden State Parcels as well as for the
kind of Chess bras Eric has to try to
save this one they are currently behind
in this match uh he goes with the queen
activity Queen before hitting that
Bishop on B2 hitting that pawn on C4 the
one good news for black is that the king
for now is safe but you always have to
watch out for ideas of sacrifice on E6
threatening a mate on G6 but right now
Karissa needs to find a response to
Queen before the bishop on B2 is hanging
how do you play here with white when
you're less experienced of a blitz
player you get nervous when you go down
below a minute you start feeling like
your clock is inexorably ticking down a
zero Carissa has to avoid uh feeling
those feelings but I think Eric he's
attacking two minor pieces at the same
time Carissa might have to sack the
Knight on C3 and somehow play Rook takes
F4 but there's no question in my mind
Tanya that she's let a Lion's Share of
the advantage slip she's let Eric get a
lot of counter play and if he can get
get this into a Time scramble he gets
good winning chances and look at this
move by Carissa he fearlessly sacrifices
her Bishop
what's going on
with a check and I am trying to
understand it but before I can there is
another sacrifice
said Eric picks up the bishop on B2 and
Carissa playing in Karissa style
sacrifices at night five seconds what is
happening here she needs to make a move
she needs to make a move fast wow Eric's
on D5
CD and maybe Eric could pick up the
bishop with his King I think he has to
try E5 here would lose with 1.2 he
doesn't King G6 running away
what running away
and I don't even see I do see a
Perpetual right you've got Queen G4
check and you can can you repeat
immediately can you bail out I'm not
sure
I wouldn't even try I would have gone
rookie I would go rookie six here and
actually play this for a win you're
right Carissa probably does have the
perpetual and maybe she says okay you
know what I let the advantage slip I
don't want to lose this game but I would
try rookie six because defending this
with seven seconds is stopping Eric Eric
is just heroic defense here and she's
going for it he's going for the win Eric
Hanson he might get Maiden but this is
so dangerous he goes for it but I'm not
sure if this is the path G6 the only
move to keep the bishop defended King H5
was made in one after Queen G4 that
would be game over G6 played Rook into
G6 is in the air Karissa has sacrificed
the bishop a knight will she sacrifice a
rook and the other game is going crazy
too Yvonne Sarge has one he's won that
end game against San Sabian that was
almost indefensible from a practical
standpoint we've got a Time scramble in
our other game as well I think abhimanyu
Mishra is going to take that game
against melee jade look at the bird's
eye view there Carissa Yip is forcing
the draw with Rook takes F7 so perfect
opportunity for us to go to the last
game they're repeating moves that's it
Carissa yep has drawn a great save for
Eric Hanson let's go to our final time
scramble maily Jade I think has let this
one slip against abhimanyu Mishra
wow so it all depends on how this one
goes and Rook to F1 what has a huge
Advantage I think if
it's a huge border he's gonna get made
it oh my gosh D5 there was winning on
the spot instead he's get like blacks
can get active
and now you can she can give it
but she's going for the window but be
very careful if you're melee Jade
because D5 could come at the most
inconvenient
now pick up the C3 pawn and no more G5
ever come back with the King 95 coming
in oh my God C3 C3
okay this is also fine but C3 was even
faster and the Canada chess Bros have
already won the match two and a half but
if melee Jade converts this they take a
three and a half Point Victory which is
massive which would mean that they go
into the final round as the leaders of
this match oh man James must be tearing
his hair praying before I come back here
by measure but this is I mean I don't
see a single waveform to make this
interesting it's over the bond is coming
and this is over before B3 nothing's
gonna ever stop that this is resign time
King D5 just pick it up with your king
she picks up the E5 Pawn also good
enough pick up the E6 Pawn White's King
is far away B2 coming next and that is
it she saves her Rook she doesn't even
give a chance to go into a king and Rook
versus King and Queen and everything's
on the board two queens incoming and
that is it melee Jade does it when it
was most needed a three and a half to
half win for the Canada chess bras oh my
lands and melee Jade it's settling in
there's that smile I mean what a win
what a game it was a time Scramble for
the last 30 moves melee Jade was
struggling in that end game from the
moment they entered into it she got
counter play on The Queen side she
blundered away upon and instead of
panicking and letting the game go she
kept generating practical chances and
she went for it she could have repeated
moves there with King F4 and King F5 she
pressed her luck and the Canada chess
bras the chess gods are smiling on them
not only have they erased the passer's
lead but now they have a lead of their
own and what Elite it is it's a
two-point lead as they lead five to
seven what a round one around for the
Canada chess bras
just incredible stuff there and we saw
Millie did on us crazy
cool cold calmness about her after that
big win and that is exactly what you
need control over your nerves look at
that scoreboard five to seven Daniel
which means the Canada chess bras need
only one and a half points in the final
round to wrap the match up Garden State
Parcels have to win and win big to take
it to playoffs indeed but Canada chess
bras we know what happened the last time
they had a lead they lost 4-0 to the
Indian yogis and Magnus suffered his
first loss of the tournament against
vidit so they're gonna have to put the
memory of that match behind them they're
going to have to step it up the world
champion he can come very close to
ending the match if he wins his fourth
game going for another 4-0 sweep of his
very strong opposition Sam sebian will
try to stand in his way everybody will
have to come up with a huge game for the
Garden State passers everything is so
possible and you are going absolutely
nowhere you will not want to miss the
final round of today's PCL action
between the Garden State passers and the
Canada chess for us we'll be bringing
you that action in just a couple of
short minutes
[Music]
thank you
welcome in to our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
and on if you have to explain that
you're world champion and it's taking
longer than two words there's something
wrong with your friends
but I believe in when we're talking the
60s and 70s even the 80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where
I was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against a man who was
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
with it
my name is Ethan Curry
uh you know we all have nicknames
um Chicago is actually where I'm born
and raised so that's how I got the name
I guess they call me the muscle I'm the
one with the passion
I'm always looking for a good fight you
know evidently they don't make a
difference man that's Checkmate coming
up they don't matter
what I'm trying to do is to let them
know hey we're playing down here in
Houston Texas
and if you come down here help step in
trust me we're going to beat you you
better bring your game
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
Sam Sabian has had an MVP run in the
first two and a half weeks of his PCL
performance for the Garden State passers
but but in the last round he has just
suffered his first ever loss to Yvonne
star's first loss of his life and now
his reward his reward is facing a dude
named Magnus Carlson Sam sebian is
facing the toughest trial of his PCL uh
career thus our time now absolutely and
he seemed Unstoppable until the very
last round where he lost against Evan
Sarge and that's definitely not the
result that you're looking forward to
right before you face a Magnus who on
the other hand today is on a hundred
percent score and we see their PCL
record as well
10-01 for Magnus while for Savion that
is nine wins a one draw and one loss so
far in the event wow this is going to be
a close fight I think this is the one
that will decide who takes this match
yeah to do absolute scrubs who've played
terribly in the PCL thus far and some of
them some of their teammates let's
review the individual scores really
really quickly always said a good run
for the passers although he has also
suffered a loss to Magnus Carlson but
Mishra and Carissa Yip are going to have
to perform well in the final round
because our match score is five seven
and the chess Bros only need one and a
half points to reach that golden number
Tanya as we review the lineups for this
fourth and final round
and there we have it and I have to say
uh Daniel that you know women's day is
on 8th of March but the ladies have been
celebrating today itself with their
performance we saw where Charlie who's
had a power pack Run for the Indian Yogi
so far in the lead and melee Jade with
that last round Victory what a game that
was against abhimanyu Mishra in that
time scramble as well that end game
played to Perfection and this is another
very crucial board Karissa Yip against
malijit Carissa played a brilliant game
against Eric but failed to convert the
poem
well melee Jade is an incredibly
experienced tournament player she plays
a lot of tournaments every year and
that's what you want on your PCL teams
you know 2204 that's her feed a rating
but that doesn't tell the whole story
she's pulled off a lot of upsets over
the board and we've seen in not just her
last game which she won but even the
previous game against Alexander Boardman
where she had a great position with the
black thesis and really only lost thanks
to Alexander reportneck's tactical
Wizardry so melee Jade if even she pulls
off a single a draw here that would
already Propel the Canada chest for us
to within a hairs breath of taking this
match home with a victory by let's say
some guy named Magnus Carlson a car
Carlson he does have I think the
um does he have the black pieces no I
think he does have the black pieces
against sam7 so for Carlson Tanya he's
going to play solvent he's not going to
do anything crazy I think he's okay with
a draw
Magnus is never okay with the draw it
doesn't even matter what the situation
is who he's playing against Magnus is
going to try to create his chances of
course we're not going to expect
anything crazy or rash over the world
but if he gets it he will try to make
the most of it and he plays the French
defense
okay you're absolutely right this is a
as clear of an indication that Carlson
wants to end the match with a win here
as there is and Sam Sabian says you're
going to play a French I'm gonna meet
you at the top playing the main main
line a classical variation here and this
is one of the most topical lines
contested now or several decades from
really the time of Gary Kasparov it's
still popular at the top level
wow this is getting crazy very early on
and of course white has to decide where
you want a castle kingside or queen side
right now Magnus putting too much
pressure on D4 to give time for savion's
King to decide one way or the other
Queen have to play it defending that D4
point and it looks like Magnus is the
first one who goes into a thing out of
the opening well this is a great sign
for Sam sebian Carlson has played the
French a good amount in Rapid
tournaments in the last couple of years
he played it against me in our aim chess
game so this can't be too much of a
surprise for Sam seven who must have
expected Carlson to play some sort of
unbalanced opening and very good
preparation Queen F2 probably not the
most common move if the world champion
already settles into a 30 second think
before completing his Queen side
development
go on to get his coincide
Devin black has got ideas of taking on
D4 trying to put that Bishop on C5 but
there are so many tactical night jumps
that you have to calculate after C takes
D4 Knight D4 I don't know what Bishop C5
is possible or not it looks very
tempting trying to put pressure on that
night we see Magnus on a very messy room
behind him I have to say the chess in
this game is going to be equally messy
it absolutely is it was that was really
smooth and to contribute to your point
CD4 and Bishop C5 is incredibly tempting
but the knight from C3 will slide back
to E2 and the last thing you want to do
is give away this big big clamp over the
D file so you don't normally take on D4
in these types of French structures
until you know a more opportune moment
arises or until white themselves
threatened let's say to take on C5 which
sem Savion could also do
hmm
that explains a lot that explains why a
Magnus is delaying the development of
his Bishop keeping C5 in control doesn't
want to give white the control of the D4
square and Magnus continues to make
improving moves while Sam also not
blinking with the central position both
players make moves that slowly but
surely improve their position at some
point one of them has to take a decision
on the center that's black capture on D4
there's black go C4 because otherwise
you can't put your Bishop on the G7
Square the C5 Pawn is hanging and I'm
not sure if after G6 you want to play
Bishop E7 that just feels wrong
yeah leaving that fee and ketode square
unoccupied guarantees that you're going
to have dark Square problems uh for a
long time by the way we should give a
shout out to Grandmaster nihal sarin who
is an integral part of the Indian yogis
uh nehal played earlier today and the
yogis have made the playoffs the first
team to make the playoffs so he's in the
chat uh explaining some uh some points
about what the players see and what they
don't see when they're playing great to
see me Hall in the chat
this is such a great time to be a chess
player and a chess fan and to be
involved in the game where do you have
the opportunities like that where you've
got nehal joining in after his big match
and chilling with Chuck I love it
awesome well Newhall we welcome you it's
an honor and uh Sam Simeon I think has
emerged from the opening with a great
position Carlson's French has resulted
in I think a flat out bad position and
we have Carlson bias where you look at
his position you always feel like the
position is better than it is here I'm
trying not to suffer from that bias and
I feel like he's worse he's got the
bishop on B7 which is totally hemmed in
by the Knight on D4 which is never going
to leave that square in a million years
and what I'd like to add Tanya is that
if we could pull up an analysis board if
Carlson plays 94 here why does by no
means Force to take on e4 a move like
Queen H4 could be seriously considered
and this is a common idea in these
French positions when he takes D4 always
loses the Queen the queen takes B5 check
blank castles that will then maybe the
exception to the rule would be if the
Knight can guarantee passage to G5 no
matter where black goes I feel like
Carlson is really really struggling here
out of the opening what a game this
would be if Sam Sabian could repeat the
success of his final round of week one
where he defeats Muhammad yarv with
black this guy's a genius
and we see sander on the camp with that
poses complete Focus he knows he should
be happy out of the position with the
opening I saw Magnus with his head on
his hands not looking pleased with the
way things have gone and it's clear why
that weakness on the king side on the
dark squares the attacking possibilities
that white has with the queen coming to
H4 The Rook lift from F3 to the H5
things can get very dangerous for black
very fast it's still a long way to go in
this one and we've got liftoff on the
other boards as well as we we wait for
Magnus to show us what he has in his
mind all the France defense let's get
our bird's eye view up uh because we've
got action on some of the other boards
and of course just a reminder that the
Canada chess bras are leading they're
leading the match currently and need
only one and a half points to get to
eight and a half and secure that match
victory
in the event of a 3-1 win in the
surround by the passers we go to tie
breaks we get to tie breaks then the
matchups from this final round they
repeat themselves but the time control
is shortened we'll have three plus two
and the colors of course will be
reversed but again we're nowhere near a
tie break yet one game in which I think
now the passers have what they want is
board two Alexander boardnick has played
exactly the kind of opening uh that he
excels in it's an Albin Sicilian he's
not only an alkyne expert he's an alapin
expert for many years he's forced
Black's King onto a vulnerable square
and just optically his position looks
really really full with tactical
potential uh Tanya but that might not
tell the whole story because he's also
sacrificed an E5 Pawn which sarich has
just captured he says show me what you
got my friend
Ivan sarich picks it up that's a brave
decision and botnik says I've got my
dark Squad Bishop jumps in with a check
on eight six I was also thinking about
ideas where he could have potentially
put that Bishop on the B2 diagonal but I
think white just did not have enough
time to beat three Knight C3 just a
complete mess probably with a Prevail
instead Bishop 86 I like this move King
to G8 Now The Rook can come to D1 you
can just start putting pressure in the
center it looks like a lot of
compensation once you start really
looking at Yvonne's Queen side pieces
The Rook is out of the game the bishop
is out of the game meanwhile white has
complete control of the center I don't
think there's an immediate blowout or a
tactic that finishes the game but white
just has a long term Advantage you can
go Rook to D1 uh and just build on the
position it's kind of harder to find
moves for black
how do you respond to Rook do you want
to start with well I thought you just
made a great point about there not being
an immediate blowout a lot of players
they panic when they sacrifice something
even something like a pawn and there's
no immediate tactical continuation they
assume that their initiative has fizzled
out absolutely not so I think the great
players are able to accumulate pressure
slowly and they're able to play down a
pawn or even sometimes down a piece for
long periods of time without necessarily
searching for some sort of immediate way
to convert their initiative here
speaking of converting the initiative I
think you have to seriously consider
eliminating the Knight on T5 just
getting it off the board and forcing
black to compromise his Pawn structure
and open up the e-files so for instance
if we bring up an Outsource Bishop takes
D5 if black takes with a pawn such a
natural move right keeping the rook in
the center Queen C3 might end the game
on the spot Rook can't move because you
get mated
we're in The Rook then white eliminates
the pawn
and then Rook takes C5 with a completely
devastating it's carte blanche against
the King this is a big moment Bortnick
has taken on D5 oh my gosh oh my gosh
this is on the spot if he takes back
with a pawn this is easy to miss this is
crazy it's so easy to miss because it's
such a natural move you're hitting that
Knight on e4 and this is a big moment
and Sarge they're shaking his head he
needs to find this tactic that you're
mentioning Queen C3 will be game over he
has to be precise
right now this is a big huge moment for
black and the more he's thinking the
more stressful this is because Daniel
the moment he points out he he figures
out and he does it oh that was he does
he does it the game goes on he's holding
his breath candy was praying for each
hd5 but the game so was boarding of
course now that doesn't mean he can't
play Queen C3 the point is that it
doesn't hit the Rook anymore which gives
black the tempo that he needs to play F6
and there's no Knight takes F6 tactic
because the Rook isn't on E5 anymore I
still like white I still think fortnite
as a raging initiative here but looks
like Sarah's just holding things
together for the time being
yeah even just this position that you're
pointing out right you can go Queen C3
and after F6 you weaken black skin more
you can trade on D5 black takes back on
D5 you can move your knight anywhere on
the board and the point is that look at
Black's Pawn structure it is so weakened
in front of the king the only thing that
you'd have to watch out for is not
getting that Bishop on eight six track
potentially with a move like G5 but
otherwise definitely a lot of
compensation even if there's no
immediate tactical blow and we see
botnik there this entire match I've been
seeing him up talk himself a lot during
every run it's like he's telling himself
to fight and to find something he's
frustrated at times his emotions are so
clear on camera
yeah I'm not sure if he's streaming this
time he was streaming the previous match
he might be he is a very experienced
streamer uh and Alexander portnick he
needs to deliver in a big way for the
Garden State passers now we've got
action on all four boards this is going
to be it just feels Tanya in the early
going that this is going to be one of
those epic rounds where we end up
screaming and yelling uh the last like
two minutes so what else can we see well
Savion still with a clear advantage
against Carlson who's sacrificed upon
and developed uh some significant
counter play on The Queen side that's
top left of your screen you can see
Carlson's Apon is running up board and
he is trying to undermine White's
control of his own C3 upon if he opens
the C file he gets serious counter play
what else can chose you rhyme
about that particular position is
threats on the H file you have to watch
out for a doubling up of the rook and
the Queen and it happens a rook lift we
see with a devious idea Rook H3 or you
can even put your queen on H6 first and
then go Rook H3 really just stopping H5
but I would be terrified with Rook H3 H5
G4 coming onto the board that would be
absolutely disastrous for Magnus Magnus
has got reasons to be worried here he
does and I don't think anybody will
blame us if we go back to this game
because this is unfolding at a Breakneck
Pace it just feels like the result of
this game could decide and imagine at
this point Sam sebion would be
disappointed with anything other than a
win given the position that he got out
of the opening a win would give such
good chances to the passers for a
miracle comeback in the last round so
does Carlson ignore and play A3 or maybe
he brings the queen back to d8 sort of
Carlson style but that could merely
exacerbate the situation after Queen H6
Tanya yeah
I mean this is a dream position right
that you can get again against Magnus
when you want to win for yourself and
your team as well Rook D3 on the board
and you pointed out this idea of A3 I
love it because if white was to pick up
that pawn then suddenly we can see black
strip jumping onto C3 and adjust
neutralizing White's request it is on
the board you called it I was a great
move Daniel Magnus finds it as well Atri
on the board and I'm trying to analyze
what happens if Sam goes all in
threatening a checkmate with the move
Rook H3 will he be in time Rook H3 H5 G4
and you can perhaps just take on B2
because G takes H5 Rook C3 and the world
is exploding
and so is my head be still my Beating
Heart Sam sevin's heart is probably
beating uh a hundred times a second
because he's done with three and a half
minutes and when you're playing against
Magnus your your time like just it
evaporates you don't even notice how
fast it takes down to zero and somehow
Carlson has left himself with over half
his time so I think the clock might be a
huge huge Factor here Rook H3 is the big
idea for Savion and Tanya there's a
crazy line here where if you try Queen
H6 if we could bring up an outboard
really quickly while Savion is still
thinking after Queen H6 a b Rook H3 it
might seem like Checkmate is inevitable
but Knight F2 check turns the tables
instantly because it either picks up the
Rook or if you eliminate that night
black delivers back range checkmate with
his newly minted Queen so so many
landmines that cebian has to avoid
stepping on here
Queen 86 is so tempting stopping H5 and
it loses on the spot as you're showing
us these tactics A3 really changes the
Dynamics in the position and forces Sam
to go into a thing and it makes me think
about that last move that Sam made right
The Rook lift which was so natural and a
move that I really liked as well with
the idea of building up the attack with
A3 on this other end of the board the
king is on one side Magnus doesn't care
he finds a resource in the opposite end
and it looks like it's good enough the
eval bar approves as well Magnus the
king's a Magnus way I love it and as
we've been discussing another minute has
elapsed from Sam's savion's clock he now
has two minutes I think if you're Magnus
at this point you're probably thinking
about winning this game you're thinking
about playing for a win the evil bar
shows zeros but that doesn't mean any
doesn't mean the game is guaranteed to
end in a draw maybe there's some sort of
a Perpetual that can be found after Rook
H3 H5 I don't see what it is though and
if White bites the bullet and takes on
A3 then magnus's pieces stream in down
the C file he gets a past D5 pawn and it
just feels like he's taking over this
game
it really does right and I mean he's
thinking he's thinking and he's down to
a minute and a half and it's really not
easy he has to find a resource he has to
find it quick and it's really easier
said than done the more we look at the
tactics that exist in the position the
harder it is to find a move he
eventually goes for the line with Rook
H3 and we're seeing this being played
out H5 captures on A3 Magnus will go
Rook C3 I'm expecting trying to trade
off this Rook on H3 but Magnus goes into
a thing which makes me wonder what is
the alternative
yeah well there's Rook C3 Knight C3
would have run into Knight C6 and 97 so
Magnus correctly sidestepping that line
and the problem for Sam is that he's
just burned three and a half minutes on
Rook H3 and now the hardest part is
still ahead he's trying desperately to
engineer kingside counter Play What a
move by seven
I think he's gonna sack the Knight on F5
Sonia it's coming wow it's happening
he's gonna try to go after Black's King
there
it's going to be after eat X5 either
Knight F5 or the other sacrifice that
comes to mind is ideas with E6 just
really opening up the king's side and
Magnus doesn't want to go into any of
that he keeps the pressure on the clock
quickly Retreats with the Knight
bringing it to the defense but now white
does have the option I was going to say
to pick up the pawns but then I realized
the default light is hanging oh gosh
this is vintage cagnus Morrison right
here 94 without thinking how is he able
to play so quickly in these positions
you look at the board like he must have
made a mistake he must have overlooked
something but the more you look the more
hopeless you feel Sam is under a minute
if he takes on G6 Tanya Carlson will
take on T4 his King is kept safe by that
well-placed Rook on f8 which is such an
integral defensive piece and there are
smother made ideas once the queen lands
on D4
39 seconds
you've got to make a move and if you
move the Knight you simply pick up the
F5 Pawn with no compensation and as our
chat is winding out it is the clock as
well which is against Sam in a very
difficult position he's trying to look
for some way to save this game maybe he
can go with fe6 he doesn't he goes
Knight C6 and this is a huge huge
blunder
this is a blunder and the reason is
Queen takes B5 Carlson took another two
seconds on that move now there's a check
on E7 Sam is painting all his hopes on
that Chuck but King H7 steps
watch out Daniel the F1 Rook was hanging
which is so easy to miss queen F4
defended but G5 you're pointing out
against any check on G6
which is he takes F5 but then maybe he
takes with the Knight
I think then you can take the Knight and
hide away on G7 you call to Tonya the
problem is that white is tied down to
this Rook so the mobility of the queen
is restricted and the Knight on e4 is
such a good defensive piece because it
guards the F6 Square once the king
reaches G7
0 seconds for some
20 seconds for some and it is a
difficult position on the
Twitter attack in this position for what
wow Magnus has turned this around it's
just unbelievable what he does more bad
news for the passers the chess bras are
in control on bortnick's board where
he's down below a minute uh and Sarge
now has a better position Carlson should
be able to finish this one off uh let's
stay here for the time being and I will
also point out that melee Jade will a is
I don't want to say crushing Carissa yup
but she's got an incredibly big
advantage of Bishop pair and attacking
chances but I think this game will end
quickly
side no problem no she's seven E6 has to
be tried
hangs
okay so F6 I think is maybe the most
cold-blooded response
it does look like the way to go right
you don't want to allow white spawn on
f70 it does it F6 just keeps everything
under control and look at notice how
that bottom F6 and the pawn on H5 just
stop all the checks Rook C1 and because
there's a background witness rookie what
a
what of this is and who's getting
checkmated now he makes it look so easy
Tanya we see these moves of course Rook
C8 right but it's crazy how quickly he
finds them Queen to E2 I think ends the
game almost officially because it opens
up the threat of Knight F2 at this point
it's choose your pick choose your poison
and choose how you want to kill your
opponent here if you're black
and Magnus is doing just that he's got
three minutes he wants to go also for
the beauty prize which would be amazing
if you could just sacrifice the queen to
deflect that Queen from F5 because
Knight F2 would be a Checkmate but I
think queenity just keeps it simple and
strong and oh man that might be the
match because Bortnick has officially
lost control of his initiative he had
such a promising position but he was not
able to find a way to capitalize on it
and sarich could basically end this
match assuming that nothing insane
happens on Carlson's board and I'm
pretty confident that nothing will uh he
could just leave his Queen on D3 Tanya
you called it I think he could play Rook
to C3 for instance uh we're gonna go
back to Carlson game because I think
this is going to end momentarily in just
a couple of moves but portnick might be
losing as well
and this is why Queenie do was so much
more tempting because you have a real
threat of Knight F2 as well but he does
decide you can actually go Queenie to no
you can't go queenity because Queenie
you actually keeps it defend it but I
like your move Rook C2 just deflecting
that Queen threatening Knight F2 and you
know he's thinking I was I was gonna say
Carlson likes to go King f8 something's
Zen here but he's just finish it off
Magnus Knight D2 I think ends the game
but we've seen Carlson G3
that's true oh my gosh king f8 queen D6
Carlson has struggled a little bit in
the technical phase of the game in tata
steel but he's up a full peace for
goodness sake even Queen E5 the simple
Queen E5 ends the game
that's it he goes through 3.5 just pick
up the E6 Pawn it's the big pawn and he
does it and A4 it doesn't matter there's
no compensation Black's fingers
absolutely safe there is not a single
check on the board Queen A7 doesn't
really get you anywhere
he stops it anyway that's it let's go to
the boarding game I think we should go
to the bird's eye because it's obvious
that Magnus is going to win this game
and so the scene shifts over to
Alexander bortnick's game which where he
has been able to somehow stay alive look
at his pieces both his bishop and his
Knight are hanging but neither peace can
be captured sarich has let his Advantage
slip
well I don't forget that is you pick up
the bishop then white jumps in with
Knight F6 picks up the bishop and
delivers a fork and that would actually
turn the result around you can't pick up
the night the queen is hanging the queen
needs to move somewhere Daniel to defend
that Bishop on F6 he does it the Bishops
are traded off and we see Yvonne saritch
there just breathing a sigh of relief
this might be the decisive game all
sarich needs here is a draw and that
might be what spells Doom for the Garden
State passers Rook to d8 here I think
might force that draw to happen instead
he checks on A1 I don't know about that
move King H2 Queen F1
there's F3 oh what tactics
we need five checks
and important counter blunders there was
a win there for white but I don't see it
I didn't see it but don't you end up in
a second seat we have no idea
yeah Rook C6 looked very tempting and
bringing the queen to D7 but instead oh
my gosh what is this you got it it's
over trapped ABS G and the game is over
he's trapped on G3 what was Bishop G3 I
ha I will have to show the win the
boarding had it was a ridiculous
sequence and he could have turned the
tables and if the passers end up winning
their other two boards this will end up
as the decisive game Sorry should repeat
Tanya sarit should repeat moves here if
he's aware of magnus's result because
that immediately bags the match
immediately
oh and we can see botnik he is
devastated right now and it just depends
I think storage is potentially checking
the match result right now he has a draw
in his hands and if that is match
Victory he can he will go for it it is
the smart thing to do and he's figured
it out Daniel I think we're gonna have a
repetition on this one as ridiculous as
it may sound right so repeat moves you
are not an individual player you are
completely a team player you sacrifice
your own results for the sake of the
team results the match is over and the
chess Bros have pulled it off before we
go to any other games let me show really
quickly what Bortnick missed in this
position Rook takes Bishop what the heck
is the point of this move well it's to
play Queen A7 to D7 and hit the Rook why
is that dangerous well The Rook can't be
defended if you play King f8 Bishop D6
throws the king back to G8 and Tanya if
you move the Rook it's complete carte
blanche against Flex King five it's just
totally crushing with a bishop and the
queen combining to Massacre Black's King
side Forte could have won this in one
move but how do you blame him for
missing Rook take C6 with two seconds on
his clock
happens to the best of us clearly Rook
C6 would have just changed a lot in this
match but instead Yvonne started making
that decision at the very end survives
that tactical shot missed by botnik and
goes on to go for the repetition with
suits the chess bras just fine we still
have actually not on one of the boards
but the Canada chess bras have taken the
match they have taken the match and they
might also take one of the other two
games melee Jade is I think she was in
control of that board but Carissa I
think has actually taken over the
initiative and might win her game and
ABI Manu Mishra is better on his board
so that result between boarding and
sarich might end up actually influencing
directly the results of the match but
again it's nobody's fault that's not how
it works and I'm going to switch over to
Abi
is going to win
and I think Carissa is going to win as
well
wow and the reason this is so winning
for black is because that H Pawn just
look at it it's Unstoppable it's as
simple as this h3h2 moved the Rook Queen
the pawn win the game that Bishop on E5
is an absolute monster H2 anyway and
then Rook C1 check it's a pretty tactic
that ends it Sam is going to resign uh
Eric is going to resign I think after uh
maybe not Rook H3 still in it no that's
it and now rookie one that is so classic
you've got to take with the pawn here
Rook to A1 yeah but this is also winning
this King B3 Rook B1 is just game over
he's gonna hide on G8 and he's gonna go
Rook to me one check wow amazing
technique there incredible indeed
okay we can go out of this game we will
trust that Abby Monumental has the
technique to win it and there we go
resignation
that leaves us with one game oh what a
heartbreaker this will be for the
passers
an absolutely heartbreaking moment here
with that with that jaw in the Ivan
sarich and the botnik game that just
means that it doesn't matter what the
result is the match is already decided
what a win by abhimanyu Mishra but it is
too little too late
it is and again if fortnite had won that
uh then Karissa Yip with a win in this
game would have forced a tiebreaker in
this match and what's crazy is karissie
has taken over this game she is now
winning with the black pieces against
melee Jade I think she's going to take
this and drive this all the way home the
passers are going to win this match but
not by enough of a margin
oh um win this round
Queen D4 it hits that Bishop on D3 Chris
and troll you're controlling the f file
your queen is centralized look at that
Knight on C5 you're hitting that pawn on
H4 oh fake it the G6 Pawn is defunded
pick up the H4 Pawn you could trade the
Rooks on F1 everything seems to be
working for black
yeah Queen takes H4 I don't know what
charissa's waiting for take that pawn
because G5 will fall consecutively and
then black will just play H4 this is
borderline resignable but melee Jade
with Queen E3 oh but then C4 pulse oh my
gosh
wow and it's really good news for black
that this Knight on C5 also defends all
time to play with the queen coming into
E6 the Knight on E7 defends the G6 Pawn
the Knight on C5 controls the E6 Square
everything is guarded meanwhile black
picking up pawns the king side falling
apart where is on the brink of Victory
uh the Canada chest bras have already
taken the match and the reason you can't
assign blame right it's easy to assign
blame but remember that this match is
the product of all four rounds so you
could just as easily look back and say
well I'll be Mani Mishra lost that
position to melee Jade that game could
have been a draw Magnus Carlson right
could have maybe drawn his first round
game against Carissa Yip so really you
should avoid looking just at the last
round and saying oh it's important
Nick's fault because he didn't win that
game no it's a team effort and
everybody's half point and zero points
matters the same amount whatever round
it occurred in but this is over Carissa
is going to bring the passers oh so
close but not close enough
what a close match this ended up being
nice move that by Carissa just three
just treating of the queen
uh it is just it's just heartbreaking
that this point just doesn't count for
anything in this match yeah yeah
or is coming upon us are pushing this
place itself E3 even E3 might be the
easiest way to win oh she's gonna push
the G Pawn and lock up the game
oh nice and you pick up the bishop yeah
and Bailey resigns
the game has ended it's not close enough
Tanya by one half of a point
is such a close match and what a
turnaround this one has been starting
from how Canada chess bras were the one
on the back foot uh with the Garden
State passes taking the early early lead
in this match but then it all turned
around in round three and Magnus
Carlson's team takes this match with
eight and a half seven and a half such a
close fight oh my goodness what a
scintillating match and a valiant
comeback attempt to buy the Garden State
passers Sam Sevin though he drops off in
the last two rounds his perfect PCL run
comes to an end it comes to an end
understandably at the hands uh of course
of the world champion and Yvonne Sarge
the two strongest boards for the Canada
chess bras who win their first round
they suffer a shock defeat at the hands
of the Indian yogis in week two and now
here in week three they got their act
together and Magnus Carlsen once again
the hero of this match where would the
chess Bros be without Magnus I'll tell
you where they'd be at om3 instead they
are sitting pretty at two and one and
ladies and gentlemen we will have a very
special guest for you on the other side
of this rake we'll have the world
champion who's once again run the table
with a 4-0 result Magnus Carlson will
join us for an interview here at the
grocery don't go anywhere we'll have the
world champion here and have him share
his thoughts in just a couple of minutes
foreign
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game
fantastic okay is chess a sport
absolutely very competitive known
worldwide uh battle of wits to the
highest degree I imagine this is the
best interview I've ever given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
a chess a sport intellectually yes okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my heart that's a great comparison
hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay on poisson
hey that guy was walking on passant
chess chess chess like the game chess I
can beat you in chess if you beat me
I'll give you ten dollars ten ten if you
beat me I bet
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I don't know what you're doing
I do know what I'm doing
I'm doing it's all right that's all
right I don't know what I'm doing in
life
hey
all right bro this Checkmate oh fools
mate who's made bro I will unbelievable
you got 30 seconds for me quick
interview come on you look like a chess
player you play chess I haven't played
chess okay when I say chess what's the
first thing that comes to your mind
winning
of these three things one of them is
real
chest dancing chess climbing chest
boxing chest climbing chest climbing
chest dancing climbing chest climb just
chest boxing chess boxing you nailed it
okay am I right for real you nailed it
seriously yeah of of the two of us one
of us is a World Chess boxing champion
which one do you think it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
World Box music no he's not I mean he
does get he tried to hit another guy
earlier so
oh my God she didn't even hesitate from
now on will you stop making me do things
in New York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
[Music]
thank you
he is a bad man Magnus Carlson the world
champion goes 4-0 for the second time in
the PCL leading to a second Canada chest
bras Victory Magnus joins us for an
interview we appreciate it Magnus how
does it feel to go 4-0 yet again
it was good to to help the team in in
this way
um
but I gotta say that um
the whole team today did a really good
job
except except Eric he sucked uh and he
almost caused the match cost us the
match so shame on you Eric uh but uh
uh yeah even as
um
I think he was a very very strong
performer the the last time he played
for uh the chess Bros in the approaches
league and uh melee got us an extremely
important win today as well so that was
really really good to see them do well
um as for me I think I played
uh
pretty mediocre chess but uh that's fine
uh I got I got it done uh especially in
the in the last round I think I was just
busted but uh
um some positions where you sort of
well I think at some point he made it a
bit difficult for himself in that he
either has to give mate or he's just
worse and in in those positions even if
your position is good you can easily
make mistakes
hmm
Magnus you mentioned about Eric's
performance there now he was your host
while you were in Canada aren't you
supposed to be nice to him
well I'm I would be nice to him if he
did well but this was
uh this is uh no but
um we had some uh we had some
discussions uh after after our last
couple of matches
uh and uh we thought
that's getting even in would be really
really uh important and then so I I have
to say he he made a really good good
choice there also considering the fact
that he brought in melee who got us an
important uh important Point
um unfortunately that meant that uh he
had himself instead of instead of our
end but
that's the way it is sometimes
um but yeah I'm happy that we uh that we
won today and we stay we stay alive
you do indeed Magnus the French is the
butt of a lot of jokes but you played it
in the last round to defeat same seven
would you say that if you're ranking the
ways to guarantee winning chances and an
unbalanced position with black against
E4 would you say that the French is
among the top ways to guarantee some
sort of intrigue against E4
foreign
I would say against really well prepared
opponents
um it's
um
it's generally hard to generate chances
but you are right in the sense that
especially if you're not well prepared
as black as I clearly was in today
then your position from the opening is
probably going to be pretty bad but it's
going to be a comp as you said it's
going to be a complicated sense
uh you know complicated kind of bad
where you can get counter chances and as
as I explained earlier yeah
um
this at some point yeah I had to have to
either get give mate or lose and that
was kind of the scenario I was hoping
for it's a little bit like playing the
king's Indian in in that sense or at
least some of the
server more double-edged variations of
the king Cindy or you know that either
as black you're either
um
getting uh you're even giving mate or or
you're gonna listen
the French is
I mean you're not giving mate of course
but you take such strategic risk in in
both openings but you know that there
are chances as well
find some interesting opening choices
there now the chess bras won by the
smallest of margins eight and a half to
seven and a half but it wasn't smooth
sailing after round two uh you were down
your team was down five to three what do
you think switched and what turned
around to take this match victory
but I think this is the good thing about
the format that
um
you you have this rating constraints
which means that almost every game is uh
so every match is going to be be close
like winning right blowouts is super
super hard
um
I think uh I mean the the key one of the
keys was
I don't know I I don't know what the key
was really I mean we got one when went
from melee which is really is really
huge and then even started to win games
but what exactly happened
you know why that happened in in the
first uh in in the third round rather
than the first two it's hard to say
Magnus as we look at the top teams in
the standings of course the Indian yogis
they won again today uh to be the first
team making it to the playoffs we've got
the Gotham Knights and the Shanghai
Tigers looking at those teams Magnus how
do you feel about the chess bras chances
to make it in the playoffs and what are
the sort of big things that need to
happen is it Eric playing better is that
the sort of the key to the kingdom
yeah I guess it's getting like good
performances from from everybody on on
this if we if we do that we can beat
every single every single team
um and uh I'll be curious to see who we
play and uh
in in the uh
in the next round but for instance like
I've obviously
I may have
on a good day been able to see made in
three against Reddit in the last in the
last match but even then we'd have lost
I lost them after we we really need
everybody to
um to Poland that's that's hard on every
any any given match but at least now
we've scraped a couple of wins so
we have a chance
Max can you also just tell us a little
bit about what's it like to play for the
chess bras and how involved are you in
the decision making for the lineup of uh
of every week is that something that you
leave to Eric or is that something that
you're actively involved in
uh well I've been discussing it a little
bit with Eric but it's it's his choices
he makes the decisions
um
he's the the manager the bus The
Godfather so uh I mainly just
tune in once a week and try to play
good enough moves to win a few games
Magnus uh feature chat question from
dizzy bagel94 how does the PCL compare
to a normal tournament is this uh sort
of a fun tournament for or are you
viewing this just like any other aim
chests or any other online rapid
tournament you've played
no it's not fun well it can be fun
sometimes when you're when your
teammates are doing well but mostly it's
a little bit frustrating
especially after last week I was
thinking like I'm never ever gonna play
a match again
uh and here you are
but uh
no it's it's uh it's obviously it's
always a different because you cannot
control your faith in the same way
hmm
all right we've got one more feature
chat question for you and it's by Dan
plays chess and he's asking Madness is
there anyone you've played that
surprised you with their play maybe
somebody previously was not on your
radar
I cannot say that I've been following
the other matches to
um
intently
in terms of how people have played
against me
uh yeah not really uh I mean
some people have played really well some
others
haven't but
um no I cannot say
I cannot say that I don't have
well Eric's surprise has surprised me in
negatively so far but
well Magnus it's been a pleasure
watching your games you've gone 4-0 now
twice so congratulations on a
well-earned victory for the Chatsworth
we'll let you take your well-deserved
less rest we look forward to seeing you
in the next match
thank you always a pleasure
Magnus
he needs no introduction to Anya eight
and a half seven and a half the final
score this could have gone either way
none of this could have happened without
the heroics as usual of Magnus Carlson
we are just so spoiled by our we just we
are used to this degree of Excellence
which is ridiculous honestly
I mean look at that score line right
Magnus constant four out of four one
more time Yvonne sarich with three
points those are some Heavy Hitters for
today and let's take a look at how what
this means for our standings with the
Canada chess bras winning their match
against Garden State bosses
wow well we've got a log Jam at the top
only one team in the playoffs thus far
they will be joined by either the
Shanghai tigers or the Gotham Knights
who will be facing off in the next PCL
match talk about fascinating we're gonna
have Wei who's gone 4-0 and Hikaru
Nakamura who has also had a perfect run
they will presumably be playing and so
many of these teams who now sit at two
and one Tanya and even I'm looking at
mgd1 don't fall asleep on those teams
because they can absolutely make a run
and make the playoffs so nothing has
been decided just because the yogis are
the first to make the playoffs
although yogis definitely have a lot to
celebrate they have done their job so
far in this main event of the protest
League they booked their spot in the
playoffs but of course you've got big
runs coming up and also not just these
things we've got Blitz the Croatia
Bulldogs the Garden State passes it is
all about getting those three match wins
and then you've got your shot into the
playoff that's what the teams are
looking at with some of the teams are
also facing elimination
well one team only has been eliminated
but the Bears and the archbishops are
staring down the barrel as are passers
the copy bars and the maniac shrimps who
have to be perfect if they want to stay
in the PCL well speaking of perfect
we've got a perfect week of action for
you ladies and gentlemen tomorrow you
have more action to look forward to so
your PCL withdrawal is not going to last
long it's the same schedule with action
starting at 7 30 a.m Pacific Time bright
and early with the Knights facing the
Shanghai Tigers uh a second team will be
in the playoffs after that match
concludes and the two one-on-one teams
the blitz against the Croatia Bulldogs
face off immediately afterwards around
10 a.m Pacific so man man man we've got
more awesome stuff coming for you start
time 7 30 a.m Pacific 10 30 New York
time tomorrow morning
but Tanya the time has come for us to
take our well-deserved rest what a day
of action we've had today
so much action so much fun and drama and
big fights and turnarounds and Neha
Serene in our chat as well what a day
it's been Daniel it's been an absolute
pleasure calling this out we had Magnus
join us as well he's on a four out of
four today's Victory but on an overall
streak as well in the protest League we
have our first participant in into the
playoffs so much action loved every
moment of it me too uh it was incredible
me too Tanya it's an honor to commentate
with you this was such a pleasure five
hours went by in a Flash and I'm sure
they'll buy in a Flash tomorrow as well
I'll be bringing you that match
alongside Grandmaster I'm on Hamilton
but for now I'd like to thank everybody
in the chat for supporting your favorite
players and your favorite teams the PCO
would not have this level of fight
without you or producers Bic and Hala as
well as our entire amazing team at
chess.com who works so hard behind the
scenes uh to help us make this the best
show that we can make it and now it
isn't
we say goodbye from Wednesday here at
the pro Chesley UA will see you tomorrow
bright and early at 7 30 a.m Pacific for
the Gotham Knights against the Shanghai
tigers have a great rest of your
Wednesday so long
foreign
[Music]
me
foreign